ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE Þ STREET BUILDING, AND WE
HAVE A BIG AGENDA. SO I'M ASKING
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO COME TO THE HEARING ROOM SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN THE HEARING
WITH A QUORUM. WE HAVE 324
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA. A
LITTLE BIT LIGHT, TWO OF WHICH
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð PASS
MOTION. SO THE REMAINING ITEMS
WILL ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. AND WE HAVE ONE
SUSPENSE FILE BILL THAT WILL
HAVE A PRESENTATION. BUT THE
AUTHORS FOR THE REMAINING
SUSPENSE FILE BILLS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IT MEANS THAT THE
AUTHORS WILL NOT BE HERE.
HOWEVER, WE WILL STILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH AND EVERY ITEM, EVEN IF THE
AUTHOR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
AB 2498 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CZIBOR. AB 2893 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WARD. AB 2903 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HOOVER AND AB
3061 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY
ARE ALL STILL LISTED ON THE
DAILY FILE, BUT THESE MEASURES
WILL BE RESCHEDULED TO OUR NEXT
HEARING. IN ADDITION, AB 2618 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN WILL BE
REPORTED DIRECTLY TO THE FLOOR
PURSUANT TO RULE 28.8. SO WE
WILL NOT HAVE TESTIMONY ON THAT
BILL TODAY. SO IF YOU'RE HERE
FOR THAT BILL, THERE WILL IT
WILL NOT BE CALLED AND THERE
WON'T BE TESTIMONY. AS USUAL,
WE'RE GOING TO EXTEND A COURTESY
TO ANY MEMBER THAT SHOW UP, ANY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT SHOWS UP IN
PERSON AND ALLOW THEM TO PRESENT
THEIR BILLS OUT OF AGENDA OR
ORDER AS THEY SHOW UP. SO IF
YOU'RE HERE ON AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BILL, AND IT'S TAKEN OUT
OF ORDER, PAY ATTENTION BECAUSE
IT IT WE COULD END UP MOVING ON.
IF WE DON'T SEE ANYBODY GETTING
UP TO TESTIFY. I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU TO, WELL, I WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT THE WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED IN THEIR TESTIMONY TO
THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL,
AND WE'VE ASKED THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO DO THE SAME THING,
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY IN YOUR COMMENTS
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING
ON ON THE BILLS BEFORE US, WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO
MADAM ASSISTANT, PLEASE, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. HERE.
CABALLERO. HERE. JONES. ASHBY
ASHBY. HERE. BECKER. BECKER.
HERE BRADFORD. SATO. SATO. HERE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. NOW WE CAN MOVE ON TO
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY. SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE ON A
TIMELY BASIS. AND WE'LL START
OFF WITH THE FIRST BILL ON OUR
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, WHICH WILL BE
AB 82 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH, A WITH OPENING THIS
UP BY SEEING IF THERE'S ANY
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB 82.
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE SEEING NO
ONE APPROACHED THE MIC? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, EXCUSE
ME. YES? GOOD MORNING, MICHELLE
PERALTA, ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS.
EXCUSE ME. NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SPENDING PLAN.
AND WE ALSO DO BELIEVE THE BILL
MAY CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW
AND THE FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION'S AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE THE SAFETY AND EFFICACY
OF THESE DRUGS. VERY GOOD. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMITTEE? SEEING NONE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 82 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1841 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER HAS WAIVED HIS
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF HER? BILL ANA
MONTES WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO 1841. THE
èC UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REPORTS ONGOING COSTS OF AT
LEAST 1.6 MILLION. TO COMPLY
WITH THE BILL, BOTH THE CSU AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPORT
MINOR ASSOCIATED COSTS. BUT WE
ARE ALSO WE ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE
IT DOES CREATE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS AS WELL AS A
POTENTIAL REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH ONE TIME AND
ONGOING PROPOSITION 91 GENERAL
FUND COSTS, PROBABLY IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OKAY, WE'RE GOOD. ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE?
SEEING NONE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1841 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1895
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CHLOE
FERMIN WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS.ORG SUPPORTS ÁP AB 1995
WEBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN. ANNA MATTHEWS. FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1895 PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES
ARE POTENTIALLY ONGOING. ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND. EXCUSE ME. GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE LOW HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS, TO
EXCUSE ME TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE AND ACCESS AND
INFORMATION AND MINOR ABSORBABLE
COST TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. SO WE ARE OPPOSED
AS A RESULT OF ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE STATE'S FISCAL PLAN. OKAY.
COMMITTEE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS?
SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, 1895 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1919 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1919. WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THE BILL COULD
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS TO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THE COSTS
WOULD, OF COURSE, DEPEND ON THE
BEST PRACTICES THAT A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY IMPLEMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1919 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1984 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1984. WE
DO BELIEVE IT COULD POTENTIALLY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE. AND WE ESTIMATE ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF UP TO ABOUT $4.7
MILLION FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES, SHOULD IT BE
CONSIDERED A MANDATE. SO WE ARE
OPPOSED TO IT. GIVEN THAT AND
THE ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
THAT ARE NOT COSTS, NOT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SPENDING PLAN,
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT IT
REQUIRES A REPORTING OF
DUPLICATE OR DUPLICATIVE
REPORTING OF ALREADY EXISTING
REPORTS. GOT IT. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1984 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2072, AGAIN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL. HOWEVER,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF THE BILL TO BE $500,000 IN
2526 FOR CONSULTING FEES AND AN
UPDATED FISCAL IMPACT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WASN'T AVAILABLE AT
THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS, BUT WE
BELIEVE BASED ON THE PRIOR
VERSION OF THE BILL, ESTIMATED
COST OF 29,000 TO THE INSURANCE
FUND COULD OCCUR IN 2020, 31 TO
32. HOWEVER, WE BELIEVE THE
CURRENT AMENDMENTS COULD
ACCELERATE THAT TIME FRAME AND
THAT THE COST COULD BE HIGHER
THAN ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED. ALL
RIGHT. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2072 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3059 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOESN'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL. HOWEVER,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES FISCAL IMPACT TO
BE 64,025 26, 133,026 27, AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER, THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM ESTIMATES A
FISCAL IMPACT OF ABOUT 332,000
ANNUALLY FROM THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES HEALTH CARE FUND.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 3059 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3139 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 3139 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 236 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, YES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 236. WE WOULD NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES THE FISCAL IMPACT
TO BE 1.9 7,000,007 POSITIONS IN
24, 25, 3.5 MILLION AND 14
POSITIONS IN 2526, 3.4 MILLION,
14 POSITIONS IN 2627, 3.4
9,000,014 POSITIONS IN 27, 28
AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE
MANAGED CARE FUND. WE WOULD ALSO
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ALSO ESTIMATES FISCAL
IMPACT OF APPROXIMATELY $24
MILLION IN 2526 AND ONGOING FROM
POTENTIAL PROPOSITION 30
IMPACTS. SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS A RESULT, IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AND MANAGED CARE FUND COSTS THAT
ARE NOT INCLUDED INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT STATE SPENDING PLAN.
THANK YOU, COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE CONCERNS THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 236 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1826 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? SURE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1826.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ESTIMATES ONGOING
COSTS OF $3 MILLION FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT TO FUND 13
POSITIONS TO HOLD PUBLIC
HEARINGS, CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS, ETC. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT
IS GENERATED FROM SURCHARGE ON
UTILITY BILLS, SO THE MEASURE
COULD RESULT IN INCREASED COSTS
FOR RATEPAYERS. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE, THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1826 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1851
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1851.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION INDICATES THE BILL
REQUIRES $304,000. ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THREE NEW
POSITIONS, OPERATING EXPENSES
AND EQUIPMENT. FINANCE ALSO
ASSUMES FEDERAL RESOURCES WILL
NOT BE AVAILABLE FOR THIS
PURPOSE, AND THEREFORE ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
MILLIONS TO LOW TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO PROVIDE THE GRANTS
TO THE PARTICIPATING LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. THEREFORE,
WE'RE OPPOSED, GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
AND COST PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED
IN THE STATE'S SPENDING PLAN,
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1851 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2193 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANNA MATHEWS WITH
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHLOE, FOR
BEING CLEANER FOR KIDS. SUPPORTS
AB 2193 ALONG WITH FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS. NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY. PEEPS AND CA
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2193.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES ONE TIME COSTS OF
$275,000 FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO DEVELOP THE COMPREHENSIVE
HAZING PREVENTION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM. THEY ALSO ANTICIPATE
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO UPDATE RULES AND REGULATIONS,
FINANCE ASSUMES THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WOULD INCUR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY $575,000 FOR THE
PROGRAM, AND ALSO ASSUMES THE
CSU WOULD INCUR ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF ABOUT $920,000. TO
UPDATE THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS, WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THE BILL COULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE WITH ONE
TIME PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS RANGING FROM 6.5 TO $9
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CREATE THE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2193 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON TO AB
2330 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ABOUT
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2330. WE
WOULD INDICATE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
$1.26 MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN 24, 25 AND $1.2 MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR 2526, AND
ONGOING FOR THE NEED FOR SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS. WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL MAY HAVE
ADDITIONAL NEGATIVE FISCAL
IMPACTS TO CDFW IF THE
MITIGATION MEASURES REQUIRED BY
THE BILL RESULT IN A DECREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF INCIDENTAL TAKE
PERMITS. SO WE ARE OPPOSED
BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN. QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FROM
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2330 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 270 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FROM
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 270. WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2346 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FILE.
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS. CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB 2346 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 25 2454 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? CHLOE
FERMIN. CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
SUPPORTS 2454 LEE, ALONG WITH
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY.
PEEPS AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DEPARTMENT OF. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WAS
TRYING TO GET TO YOU TOO FAST.
NO WORRIES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2454. THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRES
ONGOING COSTS OF 450,002
POSITIONS AND ONE TIME
CONTRACTING COSTS OF $500,000
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO ENHANCE
AND MAINTAIN THE DATABASE. WE
WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THE
WATER BOARD HAS COMMITTED
APPROXIMATELY $34 MILLION FROM
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE, SOLUTION BASED
APPROACH THAT ADDRESSES WATER
QUALITY. WITH APPROXIMATELY $6
MILLION BUDGETED FOR DOMESTIC
WELL SAMPLING. SO AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE OPPOSED BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES IN THE GENERAL FUND
NOT INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE? SEEING NONE, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2454 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3031 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? I GOT TO
JUMP TO. MARIA SULLIVAN,
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S POLITICAL CAUCUS. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FILE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS, CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SAYING NONE. AB 3031
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
AB 3031 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. THANK YOU.
LOOKING, LOOKING LOOKING. OKAY,
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO JUMP
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HERE PRESENT. AND WE,
WANT TO, GIVE HIM HIS TIME BACK,
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP AB 21.
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I THINK
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT AB 20 107. I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON THIS BILL, THE USE OF
DIGITAL DATA, RESULTS AND IMAGES
ARE BECOMING MORE COMMON IN THE
FIELD OF PATHOLOGY. FOR EXAMPLE,
THE UNITED STATES, THE FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION, FDA
APPROVED WHOLE SLIDING IMAGES,
WSI SYSTEMS FOR PRIMARY CLINICAL
DIAGNOSIS ON APRIL 12TH, 2017,
WSI TECHNOLOGY PERMITS
DIGITIZATION OF ENTIRE CLASS
SLIDES, THEREBY ELIMINATING THE
NEED FOR PATHOLOGY PRACTICE TO
BE LOCALLY TETHERED TO A
CONVENTIONAL MICROSCOPE. DUE TO
COVID 19, PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES ANNOUNCED
A POLICY AUTHORIZING
PATHOLOGISTS REVIEW PATHOLOGY
SLIDES AND DIGITAL DATA, RESULTS
AND IMAGES REMOTELY UPON
CONCLUSION, CMS REMOVED THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE REMOTE
REVIEW OF PHYSICAL SLIDES, BUT
CONTINUED TO PERMIT REMOTE
REVIEW OF DIGITAL DATA, RESULTS
AND IMAGES, INCLUDING THAT OF
SLIDES. HOWEVER, THE CALIFORNIA
LAW DOES NOT ALLOW THE REMOTE
REVIEW OF DIGITAL SLIDES DESPITE
CMS'S AUTHORIZATION. WITHOUT
THIS AUTHORIZATION, PATHOLOGISTS
WILL BE LIMITED TO VIEWING
DIGITAL DATA RESULTS IN IMAGES
INSIDE A LABORATORY, EVEN THOUGH
NO ACTUAL LABORATORY EQUIPMENT
IS UTILIZED OR NEEDED. THE GOAL
OF AB 20 107 WILL BRING
CALIFORNIA INTO CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL LAW BY ALLOWING
PATHOLOGISTS TO REVIEW DIGITAL
CLINICAL LABORATORY DATA,
DIGITAL CLINICAL RESULTS, AND
DIGITAL IMAGES AT A REMOTE
LOCATION UNDER A PRIMARY
LOCATIONS CLINICAL LABORATORY
IMPROVEMENT AMENDMENTS
CERTIFICATE. AS LONG AS CLIA
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE CODE OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS ARE MET.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME, WE HAVE
RYAN SPENCER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
PATHOLOGISTS. OKAY, MAYBE WE CAN
CHECK OUTSIDE AND SEE IF THERE'S
IF YOUR WITNESS IS HERE. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. RYAN SPENCER,
OUTSIDE. CALLING ALL. NO
WORRIES. YEAH. VERY GOOD. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE IT. WANT TO
CHECK AND SEE IF THERE THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. SUPPORT FOR 2107. HOW
ABOUT MEMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY OR AUDIENCE MEMBERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THIS IS A OH FINANCE
I'M SORRY. NO FILE. OKAY. I READ
HER MIND. SO WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THIS IS. THIS IS A DUE
PASS RECOMMENDATION. THERE IS A
MOTION, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FEEL FREE TO. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. YOU YOU YOU HAVE A
MAJORITY. WILL PUT IT ON. CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE AGENDA
AND, WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP AB 3291, WHICH IS, FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3291.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ANTICIPATES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH UPDATING THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN TO
INCLUDE CAREGIVER SUCCESSION
PLANNING AS MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE. HOWEVER, THERE ARE
ALSO POTENTIAL, SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND IMPACTS,
LIKELY IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO
CONVERT TO EXCUSE ME TO COVER
RENT, LEASE AND MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS FOR CONSUMERS WHO ARE
HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. SO THEREFORE, WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT IS LIKELY TO RESULT IN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SPENDING PLAN.
MEMBER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE,
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3291 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 347 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANY
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT? COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. PHÐ COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. CONCERNS. SEEING NONE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
347 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 691
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 691
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN COSTS NOT
CONSIDERED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT. CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES ONE TIME
CONTRACT SUPPORT COSTS OF
$750,000 FROM THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT, TO
DEVELOP THE REQUIRED REPORT.
FINANCE WOULD NOTE THAT SIX MAIN
OPERATING ACCOUNT, THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PRO EXCUSE ME PROGRAMS
ACCOUNT IS IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AND ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES WILL ACCELERATE THE
ACCOUNTS INSOLVENCY. WE BELIEVE
ANY RESOURCES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS MEASURE NEEDS TO BE
EVALUATED AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS? SEEING NONE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 691 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1780 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? NING 1780, ALONG WITH
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE. ECO SUSTAINABILITY.
PEEPS AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. HI
VALERIE JOHNSON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 1780
BECAUSE IT DOES SUPPORT EFFORTS
TO ENSURE TRANSPARENCY IN
POST-SECONDARY INSTITUTION
ADMISSIONS AND FAIR AND
APPROPRIATE ADMISSION PRACTICES,
BUT DOES NOTE THAT THIS BILL
COULD CREATE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF 235,000 FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO HIRE
TWO ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO
REVIEW, INVESTIGATE, AND ENFORCE
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS BY
INDEPENDENT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. COMMENTS QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1780 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 1814 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
WELCOME. THANK YOU. BECCA CRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
AB 1814 CREATES HARMS THAT DO
NOT EXIST IN CURRENT LAW AND
COSTS MONEY WITHOUT PROVIDING
ANY REAL BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIANS. AB 1814 COSTS
MONEY IN SEVERAL WAYS. FIRST,
POLICE WILL NEED TO BE TRAINED.
THEY WILL NEED TO KNOW ANSWERS
TO QUESTIONS SUCH AS DOES A
WITNESS ID THAT USES FACIAL
RECOGNITION, POSSIBLE MATCHES
COUNT AS A SUBSEQUENT
INVESTIGATORY TECHNIQUE TO CLEAR
AB 1814 SOLE BASIS PROVISION. AB
1814 WILL ALSO HAVE LITIGATION
AND DAMAGES COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH WRONGFUL ARRESTS, BUT AB
1814 COSTS MONEY OR COSTS.
CALIFORNIA. IN OTHER WAYS. IT
OPENS UP STATE DATABASES TO
PERPETUAL VIRTUAL LINEUPS, LIKE
THE ONE THAT CAUSED MR. WILLIAMS
TO BE WRONGFULLY ARRESTED AFTER
HIS OLD DRIVER'S LICENSE PHOTO
WAS FALSELY MATCHED TO FACIAL
RECOGNITION. IT MAY ALSO MAKE IT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE WRONGFULLY
ARRESTED TO HAVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. AS ATTORNEYS FOR MORE
THAN HALF OF THE KNOWN PEOPLE
WRONGFULLY ARRESTED DUE TO
FACIAL RECOGNITION ARGUE IN
THEIR OPPOSITION LETTER. AB 1814
WILL ALSO MAKE PROJECT 25 EASIER
TO ACHIEVE. IT IMPLIES THAT
LEGISLATORS ONLY WORRY WITH
FACIAL RECOGNITION IS IF IT'S
USED AS A SOLE BASIS FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE. BLESSING ALL
OTHER USES OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
AS QUOTE UNQUOTE SAFE, INCLUDING
USING FACIAL RECOGNITION TO
IDENTIFY PEOPLE GOING INTO
ABORTION AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE CLINICS THROUGHOUT LGBTQ
PEOPLE TO DETERMINE SOMEONE'S
POLITICAL LEANINGS, AND MORE
JUNK SCIENCE IS SOME OF THOSE
MAY SOUND FACIAL. THIS IS REALLY
THE FINANCIAL PART OF IT, FACIAL
RECOGNITION DOES CLAIM TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE ALL OF THOSE
POSSIBLE FOR THESE AND OTHER
REASONS, ACLU JOINS MORE THAN 70
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE, LGBTQ, I
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS, AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS IN ASKING
YOU TO HOLD AB 1814 ON SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIELLE KENDALL KAISER, ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF THE
OPPOSITION GROUPS, WITH THE
CHAIR'S PERMISSION, MAY READ
NAMES. SURE, THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION, PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE, MADERA
COALITION FOR COMMUNITY JUSTICE,
ACCESS, REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE,
GENDER JUSTICE, LA CALIFORNIA
LATINAS FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE,
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY, ASIAN LAW ALLIANCE,
IMMIGRATION DEFENSE ADVOCATES,
NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS AND CODE, JUSTICE, BLACK
LIVES MATTER, CALIFORNIA, IF
NGUYEN HAO, COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS,
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL IMMIGRATION
LAW CENTER, YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION, TECH EQUITY ACTION,
ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION, FREE SPEECH
COALITION, TRAINING FOR EARLY
ABORTION AND COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE, SECURE JUSTICE,
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA SILICON VALLEY,
DE-BUG, SANTA MONICA DEMOCRATIC
CLUB, INDIVISIBLE, CALIFORNIA,
TEAM JUSTICE SAN DIEGO,
UNIVERSIDAD POPULAR COUNCIL
CANCELED THE CONTRACT. THE
SIDEWALK PROJECT, ALL FAMILY
LEGAL DEFENSE FIGHT FOR THE
FUTURE, FOOD EMPOWERMENT PROJECT
AMERICAN ATHEISTS, SAN DIEGO
FACULTY ASSOCIATION, UNIVERSITY
OF IRVINE FACULTY ASSOCIATION,
SAN FRANCISCO BLACK AND JEWISH
UNITY COALITION ALLIANCE, SAN
DIEGO, INDIVISIBLE, INDIVISIBLE,
YOLO, EPIC SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY OVERSIGHT PROJECT,
ORGANIZATION FOR IDENTITY AND
CULTURAL DEVELOPMENT, ADVOCACY
FOR PRINCIPLED ACTION STUDENTS.
STUDENTS DESERVE INDIVISIBLE
EAST BAY PARIVAR. BAY AREA
POSITIVE WOMEN'S NETWORK, USA,
HEALTH CARE FOR US AND COMMUNITY
COALITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ ON BEHALF OF
THE DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION,
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1814 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2244 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? OOPS. CHLOE FERMIN
WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
SUPPORTS 22 1422. EXCUSE ME 2244
ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS FACTS. NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE. ECO
SUSTAINABILITY. PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NØ FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2244 WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE'S CASE. TRYING TO
FIND YOUR FILE, WE HAVE 354. DID
I MISS IT? 31. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THERE IT IS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL WELCOME. THANK YOU.
JUMP TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP AB 3100.
THIS ENJOYS A DUE PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND
COLLEAGUES. GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN. ASSEMBLY BILL 3100 HELPS
TO ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN WITH
RESPECT TO DIVORCES. THE FISCAL
IMPACT IS MINIMAL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR OUR VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. VERY
GOOD. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 3100? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THERE
IS A MOTION, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE JONES.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. CIERTO
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE
FIVE ZERO 5 TO 0. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING BACK TO OUR REGULAR
AGENDA, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
AB 459 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLER
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 459,
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
ESTIMATES COSTS RELATED TO DATA
STORAGE AND MAKING DATA
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC WILL BE
$3.4 MILLION IN 24, 25, AND $3.2
MILLION IN 2526, AND ONGOING
FINANCE WOULD NOTE ANY REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS
SUBJECT TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS, AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE OR THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL DOES, DOES INCUR
ADDITIONAL COSTS AS A RESULT OF
THE BILL, CHP MAY REQUIRE
FUNDING FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT IN THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION FUND, AND WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE MVA IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING WITH A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. WE WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THE BILL MAY
IMPOSE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE, AS DETERMINED BY THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES, AS
IT DOES REQUIRE A NEW PROGRAM OR
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICES TO BE
PROVIDED BY LOCAL AGENCIES.
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 459. WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 1581 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 1581 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1993 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. CONCERNS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1993 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2509 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2509,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ANTICIPATES WILL
RESULT IN COSTS RANGING FROM
300,000 TO 400,000. GENERAL FUND
TO ESTABLISH MONITORING
GUIDELINES ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS WHENEVER ESTABLISHED.
GUIDELINES FOR MONITORING OF A
PEST DO NOT EXIST, FINANCE DOES
ESTIMATE THE TOTAL IMPACT OF THE
COST OF ESTABLISHING GUIDELINES
MIGHT BE CLOSER TO LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, AND SO WE ARE
OPPOSED BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
UNKNOWN, POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT AND MAY
HINDER CFA'S ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO INVASIVE
SPECIES. COMMITTEE COMMENTS,
CONCERNS SEEING NONE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2509 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2602 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. CONCERNS SEEING NONE
AB 2602 IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2602 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2640 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2640. WE
ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE WE DO
BELIEVE IT WILL CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES
OF BETWEEN 800 AND $50,004.3
MILLION AND CREATES ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF UP TO
50,001 TIME. GENERAL COSTS.
GENERAL FUND COSTS. EXCUSE ME,
OF UP TO 20,000. TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL.
COMMITTEE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB 2640.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2926 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ. FILE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS. CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2926 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3280. THIS
IS A BILL FROM THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3280.
AT THE TIME OF THE ANALYSIS, THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAD NOT
PROVIDED A FISCAL ESTIMATE OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS.
HOWEVER, BASED ON THE BILL'S
PROVISION, THE BILL WOULD HAVE
UNKNOWN BUT LIKELY SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE LACTATION ROOMS FOR
COURT USERS IN COURT FACILITIES
THAT ARE WITHOUT A STAFF OR
WITHOUT A STAFF. LACTATION ROOM.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL DID
PREVIOUSLY INDICATE THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 215 COURT
FACILITIES THAT ARE WITHOUT
LACTATION ROOMS, AND FOR
REFERENCE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOTE THAT THE 2022
BUDGET ACT PROVIDED $15 MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND
PUBLIC ACCESS TO LACTATION
FACILITIES AND COURTHOUSES FOR
COURT USERS. COMMENTS CONCERNS
FROM COMMITTEE SEEING NONE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3280.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 460 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 460 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
1836 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS. CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE AB 1836 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB 1836 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1846 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1846
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ESTIMATES THIS
BILL RESULTS IN COSTS OF
$730,000 GENERAL FUND AND 24, 25
AND 695,000 IN 25, 26 AND
ONGOING FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING
TO CREATE AND DELIVER THE
REQUIRED TRAINING ANNUALLY.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT. COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1846 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2054 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? CHLOE
FERMIN WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS.ORG SUPPORTS 2054 ALONG
WITH FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2054 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2085 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? MARIA O'SULLIVAN
WITH THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
POLITICAL CAUCUS IS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2085 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2099 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? MORRELL O'SULLIVAN WITH
THE NATIONAL POLITICAL CAUCUS.
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS IS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
I SEE YOU RUNNING, SO NO, WAIT,
I'M ROXANNE GOULD WITH THE
AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. FILE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS? CONCERNS
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2099 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2169 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2169.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRES
1.48 MILLION, AND FOR POSITIONS
IN 25, 26, 2.08 MILLION, AND FOR
POSITIONS IN 2627, 2.85 MILLION,
AND FOR POSITIONS IN 27, 28 AND
2.1 MILLION FOR POSITIONS IN
2829 AND ANNUALLY FROM THE FEE
SUPPORTED FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FACILITY DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ALSO ESTIMATES THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF THIS BILL TO BE $80,000 IN
2526 FROM THE INSURANCE FUND TO
PROMISE TO CREATE REGULATIONS.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AS IT CREATES COSTS. THE MANAGED
CARE FUND, NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE STATE FISCAL PLAN, AND
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF SERVICES AND
CREATE ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES
FOR HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
THAT COULD BE PASSED ON TO
CONSUMERS THROUGH HIGHER
PREMIUMS. COMMENTS. QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2169 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2236 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? YES. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JENNIFER FEARING, ON BEHALF OF
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM,
OCCIDENTAL ARTS AND ECOLOGY
CENTER, OCEAN CONSERVANCY,
OCEANA, AND ALSO ASKED TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT FOR
SURFRIDER PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, BAY AREA
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
CALPIRG. I JUST WANT TO NOTE TWO
ITEMS. FIRST, THIS BILL WAS
STRONGLY ENDORSED TODAY BY THE
LA TIMES AND AS AMENDED ON JULY
3RD, WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
CURRENTLY HAS NO COST WHATSOEVER
TO THE STATE. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IS WITH THE SOLE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SHARON
GONSALVES, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD, IN SUPPORT. CHLOE
FERMIN WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
SUPPORTS 2236 ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS.
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE,
ECO SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA
AND GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING TYLER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, GAVIN MCHUGH. ON BEHALF
OF INTERNATIONAL PAPER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO FILE
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2236 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2467 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? MARIA
O'SULLIVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS IS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2467 AS
THE. AS A RESULT, IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN AND MAY POTENTIALLY RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS.
SPECIFICALLY, WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS FOR THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM, LIKELY IN THE MILLIONS
TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND TO EXTEND MEDI-CAL
MANAGED HEALTH HEALTH PLANS TO
COVER SERVICES PURSUANT TO THE
BILL. ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL
MAY ADD PRESSURES TO DEPARTMENTS
AS THEY ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING
AND IMPLEMENTING EFFICIENCIES
RESULTING FROM THE STATEWIDE
ONGOING REDUCTION TO
DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONAL BUDGETS
ADOPTED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
COMMENTS CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2467 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2527 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MARIA
O'SULLIVAN WITH THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S POLITICAL CAUCUS IS IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL, AS WE NOTE THAT IT
COULD CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE, AS DETERMINED BY
THE COMMISSION ON STATE
MANDATES, BY EXPANDING THE
REQUIRED ITEMS OF ACCESS FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT PERSONS.
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE POTENTIAL
MANDATE COST IS UNKNOWN, BUT
COULD BE SIGNIFICANT GIVEN THE
REQUIREMENT OF ADDITIONAL FOOD
AND WATER TO INCARCERATED
PREGNANT PEOPLE. WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION DOES INDICATE
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING THE
WATER NUTRITIONAL MEALS. IT
NOTES CONCERNS WITH PROHIBITING
THE PLACEMENT OF INCARCERATED,
PREGNANT, AND POSTPARTUM PERSONS
IN RESTRICTED HOUSING. COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2527 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2877 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? CRYSTAL STRAIGHT ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA.
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2877 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2930 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
IT'S A RACE TO THE MIC. I'LL DO
QUICKLY THIS TIME, DANNY CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MIKE ROBSON. ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN STAFFING
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
STAFFING PROFESSIONAL OPPOSED
BASED ON THE POLICY GROUNDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ FILE. COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2930 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 551 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYBODY HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 551 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 637 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 637.
EXCUSE ME. THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS TO BE $1.8 MILLION
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND AND EIGHT PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN 24, 25, $2.4
MILLION FROM THE FUND AND TWO
TWO PERMANENT POSITIONS, ONE
LIMITED TERM POSITION IN 2526
AND 2.3 MILLION IN 2627, AND
ONGOING FINANCE OPPOSES THE BILL
AS IT CREATES ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES ON THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND, WHICH IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT, AND THIS BILL WILL JUST
EXACERBATE THE FUND STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE. COMMENTS. QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
637 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
1801 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE COMMITTEE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1801
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1818
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANNA
MATHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1818.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, AND DOES
INDICATE MODERATE ONE TIME STATE
OPERATIONS. GENERAL FUND COSTS
BETWEEN 91,000 AND 112,000 TO
ISSUE GUIDANCE. HOWEVER, THEY DO
ANTICIPATE SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR DISTRICTS TO ACQUIRE
SECURITY EQUIPMENT AND PROVIDE
ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE ON
EACH CAMPUS, AND ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND COST
OF APPROXIMATELY $10.7 MILLION
TO 13.5 MILLION. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ESTIMATES ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 500,000,
AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF 2.25 MILLION, OR 2.25
MILLION. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
AND PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND SUBJECTS. COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES TO
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
LIABILITY. IF AN INCIDENT WERE
TO OCCUR ON THE CAMPUS DURING
THE PILOT COMMENTS, CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1818 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2042 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? GOOD
MORNING, ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ. ON
BEHALF OF THE DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2042. THE PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR THE
COMMISSION. EXCUSE ME, THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING DOES
ANTICIPATE COSTS RANGING FROM
250,000 TO 400,000. ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND, AND WE WOULD NOTE
THAT IT'S TO DEVELOP THE
GUIDELINES, WHICH, BY THE WAY,
IS A DOUBLE IS DOUBLE JOINTED
WITH AB 3241. HOWEVER, FINANCE
DOES NOTE WE DO BELIEVE THESE
COSTS COULD BE ABSORBABLE FOR
POST. HOWEVER, THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL ALSO INDICATES
THE BILL MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL UNKNOWN COSTS FOR THE
CHP, CONTINGENT UPON DETAILS OF
THE GUIDELINES THAT POST
CREATES, AND THESE COSTS COULD
BE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO COME
FROM THE FUNDING OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT, WHICH IS IN THE
STATE TRANSPORTATION FUND. AND
JUST A REMINDER, THE MVA IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING WITH A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. COMMENTS.
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE. CANDIDATES ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2042 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2448 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF 2448? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2448.
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY, EXCUSE ME,
ESTIMATES ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF 5.7 MILLION AND 2526,
AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND AND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
1.2 MILLION BEGINNING IN 2627.
TO COLLABORATE WITH THE COUNTY
OF RIVERSIDE TO DEVELOP THE
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION, THE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COULD POTENTIALLY
INCUR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATED
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. THEREFORE,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET AND LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE LIKELY TO
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE. COMMENTS. CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE. CANDIDATES ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2448 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2936 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2936. SO
SORRY. SORRY WE BELIEVE THE BILL
WILL CREATE ONE TIME PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND AND NON
PROPOSITION. GENERAL 98 FUND
COSTS THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
PART OF THE STATE'S CURRENT
FISCAL PLAN. SPECIFICALLY, THE
CSU INDICATES THE BILL WILL LEAD
TO ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS
IN THE MID HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE WORK
GROUP, THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INDICATES THE BILL WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
COSTS IN THE SAME RANGE.
THEREFORE, WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL AS IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT STATE FISCAL PLAN.
COMMENTS. CONCERNS FROM
COMMITTEE SEEING NONE. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2936.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO AB 810 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANNA MATHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 810. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES COSTS OF $9 MILLION.
ONGOING GENERAL FUND AND $1
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
THE CSU ESTIMATES THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL UNKNOWN
ADMINISTRATIVE GENERAL FUND
COSTS, POSSIBLY IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS, TO
ADJUST THEIR HIRING PROCESS. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THE BILL COULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 2.5
MILLION TO UPDATE CAMPUS HIRING
POLICIES AND PROVIDE ONE DAY
TRAINING TO EXISTING STAFF AT
CAMPUSES. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
CREATE COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
PROPOSITION 98, GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. COMMITTEE COMMENTS
CONCERNS SEEING NONE. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 810 WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 930 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 930.
FINANCE WOULD CONCUR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK'S
ESTIMATE THAT THERE COULD BE A
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE FOR
THE STATE TO INVEST HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
RISE. REVOLVING LOAN FUND, THAT
THE BILL ESTABLISHES UPON
APPROPRIATION TO FINANCE RISE
DISTRICT STARTUP COSTS. THE
ESTIMATE ASSUMES RISE DISTRICT
PROJECT IS LIKELY TO REQUIRE AT
LEAST 100 MILLION IN STARTUP
FINANCING, AND THE EYE BANK
ESTIMATES IT WILL INCUR A NÓ
GENERAL FUND COSTS, POTENTIALLY
IN THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. TO ADMINISTER THE
FUND. THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH RESEARCH ALSO ESTIMATES
COSTS OF 672,000 GENERAL FUND
AND 25, 26 AND 224,000 GENERAL
FUND IN 2627 AND ONGOING TO
SUPPORT THREE STAFF POSITIONS.
COMMENTS. CONCERNS FROM
COMMITTEE SEEING NONE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 930 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1889 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? YES. GOOD MORNING
AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR. JENNIFER
FEARING, ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT. CHLOE FERMIN WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS SUPPORTS 1889
ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS. NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE. ECO
SUSTAINABILITY. PEEPS AND CA
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NØ FILE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS CONCERNS SEEING NONE
THIS BILL IS A IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB 1889 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1963 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? YOU WANT TO BE HERE
FOR CHLOE FERMIN WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS SUPPORTS AB 1963,
ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS. NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEACE AND CA
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
MOMS ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY.
YARD SMART MARIN GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION SONOMA SAS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE
AND BEYOND PESTICIDES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ALEGRIA DE LA
CRUZ. DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TAYLOR
ROSHAN, ON BEHALF OF A VARIETY
OF AGRICULTURAL TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS AND OPPOSITION,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. FILE
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1963 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2263 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MARIA
O'SULLIVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS IS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CLIFF BERG, ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
IN SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2263.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES COSTS WILL
INCLUDE ONE TIME GENERAL FUND OF
999,000. THE FIRST YEAR, AND
986,000 ANNUALLY ONGOING FOR
FUTURE YEARS FOR STATE
OPERATIONS SUPPORT. THEREFORE,
WE ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET ACT. COMMENTS CONCERNS BY
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2263 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2925 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? JUST KIND
OF STAGE RIGHT HERE. MADAM CHAIR
CLIFF BERG, ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
REPRESENTING OVER 40 STATEWIDE
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS AND
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, IS PLEASED TO BE A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. IT IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ADDRESS
ANTI-SEMITISM AND OTHER HATE
TARGETED AT BOTH THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND OTHER ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE SEEN A SURGE OF
ANTI-SEMITIC AND OTHER HATE
DIRECTED ACTIVITY ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IN CALIFORNIA. URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME. HEY, I'M JONATHAN
MINTZER, JEWISH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL, THE LARGEST
COLLECTIVE VOICE OF BAY AREA
JEWS REPRESENTING 65 SYNAGOGUES
AND ORGANIZATIONS. URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. HI I'M MARIELLA SOKOLOVSKY,
I'M THE CEO FOR THE JEWISH
FEDERATION OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGION AND I'M I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARIANNE LEFF, CO-PRESIDENT OF
THE JEWISH FEDERATION OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO. STANLEY LEFF.
PRESIDENT OF THE EINSTEIN JEWISH
COMMUNITY SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. AND BRETT
COTTER, MEMBER AND CONCERNED
CITIZEN OF ZIONIST SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO, SANDY NIEVES,
I'M THE CHAPTER LEADER OF
ZIONISTS HERE WITH JPAC IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS ALAN FISHER.
I'M FROM ATHERTON, CALIFORNIA. I
AM A PHYSICIST AT STANFORD AT
THE ACCELERATOR. I A PAST
PRESIDENT OF CONGREGATION BETH
JACOB IN REDWOOD CITY AND
REPRESENT BETH JACOB AT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL OF THE BAY AREA. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL, AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
HELLO, I'M REN FISS AND I'M A
PROFESSOR OF CULTURAL AND VISUAL
STUDIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE OF THE ARTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS FROM THE
MY EXPERIENCES AND MY STUDENTS
EXPERIENCES. SO I STRONGLY,
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI, I'M
SANDY FAWN. I AM A CONCERNED AND
AFRAID PARENT OF AN INCOMING
FRESHMAN AT UCLA AND A RECENT
GRADUATE OF UCLA, UC BERKELEY.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JONATHAN WARMUND, ALUMNUS OF
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
BERKELEY, STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
AND I'M ALSO A VOLUNTEER WITH
THE JEWISH FAMILY CHILDREN'S
SERVICES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS LOIS
KELLERMAN. I'M WITH HADASSAH, A
JEWISH WOMEN'S ZIONIST
ORGANIZATION, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS AND URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE ANTI-SEMITISM
IS JEWS ARE THE SECOND MOST
TARGETED GROUP IN CALIFORNIA
FOR, HATE CRIMES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. GOOD
MORNING. I'M TERESA DRENIK. I'M
THE DEPUTY REGIONAL DIRECTOR AT
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE IN
THE CENTRAL PACIFIC REGION, AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI, I'M NANCY GOLDBERG, A PAST
CHAIR OF JPAC AND I'M WITH THE
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M
ALLISON BARNES. I AM THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
WITH JCRC BAY AREA. I'M ALSO A
FORMER FORMER PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER IN MENDOCINO COUNTY, AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M SKYLER
COHEN, EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
AND WEST DISTRICT CHAIR OF THE
UNION FOR REFORM JUDAISM, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. A FEW MORE. HI. MY
NAME IS NAOMI GOLDMAN. I'M AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF
DEMOCRATS FOR ISRAEL,
CALIFORNIA, AND A DESCENDANT OF
SURVIVORS. AND I VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HI THERE.
MY NAME IS MIRANDA LICHTMAN. I'M
THE ASSOCIATE REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
IN THE LOS ANGELES REGION, AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS DANIEL KLEIN,
AND I'M THE CEO OF JEWISH
SILICON VALLEY. OUR COMMUNITY IS
VERY INTERESTED TO SEE AN
INCREASE OF EDUCATION AND
ANTI-SEMITISM AND HOW THAT LEADS
TO JEW HATRED. SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
ROSE LEV. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO.
RACHEL WALLACE FROM JEWISH
FEDERATION, LOS ANGELES. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN JUST A
SECOND, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS
BRUCE PALMER, JEWISH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL, THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2020 2925. THANK YOU. HELLO,
SUSAN GEORGE FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
REPRESENTING THE RAOUL
WALLENBERG JEWISH DEMOCRATIC
CLUB, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL FOR THREE MORE. HI. MY
NAME IS WENDY LEVY BATTERSON. I
AM A FOUNDER OF SAN DIEGO
INDIVISIBLE, ADVOCATING FOR
PROGRESSIVE CAUSES, AND I AM
AFFILIATED WITH THE JEWISH
FEDERATION, THE AMERICAN JEWISH
COMMITTEE. JPAC. AND I AM A
MEMBER OF DEMOCRATS FOR ISRAEL.
I CAME FROM SAN DIEGO TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
THE SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MATTHEW FINKELSTEIN. I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE JEWISH
DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF SOLANO
COUNTY, AND I HAVE COME HERE TO
SUPPORT AB 2925. THANK YOU.
MORNING. I'M ROBIN LAYTON. I
ALSO CAME FROM SAN DIEGO. I'M A
PRODUCT OF THE EAST LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. I'M A RETIRED
EDUCATOR. I'M ON THE BOARD OF
AJC IN SAN DIEGO, AND I'M 100%
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS SOPHIA MEYERHOFF. I GREW
UP IN SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA. I'M
A RECENT GRADUATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND AND I'M
THE COORDINATOR AT AGC SAN
DIEGO. AND I APPROVE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS REBECCA
PEARL. I'M AN INTERN AT AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMITTEE, SAN DIEGO AND
A RISING SENIOR AT UC DAVIS WHO
NO LONGER FEELS SAFE ON CAMPUS
WEARING MY JEWISH STAR NECKLACE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS NATANYA CRANFORD. I'M
A PRODUCT OF SAN DIEGO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND A BOARD MEMBER OF MY
CONGREGATION. I'M ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH THE JEWISH
FEDERATION OF SAN DIEGO, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS MATTHEW BLOCH.
I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AT
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE. SAN
DIEGO, AND I'M FULLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO.
MY NAME IS KAREN STILLER. I AM A
PARENT OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA, AND ALSO
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF JEWISH
AFFAIRS AT THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL. AND I KNOW
FROM EXPERIENCE HOW CRITICAL
THIS BILL IS, AND I STAND HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL HOLD WITH YOU.
HELLO, MY NAME IS JESSICA
TRUBOWITZ. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL OF THE BAY AREA, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI, I'M DOREEN KESSELMAN. I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE JEWISH
DEMOCRATIC COALITION OF THE BAY
AREA, REPRESENTING FOUR COUNTIES
SANTA CLARA, SAN MATEO, SANTA
CRUZ, AND ALAMEDA COUNTIES. AND
WE'RE IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI,
I'M REBECCA GOODMAN. I ATTENDED
UC SANTA BARBARA AND UC DAVIS,
AND I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HI, I'M JESSICA
BLACKHAWK. I'M A DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS WITH JCRC
BAY AREA. I'M A PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AS
ARE MY TWO CHILDREN, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. DO
YOU WANT US TO HOLD IT RIGHT
THERE? OKAY. MY NAME IS LARRY
WARNOCK. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE. I
TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SIR. I APPRECIATE IT. MY
NAME IS ELLEN DIAMOND. I'VE BEEN
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT FOR OVER
50 YEARS. I'M A GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI. MY
NAME IS LYNN LAZARUS AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA
AND, I'M A MEMBER OF KEHILLA
COMMUNITY SYNAGOGUE AND NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN, AND I'M
ALSO A RETIRED SCHOOL TEACHER. I
TAUGHT SCHOOL FOR 30 YEARS, AND
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT,
BULLYING IS ALWAYS A CONCERN AND
AN ISSUE IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MY NAME IS
LEE TO KROENKE AND I'M FROM
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA. ALSO, I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF KEHILLA
COMMUNITY SYNAGOGUE, AND I, I'M
A RETIRED LAWYER AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
SCOTT WIEDERMAN. I LIVE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. I'M A VETERAN AND
SERVED AS AN OFFICER IN THE
ARMY. I'M HERE AS A PARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN, ONE OF WHOM IS
SPECIAL NEEDS. BOTH HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY ANTISEMITISM
FACILITATED BY BIAS
INDOCTRINATION, AS PART OF AN
ACADEMIC CURRICULUM. I URGENTLY
SUPPORT PASSAGE OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS ERIC KINGSLEY. I'M A
VICE CHAIR OF INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE NATIONALLY, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS PETER LEVY. I'M
A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN. I AM A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF RABBIS OF
ORANGE COUNTY. I'M THE REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE ADL AND LONG
BEACH, ORANGE COUNTY, THE PROUD
FATHER OF FOUR. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS DAVID GABRIEL. I'M A
PRESIDENT OF THE MARIN COUNTY
JEWISH DEMOCRATIC CLUB. I'M ALSO
A PROUD GRADUATE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M
SHERRY DIMMERLING. I'M A FAIR
HOUSING EXECUTIVE. I'M FROM HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. I'M ALSO WITH THE
NCW, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M AMY
SPADE, I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY IMPACT AT THE BAY AREA
OF JEWISH FEDERATION, AND I, WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
I'M SETH BRISK. I'M THE SON OF A
HOLOCAUST REFUGEE. I'M ALSO THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WE ALSO HAVE OFFICES
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO,
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS SUSAN KITCHELL.
I'M A CHILD OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS. I AM A GRADUATE OF
UCSF AND A RETIREE FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS BEN LEVY.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE PALO
ALTO BBYO, WHICH IS A JEWISH
YOUTH ORGANIZATION. AND I'M A
STUDENT IN THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOL, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR
COMING TODAY. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HARRIS. I LIVE IN SONOMA COUNTY.
I'M A LAY LEADER FOR STAND WITH
US, AN ORGANIZATION BASED IN LOS
ANGELES. THE COMBATS
ANTI-SEMITISM AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS DOUG JAFFE. I'M A
GRADUATE OF THE PALO ALTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DAVIS. I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ALSO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPUS SAFETY BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
JAMES CASTLEMAN. I'M ON THE
BOARD OF THE JEWISH DEMOCRATIC
COALITION OF THE BAY AREA, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. BARBARA
NEMKO, NAPA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS FOR
THE LAST 27 YEARS, MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
ETHNIC STUDIES PROJECT. AND I
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. I'M JANA WALDINGER,
ALSO, HAVING SERVED 27 YEARS ON
THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI, I'M
ALENA WEISS DUMAN, DAUGHTER OF A
HOLOCAUST REFUGEE PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M BETH FORSMAN FROM
MILL VALLEY, AND I'M WITH ALUMS
FOR CAMPUS FAIRNESS. I AM THE UC
DAVIS CHAPTER LEAD. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS ASSEMBLY BILL AND I
AM THE GRANDDAUGHTER OF A BRANCH
OF MY ENTIRE FAMILY LOST IN THE
HOLOCAUST. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. HELLO, MY NAME IS LINDA
POLLOCK. I'M A RETIRED TEACHER
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. I WAS THE
DEAN OF STUDENTS AT ONE OF THE
HIGH SCHOOLS THERE, AND I KNOW
WHAT BULLYING IS, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL PRESENTLY,
EVEN THOUGH I'M RETIRED, I DO
WORK AS A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER IN
THE HIGH SCHOOLS. AND I THINK
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT EFFORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PAT CRAWFORD. I'M A MEMBER OF
THE EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE
UNITED EDUCATORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO, RETIRED DIVISION, AND
I'M SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
I'M BETH RUTCHICK. I LIVE IN
MILL VALLEY, CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF BILL 2925. I DON'T
KNOW, IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
VERY GOOD. ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ANY
OPPOSITION OUTSIDE? GOOD
MORNING, COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ALL
THIS TESTIMONY. MY NAME IS DAVID
MANDEL. I'M AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF JEWISH
VOICE FOR PEACE, WHICH
REPRESENTS 100,000 MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS AROUND CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE, OF COURSE, VERY CONCERNED
BY THE RISE OF ANTI-SEMITISM
THAT WE SEE COMING FROM THE
WHITE SUPREMACIST RIGHT IN ALL
SORTS OF WAYS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
NONE OF US ARE SAFE UNLESS ALL
OF US ARE SAFE. AND THIS BILL,
UNFORTUNATELY, THE AUTHORS DID
NOT ACCEPT AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PROPOSED BY A GROUP THAT WE WORK
WITH THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS, THAT
WOULD CANCEL THE VERY ARBITRARY
DESIGNATION THAT THE EDUCATION
ABOUT DISCRIMINATION WOULD BE
ONLY REGARDING, STEMMING FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT DATA ON WHICH
GROUPS ARE SUBJECT TO HATE HATE
CRIMES AND OTHER DISCRIMINATION.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS, CERTAIN HATE
CRIMES AND DISCRIMINATION THAT
ARE NOT THAT ARE VERY MUCH
UNDERREPORTED, THE ONE OF THE
MOST WELL KNOWN, OF COURSE, IS
SEXUAL ASSAULT, BUT ALSO
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI-PALESTINIAN ANTI-ARAB, HATE
HATE SPEECH, HATE CRIMES AND
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
ARE VERY MUCH UNDERREPORTED. AND
THAT WOULD THAT IN DANGER OF
BEING LEFT OUT BY BY THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. AND SO
WE WOULD, OPPOSE IT UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
AND ANY OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
OFTEN UNDERREPORTED ARE INCLUDED
IN THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN, THIS IS ON
THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
MOVE IT TO SUSPENSE. SO, HELLO,
MY NAME IS MAYA STEINHARDT. I'M
A JEWISH EDUCATOR AND RECENT SAC
STATE GRADUATE WHO SPENT TIME AT
THE SAC STATE ENCAMPMENT FOR
PALESTINE. I AM OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED, TO INCLUDE THE TOP
THREE RELIGIONS MOST
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST TO ADDRESS
THE RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA. JUST
AS THERE HAS BEEN A RISE IN
ANTI-SEMITISM, THERE HAS BEEN A
RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA, AND THIS
BILL ACTIVELY, ENACTS AN
INSTANCE OF ISLAMOPHOBIA BY
KEEPING THIS OUT OF ANTI-BIAS
TRAINING, PRIVILEGING EDUCATION
FOR ONE GROUP ABOUT HOW TO
COMBAT THAT BIAS VERSUS
EDUCATION ON HOW TO COMBAT
BIASES FOR ANOTHER GROUP
RECREATES HARM. THERE IS NO
REASON NOT TO INCLUDE
ANTI-ISLAMOPHOBIA EDUCATION
WITHIN THIS BILL. IT IS SIMPLE,
COMMON SENSE. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT I'M
SPEAKING FOR, INCLUDING JEWISH
VOICE FOR PEACE, CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN-ISLAMIC
RELATIONS, CALIFORNIA ARAB
RESOURCE AND ORGANIZING CENTER,
AS WELL AS WORKER CIRCLE ARBETER
RING OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE ALL OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M MAGGIE COLTER. I HOLD
DEGREES FROM UC SANTA BARBARA,
UC SANTA CRUZ. SORRY, UC DAVIS
AND UC BERKELEY. I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL COALITION FOR
PALESTINIAN RIGHTS. I WISH TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED AS INDICATED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2925.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN UNKNOWN SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS BETWEEN
275,000 AND 1 MILLION. TO UPDATE
THE VARIOUS TRAINING COURSES,
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE DOES INDICATE THAT BILL
WILL RESULT IN MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE GENERAL FUND COSTS.
HOWEVER, THE BILL COULD CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
WITH PROP 98 GENERAL FUND COSTS
IN THE RANGES OF 600,000 TO 1.2
MILLION. BY REQUIRING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO UPDATE
THEIR EXISTING TRAINING TO
ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
THE FIVE MOST TARGETED GROUPS IN
THE STATE. COMMENTS, QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NONE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. FIRST, LET ME.
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
OR EXPRESS A CONCERN? I'LL JUST
SAY THAT I APPRECIATE ALL THE
PEOPLE COMING TO TESTIFY, AND I
DO BELIEVE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TOOK THE WORDS RIGHT OUT OF MY
MIND, OUT OF MY MOUTH, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, BUT I
WANT BEFORE I GET THERE, I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
THAT ARRIVED TODAY. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNITY, AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AS
WE CONSIDER THE FISCAL IMPACTS
OF THINGS, TO UNDERSTAND THE
REAL LIFE IMPACTS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE COMMUNITY. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE,
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT THAT
HAVE SPENT YOUR LIFE TEACHING,
IT'S A THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE, YOU DO YOU DO REALLY,
REALLY IMPORTANT WORK AND I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO BE A
TEACHER. AND THEN I GOT IN A
CLASSROOM AND REALIZED I JUST
DIDN'T HAVE THE PATIENCE FOR IT,
FOR IT. SO. SO I REALLY, RESPECT
TEACHERS BECAUSE I HAD SOME
GREAT ONES. IN ANY CASE, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
YES, I JUMP IN. YES I APOLOGIZE
FOR BEING LATE. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU EXPLAINED THIS ALREADY TO
THE FOLKS THAT TRAVELED HERE,
BECAUSE I KNOW MANY OF THEM
TRAVELED A LONG WAYS. DID WE
EXPLAIN WHAT SUSPENSE MEANS FOR
THE FOLKS THAT ARE HERE TODAY SO
THEY KNOW WHAT'S WELL, THEY'VE
BEEN HERE FOR A WHILE AND
SITTING OUTSIDE. SO WHICH FOR
WHICH I REALLY, REALLY THANK
THEM. BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND DO A TRAINING, I'M
SURE YOU DID IT. BUT AGAIN, I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE. I JUST
WANTED TO EXPLAIN TO THE
EVERYBODY THAT'S HERE, YOU KNOW,
BOTH IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION,
THAT WHEN A BILL GOES ON
SUSPENSE, WHAT THAT MEANS, IT'S
UNDER FURTHER REVIEW. IT WILL
COME UP FOR A VOTE LATER IN THE
MONTH. AND SO THIS IS NEITHER
THE BEGINNING NOR THE END OF THE
BILL. AND, WE'LL, SO YOUR
ADVOCACY IS STILL, WARRANTED.
AND ENCOURAGED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND APPRECIATE IT AND
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. I DO
APPRECIATE THAT WE JUMPED RIGHT
INTO THE INTO THE HEARING, SO
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2925 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE. SUSPENSE FILE. THESE
ARE ALL THE BILLS THAT COST
MONEY AND ULTIMATELY WE'LL GO
THROUGH THOSE BILLS AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT WHAT WE CAN AFFORD. AND
YOU KNOW, WHAT POLICY PRIORITIES
WE'VE SET FOR THE STATE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. REALLY APPRECIATE
IT, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
3088 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. SO I WANT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FOR YOU ALL DON'T
HAVE TO STAY HERE IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO. YOU WON'T HURT OUR
FEELINGS IF YOU GET UP AND WALK
OUT, AFTER YOUR TESTIMONY, ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR. WELL,
YEAH. COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ON
THIS FROM THE COMMITTEE SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTION, AB 3088 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB 815 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE,
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 815.
FINANCE ESTIMATES. THE COST OF
THIS BILL TO BE IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE FEE
SUPPORTED BY THE MANAGED CARE
FUND. WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILLS THAT RESULT IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN, AND MAY BE DUPLICATIVE OF
CURRENT EFFORTS TO COLLECT
STANDARDIZED PROVIDER
INFORMATION. THE BILL MAY ALSO
ADD PRESSURES TO THE DEPARTMENT
OR TO DMHC AS ITS EVALUATING AND
IMPLEMENTING EFFICIENCIES
RESULTING FROM THE STATEWIDE
ONGOING REDUCTIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OPERATIONAL BUDGETS
ADOPTED IN 2020 FOR BUDGET ACT.
AND WE WOULD JUST LASTLY NOTE
THAT THESE COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE
PASSED ON TO CONSUMERS THROUGH
HIGHER PREMIUMS. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 815 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 869,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANY ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. AT THE TIME OF THE
ANALYSIS OF AN UPDATED FISCAL
IMPACT WAS NOT AVAILABLE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION. HOWEVER,
BASED ON PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF
THE BILL FROM 2023, HØI
ESTIMATED THE FISCAL IMPACTS TO
BE 155,000 SMALL AND RURAL
HOSPITAL RELIEF FUND IN 2425,
AND ONGOING TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM IF ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATED. HØI DOES ESTIMATE
902,024, 25, AND 763 ANNUALLY
FOR THE FIVE YEARS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD
LIKELY RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN
THE STATE'S SPENDING PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL DOES
PROPOSE EXPANSION OF ELIGIBILITY.
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION OF
ELIGIBILITY MAY ALSO CREATE
PRESSURES ON AVAILABLE FUNDING
FROM THE SMALL RURAL HOSPITAL
RELIEF PROGRAM. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 869 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2643 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THAT MEANS HE WON'T
BE HERE TODAY. IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ FILE
ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS BY THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2643 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3129 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THEY WERE LEFT OPEN.
YES. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MARK
APRIL, I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN INVESTMENT COUNCIL. OUR
OPPOSITION ON THE FISCAL GROUNDS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THIS MEASURE
WILL COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IT IS DUPLICATIVE OF THE REVIEW
FUNCTION THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
DONE BY THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. FURTHER,
THIS MEASURE ALSO FAILS TO
CONSIDER THE LITIGATION COSTS
THAT WILL BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS MEASURE THAT WILL BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT WILL NOT
ONLY IMPACT THE APPLICANTS, IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO ASSIGN LAWYERS AND
TIME TO THIS. IT WILL ALSO COST
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MONEY
CONSISTENT WITH THE OPPOSITION
LETTER BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WE THEREFORE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, MY NAME IS FRED.
NOTE WE'RE REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS. WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL. HOWEVER,
WE WOULD NOTE AT THE TIME OF OUR
ANALYSIS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAD NOT PROVIDED A
FISCAL ESTIMATE OF
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS. HOWEVER,
BASED ON THE BILL'S PROVISION,
THE BILL WOULD LIKELY GENERATE
COSTS AND LOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
REVIEW TRANSACTIONS. THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES COSTS OF
216,000 GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO
HEAR UP TO THREE CASES. DGS
NOTES THAT THIS IS AN ESTIMATE
BASED ON ONE CASE LASTING 28
DAYS, WITH 6.5 HOURS OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. JUDGES TIME
PER DAY, WHICH EQUATES TO
$72,000 PER CASE AT THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. JUDGE RATE
OF $395 AN HOUR. ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3129 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE HAVING CHEN? OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO, OPEN UP THE ROLL
CALL IN A COUPLE OF THE BILLS
THAT WE DID AS Dð PASS MOTIONS
TO ALLOW, SENATOR JONES TO JOIN
IF HE'D LIKE. WELL FIRST UP WILL
BE. AND THEN WE'LL OPEN THEM ONE
MORE TIME FOR THE REMAINING
MEMBER THAT IS NOT PRESENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO AB 3100 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LO. THE MOTION
WAS DUE. PASS, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES. I JONES I BRADFORD 6 TO
0. THAT BILL HAS SIX VOTES 6 TO
0. AND WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO AB 2107
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES A, JONES I BRADFORD OKAY,
THAT'S 6 TO 0 AS WELL. AND SO
WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON CALL FOR
THE LAST REMAINING MEMBER TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON OKAY. SO WE'LL GO
BACK TO OUR AGENDA WHICH IS THE
NEXT UP IS AB 3218 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD WHO WAIVED
PRESENTATION. I'M GOING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. FOR
KIDS SUPPORT. OOPS. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. WE'LL START THAT OVER
AGAIN. GOT THE MIC UP CHLOE.
FERMIN WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
SUPPORTS 2827 ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE.
ECO SUSTAINABILITY. PEEPS ENCA
AND GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. DID SHE DO THE RIGHT
THING? ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOESN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD NOTE
THAT DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF $318,000 FROM
THE PUBLIC RIGHTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SPECIAL FUND AND
THREE POSITIONS IN 24, 25 AND
603,025 26. FINANCE DOES NOTE
THAT WHILE REVENUES FROM THE
APPLICATION OR RENEWAL FEES FOR
THE NEW CALIFORNIA FLAVORED
TOBACCO LIST FUND, WHICH COULD
BE AS HIGH AS $1,000 PAID TO DOJ
BY MANUFACTURERS AND IMPORTERS,
ARE UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. SO
THESE REVENUES COULD OFFSET AT
LEAST A PORTION OF DOJ'S COST TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL. IN ADDITION
TO THAT, Ã CDTFA DOES ESTIMATE
COSTS OF UP TO 50,000. GENERAL
FUND IN 24, 25, AND ONGOING FOR
THE WORKLOAD. THEY ALSO NOTE
THAT THEY MAY INCUR SUBSTANTIAL
MEANING ABOUT 250,000 TO $1
MILLION TO MAJOR OR GREATER THAN
$1 MILLION ADDITIONAL ONGOING
COST FOR THE DESTRUCTION,
DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT AND TYPE
OF TAX PAID. FLAVORED CIGARETTES
AND TOBACCO PRODUCTS THAT ARE
SEIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE NO LONGER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE, SO THERE WON'T BE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. SO
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
3218 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
846 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. THAT MAKES IT
EASY. QUICK, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 846 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1186 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1186.
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD WAS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE A FISCAL ESTIMATE.
HOWEVER, FINANCE NOTES THAT
COMPENSATION FOR VICTIMS ARE
GENERALLY FUNDED BY PENALTY
ASSESSMENTS AND RESTITUTION,
FINES AND ORDERS PAID INTO THE
RESTITUTION FUND. THE
RESTITUTION FUND CURRENTLY
OPERATES IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT, AND THE FINES
ELIMINATED IN DEBTS VACATED BY
THIS BILL WILL FURTHER REDUCE
FUND REVENUES. SO UNFORTUNATELY,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
TO BACKFILL THE RESTITUTION FUND
FOR THE ANTICIPATED REDUCTION OF
REVENUES. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1186 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2239 IS A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA BILL WHO HAS AND
SHE'S WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ. ON
BEHALF OF THE DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. CARLY STELZER, ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE?
HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
GOOD MORNING. AMANDA GUADERRAMA
WITH CAL BROADBAND AND ALSO
TESTIFYING FOR US TELECOM IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. FILE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATE SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2239 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2381 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
WHO WAIVED PRESENTATION IS NEXT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2381. WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
BILL WOULD MAY RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND IMPACTS TO THE EXTENT THAT
RESULT THAT THIS RESULTS IN AN
EROSION OF POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE
SAVINGS. ADDITIONALLY, IN
ADDITION, PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL MAY BE DUPLICATIVE OF
RECENT ONGOING EFFORTS TO REFORM
REIMBURSEMENT RATE POLICIES
AMONG CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2381 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2476 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? YES, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2476. THE BILL WILL RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
AT A MINIMUM, TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES, TO ONE
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
ABOVE THE LEVEL ENACTED IN
STATUTE. REMOVE THE JUNE 30TH,
2025 SUNSET DATE TO REIMBURSE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BASED ON
MAXIMUM AUTHORIZED HOURS OF
CARE, UPDATE PAYMENT PROCESSING
PROGRAM OR SYSTEMS, AND ADDRESS
INCREASED ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO CONTRACTORS IN ADDITION, THIS
BILL DOES CONFLICT WITH THE
STATE'S STATUTORY CURRENT
STATUTORY COMMITMENT TO
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM. SO
UNFORTUNATELY, FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NONE THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2476 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2709 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ,
DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? NO FILE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING. NONE THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2709 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2851 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO. SHE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CHLOE FERMIN
WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS SUPPORTS
2851 ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. FACTS. NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2851. THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL REPORTS. THE
BILL COSTS $700,000 FROM THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
AND 2526 1.2 MILLION IN 2627 AND
1,000,000 IN 2728, AND ONGOING
FOR THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS.
THE BILL DOES AUTHORIZE DTSC TO
ASSESS FEES ON METAL SHREDDING
FACILITIES, SUPPORT COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL. IN
ADDITION, AT THE TIME OF OUR
ANALYSIS ANALYSIS, FINANCE WAS
NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN A FISCAL
ESTIMATE FROM THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN COSTS AND PRESSURES
TO THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL PLAN. OKAY.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS? SEEING NONE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE. FILE
CANDIDATES OR WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB 2851 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
3161 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL. HOWEVER,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT WHILE A
FISCAL ESTIMATE WAS NOT
AVAILABLE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT
THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS, THAT
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES COST
BETWEEN 1 MILLION AND 2 MILLION
IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND ONGOING COST
IN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS TO LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER, FROM THE LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION FUND. BASED ON
PREVIOUS ESTIMATES, THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT ALSO ESTIMATES
ONGOING COST IN THE HIGH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND,
ASSUMING AN ESTIMATED INCREASE
IN 50 TO 100 ADDITIONAL
COMPLAINTS PER YEAR. QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3161 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO
AB 884 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ,
DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 884.
SECRETARY OF STATE'S SECRETARY
OF STATE ESTIMATES COST OF $22.4
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND AND 2425
16.4 MILLION ONGOING IN 25
POSITIONS. TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL, CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
ESTIMATES THE COST OF $890,000.
GENERAL FUND. IN 24, 25 AND 1.3
MILLION ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL. THEREFORE WE ARE OPPOSED
BECAUSE THE COSTS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY PART OF THE STATE'S,
FUNDING PLAN. COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS, SEEING NONE, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 884 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 996 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORT TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ. FILE COMMITTEE
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 996 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
1577 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. SEEING NO
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB 1577 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2132 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2132.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE. OR I'M SORRY? THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ESTIMATES $96,000 IN 24,
25, AND 166,000 ONGOING FROM THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FUND
TO ASSESS AND FORCE COMPLIANCE
OF 1450 FACILITIES, INCLUDING RE
LICENSURE SURVEYS AND COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS. AT THE TIME OF
OUR ANALYSIS, A FISCAL ESTIMATE
WAS NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, BUT FINANCE WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
MEDI-CAL TO THE EXTENT IT
RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
AND HIGHER COSTS TO REIMBURSE
MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS FOR
THIS BILL'S REQUIREMENTS.
THEREFORE, WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT
ARE NOT A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FISCAL PLAN.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2132 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
2148 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THAT CONVERSATIONS
WILL ENABLE THE ANTICIPATED COST
TO BE MINIMIZED SO THAT THE
EXISTING LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW
CAN BE CLOSED TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THAT. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL FILE
I'M SEEING NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2148 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2421 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? I THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES, THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION, AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN OPPOSITION TO
2421. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI.
GOOD MORNING. SHARON GONSALVES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICTS, IN OPPOSITION,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2421.
WHILE WE DO ANTICIPATE THE BILL
MAY RESULT IN MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE COSTS TO THE STATE,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT EXPANDS THE SCOPE OF
EXISTING UNION EMPLOYEE
CONFIDENTIALITY OUTSIDE OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS,
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY AND
INVESTIGATE ISSUES OF WORKPLACE
SAFETY AND HARASSMENT WITHOUT
INITIATING A DISCIPLINARY OR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION. SEEING
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FOR CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, 2421 WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. 2883 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO 2883. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
ESTIMATES THAT AN ADDITIONAL
HOLIDAY COULD REPRESENT A COST
TO THE CSU OF APPROXIMATELY
$21.2 MILLION IN LOST
PRODUCTIVITY, AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH ADJUSTING THE ACADEMIC
CALENDAR. FINANCE ASSUMES THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THIS LOST
PRODUCTIVITY WOULD RESULT IN
CORRESPONDING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REPORTS NO MANDATORY
MANDATORY COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BILL, BECAUSE IT'S MERELY A
REQUEST AND DOES NOT REQUIRE
THEM TO TAKE ACTION. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES SIGNIFICANT, ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES.
DURING A FISCAL YEAR IN WHICH
BOTH THE CSU AND UC SYSTEMS WILL
BE PREPARING TO IMPLEMENT
ONGOING STATE APPROPRIATION
REDUCTIONS. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2883 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2892 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2892 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3034 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3234.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
REPORTS THE COST OF A NEW
TUITION AND FEE WAIVER WILL VARY
YEAR TO YEAR AND COULD INCREASE
OVER TIME, DEPENDING ON HOW MANY
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
MEMBERS ENROLL AT A CSU CAMPUS.
THE SYSTEM COULD FACE BETWEEN
900 AND 7009.7 MILLION IN
FOREGONE REVENUE. THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA REPORTS IT WILL
EXPERIENCE A LOSS IN TUITION OF
FEE REVENUE. AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT,
BUT POTENTIALLY IN THE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AS THEY DO NOT
CURRENTLY TRACK HOW MANY
STUDENTS CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE
IN THE C.C.C. AND THEY'RE UNABLE
TO PREDICT HOW MANY WOULD
PARTICIPATE IF THE BILL WAS
ENACTED. SO THEREFORE, THE
EXCUSE ME, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES REVENUE
LOSSES OF UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES, ALSO, WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WHILE THE
BILL AIMS TO BENEFIT
PARTICIPANTS IN A PROGRAM THAT
OFFERS YOUNG PEOPLE SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCES THAT COULD LEAD TO
MEANINGFUL CAREERS, IT WOULD
LIMIT REVENUE SOURCES FOR THE UC
AND CSU SYSTEMS. DURING A FISCAL
YEAR IN WHICH BOTH SYSTEMS ARE
PREPARING TO IMPLEMENT ONGOING
STATE APPROPRIATION REDUCTIONS.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FOR ALL CANDIDATES.
SO AB 3034 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 886 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? CARLY STELZER ON BEHALF
OF MUSIC ARTISTS COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? HELLO, DANNY
CANDLE KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. SEEING NO
COMMENT OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 886 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 922 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 922,
THE ANNUAL COST OF THE PROGRAM
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE DEPENDS ON
HOW MANY COUNTIES ELECT TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM, WHICH
COULD BE IN THE MAGNITUDES OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
THE GENERAL FUND. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO RESULT IN UNKNOWABLE,
UNKNOWN, BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING STATE
OPERATION COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THE BILL COULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE, CURRENTLY
OF AN INDETERMINABLE COST,
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PILOT PROGRAM AND SUBMIT
PERFORMANCE DATA REPORTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT AND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET ACT AND COULD RESULT
IN A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE.
SEEING NO COMMENT QUESTIONS.
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FOR ALL
CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 922 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1252 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1252.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF 656,000,
GENERAL FUND IN 24, 25 AND 1.2
MILLION IN 25, 26 AND ONGOING
FOR SIX POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH
THE OFFICE OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION, DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE NOTES IT IS UNABLE TO
ABSORB THE COST TO COMPLY WITH
OR IMPLEMENT THIS BILL WITHIN
THEIR EXISTING RESOURCES FOR
FINANCE, AS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT GENERATES ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT. SEEING
NO COMMENTS, QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB 1252 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1949 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CHLOE FERMIN
WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS .ORG
SUPPORTS THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY,
PEEPS AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO AND
STANDING UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO, CARLY STELZER, ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE. CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1949 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1961 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HELLO. SHARON
GONSALVES WITH THE CITY OF
MERCED IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JENNIFER.
FEARING FOR COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MARIA O'SULLIVAN WITH
THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS IS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1961, THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF LAND USE AND CLIMATE
INNOVATION ESTIMATES COSTS OF
3.7 MILLION IN 24, 25 AND 2.2
MILLION IN 2526. THESE COSTS
ACCOUNT FOR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND TASK FORCE
FACILITATION. TRAVEL STAFF
ENGAGEMENT SUBCOMMITTEE
MEETINGS, FOOD ACCESS ANALYSIS,
AND ADMINISTRATIVE AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT FOR PROGRAM STAFF.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN 2024 BUDGET,
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1961 WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. RIGHT, RIGHT.
IN THE SAME DESK. YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH. SO.
IF YOU JUST GIVE US A MINUTE, WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THAT ARRIVED AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE FIND THE BILL.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON IN THE
AGENDA. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE AGENDA AND TAKE
UP AB 2918 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CZIBOR, WHO IS HERE. AND I
UNDERSTAND IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE, NURSE SCRIPT, IF YOU
WANT TO. OKAY. I'LL GIVE YOU
THAT. SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE, BUT, YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND. OKAY. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. WELL GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING, GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ALONG WITH JOINT AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND OUR
SPONSOR, STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION, TONY
THURMOND, AND THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2918, A
BILL THAT STRENGTHENS ETHNIC
STUDIES. AB 2019 IS A JEWISH
CAUCUS PRIORITY, AND AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR OVER 20
YEARS WHO SERVED BOTH STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND EMERGENT
BILINGUAL STUDENTS, I HAVE
ALWAYS WORKED TO CREATE A SAFE,
INCLUSIVE AND AFFIRMING
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT FOR
DIVERSE STUDENT GROUPS. BEST
PRACTICE TELLS US THAT SUCH
ENVIRONMENTS WE MUST PROVIDE
MIRRORS WHERE STUDENTS LEARN
THEIR OWN HISTORY AND SEE
THEMSELVES ACCURATELY REFLECTED
IN THE CURRICULUM AND WINDOWS,
WHERE STUDENTS LEARN ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND STORIES ABOUT
DIVERSE PEOPLE. ESSENTIALLY A
WINDOW INTO THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
BEST PRACTICE ALSO USES
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CURRICULUM
AND INSTRUCTION THAT PROMOTES
INCLUSIVITY AND EQUITY BY
ACKNOWLEDGING AND VALUING
DIFFERENT CULTURES, ETHNIC
STUDIES IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PART OF PROVIDING
WINDOWS AND MIRRORS FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE WITNESSING
HARMFUL SITUATIONS WHERE
INTENTIONALLY OR NOT, SOME
ETHNIC STUDIES, CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION IS CREATING
CLASSROOMS THAT JEWISH STUDENTS
ARE NOT EXPERIENCING AS SAFE,
INCLUSIVE OR AFFIRMING AB 2918
HELPS RECTIFY THIS SITUATION BY
REQUIRING THAT ETHNIC STUDIES
ADHERES TO CULTURAL COMPETENCY
PRACTICES, EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF MULTICULTURALISM
AND TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES AND
ACTIVATING THE EXISTING AB 101
GUARDRAILS SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER. AB 2918 AFFIRMS THE
IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC STUDIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION,
COMPLEMENTS THE MODEL
CURRICULUM, AND ENSURES THAT ALL
STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED ACCURATE
AND AFFIRMING MIRRORS AND
WINDOWS. WHAT AB 2918 DOES NOT
DO IS IT DOES NOT ERASE OR
ELIMINATE TEACHING OF THE
STORIES OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
STUDENT BODY. IT DOES NOT CREATE
BARRIERS TO ETHNIC STUDIES
PROGRAMS AS ENVISIONED IN THE
MODEL CURRICULUM, AND IT DOES
NOT CONTRADICT AB 101 OR MAKE
ETHNIC STUDIES MORE EXPENSIVE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS REMOVED
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZEBRA WILL
TALK ABOUT IN MORE DETAIL. AT
ITS CORE, ETHNIC STUDIES IS A
STEP TOWARD RECTIFYING OMISSION
OF THE EXPERIENCES AND CULTURES
OF COMMUNITIES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. BUT AS WE RIGHT
THESE WRONGS OF THE PAST, WE
MUST DO SO IN A PRESENT THAT IS
WHOLLY FOCUSED ON CREATING SAFE,
INCLUSIVE AND AFFIRMING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MULTICULTURAL STUDENT BODY SO
THAT EVERY STUDENT SEES
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THEIR
CURRICULUM AND FEELS EMPOWERED,
UNDERSTOOD AND REPRESENTED. AB
2918 IS A SIMPLE BILL WITH
LITTLE TO NO COST THAT WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY MOVE US FORWARD
AND WITH THAT, I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZABIR. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS, I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 2918, WHICH AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAMS HAS INDICATED, IS A
KEY PRIORITY FOR BILL FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS, IN
CALIFORNIA, WE CELEBRATE OUR
DIVERSITY, RECOGNIZING IT AS A
CORNERSTONE OF OUR VALUES AND
STRENGTH AS A COMMUNITY. AS
SUCH, IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WHAT IS
TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS REFLECTS
THIS DIVERSITY, FOSTERING
UNDERSTANDING, RESPECT, AND
APPRECIATION FOR THE MULTITUDE
OF CULTURAL PERSPECTIVES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT ENRICH OUR
SOCIETY. ETHNIC STUDIES OFFERS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO
BOTH LEARN ABOUT COMMUNITIES
OTHER THAN THEIR OWN, AND TO SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
STORIES THEY HEAR AT SCHOOL, THE
WINDOWS AND THE MIRRORS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS JUST
TALKED ABOUT. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
ORIGINAL DRAFT OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM THAT
WAS RELEASED IN 2019 WAS WIDELY
CRITICIZED NOT ONLY BY THE
GOVERNOR AND OTHER STATE
LEADERS, BUT ALSO BY MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES IT WAS AIMED TO
UPLIFT DUE TO MISLEADING, FALSE,
AND BIASED, SOMETIMES BIASED
CONTENT. IN THE DRAFT. AFTER
SUBSEQUENT LENGTHY, TRANSPARENT
AND PUBLIC PROCESS, THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
REPLACED THE FIRST DRAFT IN 2021
WITH AN ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY
THE GOVERNOR, THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT, AND CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. DISTRICTS
RETAINED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS MODEL CURRICULUM
OR TO ADOPT LOCALLY DEVELOPED
CURRICULA, FOR EXAMPLE, TO
TAILOR THEIR CLASSES TO THEIR
LOCAL HERITAGES AND COMMUNITIES.
IN 2021, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
ADVANCED AB 101, WHICH CONTAINED
IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THAT CURRICULUMS BEING ADOPTED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WOULD STILL
ALIGN WITH STATE GOALS AND NOT
PROMOTE BIAS, BIGOTRY, OR
DISCRIMINATION TO ANY COMMUNITY.
SINCE THE MODEL CURRICULUM
SERVES AS A GUIDE RATHER THAN
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE STATE
APPROVED INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS, THERE ARE NO
PROCEDURAL SAFEGUARDS AT EITHER
THE STATE OR LOCAL LEVEL TO
PROTECT AGAINST BIAS OR
DISCRIMINATION. IF DISTRICTS
DEVIATE OR DEVIATE FROM THE
MODEL CURRICULUM. PROMOTERS OF
THE REJECTED 2019 MODEL HAVE
EXPLOITED THIS GAP, ATTEMPTING
TO DISCREETLY INSERT BIASED
CONTENT INTO LOCAL COURSES AND
URGING DISTRICTS TO ADOPT
MATERIALS THAT DEVIATE FROM
STATE APPROVED GUIDELINES,
UNDERMINING THE EXTENT EXTENSIVE
PUBLIC EDUCATION PROCESS THAT
OCCURRED. AS A RESULT, SOME
SCHOOLS HAVE ADOPTED AND BEGUN
UTILIZING CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT ARE
INACCURATE AND BIASED AND
PROMOTE THE TARGETING OF JEWISH
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES, AND MANY
TIMES, FAMILIES HAVE FOUND OUT
ABOUT IT ONLY AFTER THE
OBJECTIONABLE MATERIAL WAS
ALREADY BEING TAUGHT IN
CLASSROOMS. WE ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A PROBLEM THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS WHEN A
MARGINALIZED OR MINORITY
COMMUNITY TELLS US THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE AND SEE BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION, IT'S OUR DUTY TO
LISTEN TO THAT COMMUNITY BECAUSE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
RECOGNIZE THE PATTERNS OF
DISCRIMINATION THEY RECOGNIZE
THE TROPES AND THEY RECOGNIZE
WHAT THEY KNOW TO BE HARMFUL
BASED ON THEIR OWN LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND WHAT IS HAPPENING
TODAY ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IS THAT
EDUCATIONAL CONTENT THAT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RECOGNIZES AS
BIASED AND ANTI-SEMITIC IS
SOMETIMES BEING PROPOSED AND
USED IN OUR SCHOOLS. SO WE NEED
TO TAKE STEPS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S COURSE CORRECTED. SO AB
2918 CONTAINS TWO MAJOR
COMPONENTS. FIRST, IT HAS
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS THAT
MAKE SURE THAT PARENTS HAVE
NOTICE THAT AN ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM IS BEING ADOPTED IN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT, CAN
REVIEW IT AND CAN PROVIDE INPUT
TO THE DISTRICT BEFORE IT'S
ADOPTED. WE HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS,
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
EDUCATION UNIONS AND OTHER
IMPORTANT PARTNERS WHOSE
PARTNERSHIP WE VALUE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS. THAT IS
WHY, IN ORDER TO HAVE TIME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THESE
STAKEHOLDERS, WE ARE AMENDING
THE BILL THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
TO REMOVE THE TRANSPARENCY
PROCEDURES AT THIS TIME. THIS
AMENDMENT WILL ALSO ELIMINATE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL THE COSTS
RELATED TO THE BILL. WE INTEND
TO PROPOSE A NEW BILL NEXT YEAR
IN ORDER TO REFINE THESE
TRANSPARENCY PROCEDURES OR
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT THE EDUCATION UNIONS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS MAY PROPOSE
AS AN ALTERNATIVES. SO WHAT
REMAINS OF 2918 ARE IMPORTANT
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE GUARDRAILS
ESTABLISHED UNDER AB 101 THAT
PROTECT ALL. AND I WANT TO SAY
THIS. IT'S NOT JUST THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY, IT'S ALL MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. ONE THING THE BILL
DOES IS TO MAKE THE GUARDRAILS
EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY 2025. THE
GUARDRAILS TODAY ARE NOT
EFFECTIVE, AND IT'S CRUCIAL THAT
THESE ARE IN PLACE AS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS IN ANTICIPATING THE
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. SECOND,
THE BILL STRENGTHENS THE
GUARDRAILS BY ADDING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT DETERMINATIONS
ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES, CURRICULUM
INCORPORATE PRINCIPLES OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. THIS MEANS
THAT WHEN A SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
DETERMINING WHETHER EDUCATIONAL
CONTENT IS BIASED OR APPROPRIATE
FOR USE IN OUR SCHOOLS, THE
DISTRICT MUST CONSIDER THE VIEWS
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT THE
CURRICULUM IS ABOUT AND EFFECTS.
AB 2918 ALSO ASSURES THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES PROMOTE
MULTICULTURAL RESPECT AND
ACCEPTANCE, WHILE FOCUSING ON
THE HISTORIES, CULTURES,
STRUGGLES, AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES. THESE GUARDRAILS PROTECT
ALL COMMUNITIES AND REFLECT THE
CORE PRINCIPLE THAT MARGINALIZED
AND MINORITY COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING THE JEWISH COMMUNITY,
SHOULD SHAPE THE EDUCATIONAL
CONTENT ABOUT THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCES, CHALLENGES, AND
HISTORY, AND THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE A VOICE IN DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THEM. FOR EXAMPLE,
WITHOUT THIS BILL, WE RISK
DISTRICTS, INCLUDING BIASED AND
FALSE CONTENT, ABOUT OTHER
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES AS WELL,
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE SAW IN
FLORIDA, WHERE OUTRAGEOUS
EDUCATIONAL CONTENT WAS
PROPOSED, TEACHING THAT ELEMENTS
OF SLAVERY WERE BENEFICIAL. SO
REGARDING THE COSTS, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF HAS CONCLUDED THAT THE
COST OF AB 2918 ARE UNKNOWN.
HOWEVER, WITH THE AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS WHICH WE HAVE
SUBMITTED, THERE ARE NO
SUBSTANTIAL ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL. WITH
THE AMENDMENTS, THE BILL MERELY
MODIFIES THE AB 101 GUARDRAILS.
THE BILL REQUIRES MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE LEGAL
STANDARDS THAT LEAS MUST
CONSIDER THAT SHOULD NOT RESULT
IN ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
LOCAL FOR LEAS, AS THE ADOPTION
OF AN ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM
IS CURRENTLY VOLUNTARY AND
CONTINGENT UPON THE
APPROPRIATION OF FUNDS, THE BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE OR IMPEDE A
DISTRICT FROM ADOPTING AN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE, AND THE COST OF
THE ADOPTION ARE NOT AFFECTED AT
ALL BY THIS CHANGE IN THE LEGAL
STANDARD. IN CLOSING, IN MY
PREVIOUS CAREER, WHEN I WAS AT A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA, WE PARTNERED
WITH THE DIVERSITY CAUCUSES AND
I PERSONALLY NOT ONLY SUPPORTED,
BUT I MYSELF LOBBIED FOR THE
ADOPTION OF ETHNIC STUDIES. AND
I POINT OUT THAT EVERY MEMBER OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS VOTED FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES. I KNOW, AND THE
CAUCUS KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT THIS
CURRICULUM IS TO UPLIFTING AND
PROVIDING BOTH MIRRORS AND
WINDOWS AS ASSEMBLY MATTER HAS
DISCUSSED TO THE EXPERIENCES AND
LIVES OF OUR ETHNIC COMMUNITIES.
BUT AS WE PROCEED WITH THIS
IMPORTANT CURRICULUM, IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
FOR ALL STUDENTS. WE CAN HAVE
ROBUST ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
THAT LIFT UP ALL ALL
COMMUNITIES, ALL ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
FOR AND LIFT UP ALL STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S WHAT AB 2918 IS
INTENDED TO DO WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ARE DOCTOR
MIKE TORRES, DIRECTOR OF THE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND DAVID PARSLEY
FROM JPAC. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS,
I GAVE YOU GREAT DISCRETION TO
TELL ME THE WHOLE, POLICY REASON
WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT. AND I, I
IT'S THAT'S ALL GOOD, BUT THIS
IS THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AND SO OUR REAL
REVIEW, AT LEAST TODAY, IS, IS,
THE WAY THE BILL IS IN WRITING
THIS MINUTE AND, AND IT'S THE
FISCAL IMPACT. AND SO IT IT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. I UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE GOING TO BE PROPOSING SOME
AMENDMENTS, THAT MAY CHANGE THAT
AT A LATER DATE. AND SO THAT'S
THE REASON I ALLOWED SO MUCH
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU. BUT IF,
IF, IF I COULD, WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE WHO ARE GOING TO,
TESTIFY. I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THROUGH THEM. AND I HAVE 354
BILLS TODAY TO GET THROUGH. AND
I THINK WE'VE PROBABLY GOT
THROUGH ABOUT 70. YES. SO, I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
REALLY EFFICIENT WITH OUR TIME,
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING NOT ONLY THE FISCAL
IMPACT, WHICH I APPRECIATE, BUT
ALSO THE CONTEXT. AND I DO
APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S VERY, VERY HELPFUL. SO IF
YOUR WITNESS COULD MAKE IT AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE ON THE FISCAL
PART OF IT, WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT ANY AMENDS THAT YOU HAVE
PROPOSED. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT BECAUSE IT MAKES OUR
JOB A LOT EASIER IF THE FISCAL
IMPACTS ARE LESS SO. SIR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS, BUT MAKE IT VERY
BRIEF. I DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
INTERRUPT THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC,
BUT I DO HAVE OTHER THINGS I
NEED TO GET TO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SO I'M DOCTOR
MIKE TORRES, DIRECTOR OF THE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION. I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND ON AB 2918,
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND IS A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. AS YOU
KNOW, ETHNIC STUDIES PROVIDES A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR TO LEARN ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THEIR
ANCESTORS, SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING
ON THE FOUR FOUNDATIONAL
DISCIPLINES OF ETHNIC STUDIES
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAVE ENCOURAGED
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
FOCUS ON THE FOUR GROUPS AND TO
FOLLOW THE MODEL. ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM GUIDE WHEN CREATING
THEIR LOCAL CURRICULA. IT'S FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION SUPPORTS THE GOALS
AND THE DIRECTION OF THIS BILL,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB 2918. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI, SENATOR AND
MEMBERS CHAIR. MY NAME IS DAVID
BOCARSLY AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF JPAC, THE LARGEST
SINGLE STATE COALITION OF JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NATION. AND
THE GROUP THAT HAS BROUGHT A
NUMBER OF THE FOLKS UP HERE
TODAY, OUR COALITION HAS BEEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM, WHICH
WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE THE FIRST
DRAFT WAS REPLETE WITH
ANTI-SEMITIC AND ANTI-ISRAEL
CONTENT. AND WE CELEBRATED THE
FINAL APPROVED CURRICULUM, WHICH
ADDRESSES OUR CONCERNS, REMAINS
TRUE TO THE FOUR CORE GROUPS,
AND IS A TRAILBLAZING MODEL FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES. OUR COALITION
MEMBERS ARE NOW WORKING WITH
STUDENTS, FAMILIES AND SCHOOL
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE AS
DISTRICTS IMPLEMENT ETHNIC
STUDIES AHEAD OF THE 2025
DEADLINE. UNFORTUNATELY, IN TOO
MANY DISTRICTS, WE ARE SEEING
THAT THIS COURSE IS BEING
CO-OPTED BY THOSE WITH AN
ANTI-JEWISH BIAS. INSTEAD OF
USING APPROVED LESSONS FROM THE
MODEL CURRICULUM, SOME DISTRICTS
ARE TEACHING LIBERATORY COURSES,
WHICH IS SIMILAR EXCEPT THAT IT
EXCLUDES JEWS, ERASES
ANTI-SEMITISM, AND DENIGRATES
ISRAEL WITH CONTENT THAT IS ONE
SIDED, PROMOTES A SPECIFIC
IDEOLOGY, AND IS FACTUALLY
INACCURATE. IN EFFECT, A
CURRICULUM MEANT TO HELP
ALLEVIATE ALLEVIATE BIGOTRY IS
INSTEAD MARGINALIZING JEWISH
STUDENTS AND FUELING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST OUR
COMMUNITY. THIS BILL INITIALLY
INCLUDED THE TRANSPARENT AND
COMMUNITY LED IMPLEMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S B¢O REFERENCED,
AND WHICH WE DID ADVOCATE FOR,
ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN AMENDED
OUT, AND THIS BILL SIMPLY ADDS
BASIC GUARDRAILS, SUCH AS
PROMOTING RESPECT AND
CONSIDERING THE VIEWS OF
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY
WITHOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS OUR COMMUNITY
NEEDS. THESE GUARDRAILS, AND IF
THE OPPOSITION DISPUTES THE NEED
FOR SUCH BASIC PROTECTIONS
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION, THAT
HIGHLIGHTS WHY THESE PROTECTIONS
ARE ALL THE MORE NECESSARY. SOME
OF THESE FOLKS HAVE TARGETED
LEADING JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE JCRC AND ADL. I HATE TO
INTERRUPT YOU. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION, BUT NOT
FOR THIS COMMITTEE. WHAT IS
IMPORTANT IS THE FISCAL IMPACT
AND SO I REALLY APOLOGIZE. NØ I
APPRECIATE IT'S NOT THAT I
DISAGREE OR ANYTHING. I JUST
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT. AND THEN SURE,
CHAIR, I APPRECIATE IT. AND
THANK YOU, AS MENTIONED, THE
FOCUS ON THE GUARDRAILS IS
BECAUSE THIS SHOULD NOT HAVE ANY
FISCAL IMPACT. AND THAT IS, THE
ATTEMPT THAT IS WHY IT'S SO
NECESSARY TO PASS THIS BILL.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ENACT POLICIES THAT DO NOT
CHANGE THE COST FOR THE STATE OR
TO LOCALITIES. WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
RISING ANTI-SEMITISM IN SOCIETY
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND WE VIEW ETHNIC STUDIES AS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO USE EDUCATION
TO COUNTER SUCH HATRED, BUT ONLY
IF IT HAS THE GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE IT IS UNBIASED. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. I WANT TO WELCOME YOU
TO THE MIC. WHO'S GOING TO BE
FIRST? BRAVE. MY NAME IS SCOTT
WIEDERMAN. I LIVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. I'M A VETERAN AND I
SERVED AS AN OFFICER IN THE ARMY.
I'M. BUT I'M HERE AS A PARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN, ONE OF WHOM IS
SPECIAL NEEDS. BOTH HAVE BEEN A
VICTIMS OF ANTI-SEMITISM
FACILITATED BY BIASED
INDOCTRINATING ACADEMIC
CURRICULUM. I URGE YOU, I
URGENTLY SUPPORT URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS MARK
LEVINE WITH THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE. VERY GOOD TO SEE YOU
THIS MORNING, I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER ZUBER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GOOD AFTERNOON. JONATHAN MINTZER
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL. WE ARE THE
LARGEST COLLECTIVE VOICE OF BAY
AREA JEWS, REPRESENTING OVER 65
SYNAGOGUES, AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LYNN
LAZARUS, MEMBER OF KEHILLAH AND
NCW. I'M ALSO A RETIRED TEACHER
OF 30 YEARS AND CONCERNED ABOUT
BULLYING, AND I'M ALSO A
GRANDMOTHER AND I HAVE CHILDREN
IN THE SCHOOL, AND I'M A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI, MY NAME IS NAOMI GOLDMAN.
I'M AN EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF
DEMOCRATS FOR ISRAEL,
CALIFORNIA, AND A PROUD ADVOCATE
WITH THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
I'VE HAD MY OWN FAMILY AND MANY
IN MY LIFE IMPACTED AMONG
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES TARGETED
BY HATE. AND SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BRUCE
PALMER, JEWISH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION, IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 2918. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HELLO,
REBECCA PEARL, I'M AN INTERN AT
SAN DIEGO AMERICAN JEWISH
COMMITTEE AND A RISING SENIOR AT
UC DAVIS WHO NO LONGER FEELS
SAFE ON CAMPUS WEARING MY JEWISH
STAR NECKLACE. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, I'M SHERRI
DIMMERLING. I AM A FAIR HOUSING
EXECUTIVE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN, THE
JEWISH FEDERATION, AND THE
NATIONAL COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL, AND I STRONGLY ADVOCATE
FOR THIS AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
ROBYN LAYTON. I FLEW UP FROM SAN
DIEGO, RETIRED EDUCATOR, AND I
AM ON THE BOARD OF THE AJC IN
SAN DIEGO. I SUPPORT ETHNIC
STUDIES. I SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY,
AND I SUPPORT GUARDRAILS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'M VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SOPHIA MEYERHOFF. I
CAME UP FROM SAN DIEGO AND GREW
UP IN THE SAN DIEGO JEWISH
COMMUNITY. I'M A RECENT GRADUATE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND,
AND I'M THE COORDINATOR OF
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE SAN
DIEGO, AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI, I'M WENDY LEVY
BATTERSON. I AM THE FOUNDER OF
SAN DIEGO INDIVISIBLE,
ADVOCATING FOR PROGRESSIVE
CAUSES. THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS FOR ISRAEL.
AND I'M AFFILIATED WITH THE
JEWISH FEDERATION, THE AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMITTEE, AND JPAC. I
CAME FROM SAN DIEGO TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB 2918 FOR THE SAFETY
OF MY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DAVID GABRIEL. I'VE
COME HERE FROM NOVATO,
CALIFORNIA, WHERE I AM A MEMBER
OF THE NEVADA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER, I HAD MY BAR MITZVAH
MANY YEARS AGO, AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB 2918. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO, SANDY NIEVES HERE
WITH JPAC, ALSO A CHAPTER LEADER
OF ZIONS. I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT AN INVESTMENT INTO
BUILDING BRIDGES INTO OUR
COMMUNITY WILL OFFSET THE COSTS
OF HATRED AND DIVISION. LATER
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO, SKYLER
COHEN, I'M AN EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE UNION FOR REFORM
JUDAISM, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI, BRETT
CODER, I'M ALSO WITH ZIONS AND
JPAC AND I'M ALSO A FATHER OF A
NATIVE AMERICAN CHILD. AND SO
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HE'S LEARNING OR WHAT HE'S NOT
LEARNING IN SCHOOL. SO I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI, AMY SPADE, SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY IMPACT AT
THE BAY AREA JEWISH FEDERATION
AND MOTHER OF AN OAKLAND UNIFIED
HIGH SCHOOLER WHO HAS
EXPERIENCED HOSTILITY AND
BULLYING. BULLYING I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. JONATHAN
WARMUND, CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER AND
I REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL GIVEN
ITS MINIMAL IMPACT ON THE FISCAL
SITUATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON.
JESSICA BLACKHAWK WITH THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL, THE BAY AREA, AND ALSO
TWO CHILDREN THAT GRADUATED FROM
SAN JOSE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. KAREN
STILLER, PUBLIC SCHOOL PARENT,
AS WELL AS SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
JEWISH AFFAIRS FOR THE BAY AREA
JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL, WHERE WE HAVE WORKED
WITH COUNTLESS FAMILIES WHOSE
CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCED
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M LARRY, WANT TO TAKE A
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN JEWISH
COMMITTEE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND ANY BILL THAT
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE OF A
PERSON, NOT NOT NOT BASED ON
RELIGION OR COLOR OR ETHNIC
OTHER ETHNIC QUALITIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LOIS KELLERMAN,
PART OF HADASSAH, THE ZIONIST
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION. BUT I ALSO
HAVE BEEN, AN INSTRUCTOR AT SAN
JOSE STATE AND FOOTHILL COLLEGE
AND A HIGH SCHOOL MATH TEACHER
IN CALIFORNIA, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND I THINK
THAT NO JEWISH CHILDREN SHOULD
BE EXPOSED TO ANTI-SEMITIC
PROPAGANDA IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS BEN LEVY. I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF MY LOCAL BBYO
CHAPTER, WHICH IS A JEWISH YOUTH
GROUP, VICE PRESIDENT OF MY
LOCAL JEWISH STUDENT UNION. I'M
A STUDENT IN PALO ALTO HIGH
SCHOOL. AND ON BEHALF OF ALL MY
FRIENDS WHO COULDN'T BE HERE AND,
EVERYONE ELSE IN MY FAMILY AND
MY COMMUNITY, WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI, I'M DOREEN
KESSELMAN. I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE JEWISH DEMOCRATIC COALITION
OF THE BAY AREA. WE HAVE FOUR
COUNTIES THAT I'M REPRESENTING
SANTA CLARA, SAN MATEO, SANTA
CRUZ, AND ALSO ALAMEDA COUNTIES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL,
AND I ALSO DO AS 20 YEARS
WORKING AS A SOCIAL WORKER IN
EDUCATION WITH MARGINALIZED
STUDENTS WHO ARE PART OF THE
BLACK. AND ALSO YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW, IN OUR AREA, SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT ARE MARGINALIZED IN
THE VIETNAMESE AND ALSO IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HISPANIC
AND IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES,
AS AS OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID,
WE ALL BENEFIT FROM THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. FROM
THIS, THIS WORK THAT IS BEING
DONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING IT. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR JAMES CASTLEMAN ON THE
BOARD OF THE JEWISH DEMOCRATIC
COALITION OF THE BAY AREA, I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS TERESA
DRENIK, AND I'M HERE AS ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE. I'M THE DEPUTY REGIONAL
DIRECTOR IN THE CENTRAL PACIFIC
REGION. I'M ALSO THE MOTHER OF
TWO PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS,
GRADUATES FROM HERE IN THE BAY
AREA. AND I'M THE DAUGHTER OF
TWO HOLOCAUST REFUGEES. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SETH
BRISK, I'M A MEMBER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON HOLOCAUST
AND GENOCIDE EDUCATION. I'M A
STUDENT OF ETHNIC STUDIES. I'M
ALSO THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE IN
SAN FRANCISCO. AND ON BEHALF OF
OUR OFFICES IN LOS ANGELES AND
SAN DIEGO AS WELL, WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI. I'M SANDY FAWN,
PUBLIC SCHOOL PARENT AND OUT OF
CONCERN FOR NOT ONLY MY
DAUGHTERS, BUT THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOU TO PLEASE,
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. I'M MARIAN LEFF, I'M
CO-PRESIDENT OF THE JEWISH
FEDERATION OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGION. I'M ALSO A GRANDMOTHER
AND MY GRANDCHILD. AND I NEED
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
STANLEY LEFF. I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF EINSTEIN JEWISH COMMUNITY
SERVICES IN SACRAMENTO, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI, NICK. SORRY, I'M
NANCY APEL, A SENIOR ASSOCIATE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR WITH THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE IN OUR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OFFICE. AND,
I AND ALSO A RESIDENT OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY. AND I JUST ECHO
WHAT MY COMMUNITY COLLEAGUE
KAREN STILLER SAID IN TERMS OF
JUST IT'S WHAT WE'VE JUST
EXPERIENCED IN THE SCHOOLS I'VE
BEEN AT ADL 20 YEARS IS JUST
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT. AND SO PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY, I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M ELLEN DIAMOND AND BOTH
MY CHILDREN ARE GRADUATES OF THE
OAKLAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I
AM EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE CURRICULUM
OF THE OAKLAND SCHOOLS. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I'M LEE DICHROIC. I'M ALSO AN
OAKLAND RESIDENT, I'M ALSO A
GRADUATE OF, OAKLAND. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND, UC
BERKELEY. AND NOW IT'S CALLED UC
LAW, SAN FRANCISCO, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MATTHEW BLOCK. I'M THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR AT THE AMERICAN JEWISH
COMMITTEE IN SAN DIEGO. IN SAN
DIEGO, THE ADDITIONAL GUARDRAILS
THAT THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE ARE
DEEPLY NEEDED, AND ESPECIALLY AS
SOMEBODY WHO PLANS TO BUILD A
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
CHILDREN, IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME. SO I'M FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO. MY
NAME IS NATANYA CRANFORD. MY
CHILDREN AND I ARE A PRODUCT OF
SAN DIEGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AND I
AM A BOARD MEMBER OF MY
CONGREGATION. I'M AFFILIATED
WITH THE JEWISH FEDERATION OF
SAN DIEGO, AND I'M ACTIVE IN A
SAN DIEGO INDIVISIBLE GROUP
ADVOCATING FOR PROGRESSIVE
ISSUES CALLED CHANGE BEGINS WITH
ME. I SUPPORT ETHNIC STUDIES AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
SUSAN KITCHELL. I'M A RESIDENT
OF SAN FRANCISCO. MY PARENTS
WERE HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS, MY
MOTHER AND AUSCHWITZ SURVIVOR. I
AM A RETIREE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO, MY
NAME IS JESSICA TRUBOWITZ WITH
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL OF THE BAY AREA AND A
PARENT OF AN EIGHTH GRADER WHO
WILL BE IN HIGH SCHOOL NEXT
YEAR. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO. I'M RAN FOR OFFICE. I AM
A PROFESSOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE OF THE ARTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO, WHERE I SPECIALIZE IN
VISUAL AND CULTURAL STUDIES. I
AM ALSO THE DAUGHTER OF TWO
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS WHO BECAME
VERY INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, VALUES THAT
THEY PASSED ON TO ME, WHICH HAVE
CLEARLY INFLUENCED MY TEACHING.
HOWEVER, I'VE SEEN MY FIELD ON
THE ACADEMIC LEVEL IN THE HIGHER
ED BE TRANSFORMED INTO A VERY
DIFFERENT IDEOLOGY, ONE THAT HAS
SERIOUSLY ISOLATED AND
OSTRACIZED JEWISH TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT SIGN ON TO A
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE IDEOLOGY. SO
UNFORTUNATELY, I SUPPORT ETHNIC
STUDIES STRONGLY. IT'S BASICALLY
WHAT I TEACH. BUT THIS BILL WILL
HOPEFULLY HELP PREVENT, PROTECT
THE RIGHTS AND SPEECH OF JEWS IN
THE FIELD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. PAT
CRAWFORD. I'M A MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER, A RETIRED TEACHER
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND A MEMBER OF
THE EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE
UNITED EDUCATORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO, RETIRED DIVISION I
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MYSELF IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. STUDENTS DESERVE A
SAFE AND WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT.
MY NAME IS LINDA POLLACK. I'M A
RETIRED TEACHER, BUT I STILL
WORK AS A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER AND
I ALSO NEED THE GUARDRAILS THAT
ARE IN THIS BILL BECAUSE AS A
MEMBER OF THE STAFF, I WANT A
SAFE AND WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT
WHEN I WALK INTO A CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M REBECCA
GOODMAN. I WAS RAISED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
WHERE I HEARD MY FIRST
ANTI-SEMITIC JOKE. I'M NOW
RAISING MY CHILDREN IN THE BAY
AREA, AND I DON'T WANT THEM TO
HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCE. I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2918. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO AGAIN.
SENATORS, I'M MICHAEL HARRIS,
I'M A LAY LEADER FOR STAND WITH
US, AN ORGANIZATION BASED IN LOS
ANGELES THAT COMBATS
ANTI-SEMITISM. AND PART OF THAT
ROLE I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND HAVE SEEN MULTIPLE
EXAMPLES OF ANTI-SEMITISM IN
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULA FROM
SAN DIEGO TO BERKELEY TO SANTA
ANA. THIS IS A NECESSARY BILL TO
HELP KEEP ANTI-SEMITISM OUT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CURRICULA AND
STAND WITH US. AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
FINKELSTEIN AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE JEWISH
DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF SOLANO COUNTY,
A SURVIVOR OF THE SECOND
INTIFADA AND I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. AB 2918 THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
SUSAN GEORGE. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE RAOUL
WALLENBERG JEWISH DEMOCRATIC
CLUB, AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO
AGAIN. I'M BARBARA NEMKO. I'VE
BEEN AN EDUCATOR FOR MORE THAN
50 YEARS, COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN NAPA FOR 27, AND A
MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES AT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
CONCERN THAT IT MIGHT COST MONEY,
BUT THE COST OF ALLOWING
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE SCHOOLS IS
INCALCULABLE. THANK YOU. I'M
JANNA WALDINGER, 27 YEARS
SERVING ON THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION AND A PRODUCT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SYSTEM.
AND I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THE IMPORTANT
GUARDRAILS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO. I AM BETH
FORSMAN FROM MILL VALLEY, AND I
AM WITH ALUMS FOR CAMPUS
FAIRNESS, THE LEAD FOR THE UC
DAVIS CHAPTER. I AM A PRODUCT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATION IN MARIN
COUNTY, AND I WAS OFTEN THE
TOKEN JEW. IN EACH OF MY
CLASSES. I WOULD FOLLOW MY
BROTHER HOME FROM SCHOOL. HE WAS
TARGETED AND STONED, AND I
REMEMBER HAVING TO PROTECT HIM,
AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO HAVE
OTHER CHILDREN TO BE PROTECTED
FROM THAT KIND OF ANTISEMITISM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO AGAIN. MY NAME IS ALAN
FISHER. I COME FROM ATHERTON AND
I'M A I WORK AT STANFORD AS A
PHYSICIST AT THE ACCELERATOR.
I'M A PAST PRESIDENT OF
CONGREGATION BETH JACOB. I AM A
MEMBER OF A COMMITTEE OF THREE
DEALING WITH ANTI-SEMITISM AS IT
AFFECTS OUR LOCAL SYNAGOGUE
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S TAKEN US
TO A LOT OF THE LOCAL SCHOOLS,
WE'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT
ANTI-SEMITISM IN ETHNIC STUDIES
AT THE SCHOOL. MY SON HAD
GRADUATED FROM MENLO-ATHERTON. I
KNOW SENATOR BECKER IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE LESSONS THAT
WERE TAUGHT. THERE AND WE CANNOT
HAVE THAT KIND OF, ANTI-SEMITISM
IN OUR SCHOOLS. WE NEED THE WE
NEED THIS LEGISLATION. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M ALISON
BARNES. I'M FROM I LIVE IN A
RURAL MENDOCINO COUNTY WHERE I
TAUGHT FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS AS A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER, TEACHING
GRADES KINDERGARTEN, FIFTH,
SIXTH, ALL SUBJECTS, MIDDLE
SCHOOL, ENGLISH, MATH, YOU NAME
IT, SCIENCE. I'VE DONE PRETTY
MUCH ALL OF IT, I AM A PARENT OF
YOUNG CHILDREN WHO WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, AND I THINK THAT,
STRONG AND INCLUSIVE ETHNIC
STUDIES IS KEY TO PREPARING OUR
STUDENTS TO MAKE OUR WORLD FAIR
AND JUST FOR EVERYONE. SO I'M IN
BIG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS DANIEL KLEIN, AND I'M CEO OF
JEWISH SILICON VALLEY, OUR
COMMUNITY DOESN'T THINK
ANTI-SEMITISM AND JEWISH HATE
SHOULD BE PART OF THE EDUCATION
PROCESS. AND SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO AGAIN,
ERIC KINGSLEY, ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PETER LEVY FROM ORANGE COUNTY,
CALIFORNIA, MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF RABBIS OF ORANGE COUNTY, THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR ADL,
ORANGE COUNTY, AND FOR MY
POSITIONS. WE NEED A ROBUST,
GUARDRAILS. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO, RACHEL WALLACE, DIRECTOR
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT WITH JEWISH
FEDERATION LOS ANGELES. WE
SUPPORT ETHNIC STUDIES AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RYAN PESA, SACRAMENTO RESIDENT.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I LIVE WITH THE BAY AREA
JEWISH COALITION. I HAVE THREE
KIDS WHO GO TO SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP GOING TO SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI
THERE. MY NAME IS MIRANDA
LICHTMAN. I'M THE ASSOCIATE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE IN LOS
ANGELES, AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI, I'M
NANCY GOLDBERG, PAST CHAIR OF
JPAC AND A PAST PRESIDENT OF
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES. AND I'M STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
DOUG JAFFE. I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
I WAS TRAINED ENTIRELY IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
STARTING IN PALO ALTO. I THINK
THIS BILL IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. WE NEED TO TEACH OUR
CHILDREN, NOT TO BE ANTI-SEMITIC
AND NOT WE NEED TO TEACH THEM
THE SIKHS TO SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HI THERE. I'M BETH
RUTCHICK FROM MILL VALLEY,
CALIFORNIA, AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF 2918. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, BEN HERMAN. I'M A RABBI
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AFTER SEEING
THE RISE IN ANTI-SEMITISM IN MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY, I'M STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF 2918 SETTING UP
GUARDRAILS THAT WE NEED FOR THE
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YAAKOV SUMAR, DIRECTOR OF
AGUDATH ISRAEL OF AMERICA'S
CALIFORNIA OFFICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR SETH
BRAMBLE, SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL 2918, ALTHOUGH WE
DID HAVE SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE BREAK WITH THE AUTHORS
AND ATTEMPTS TO IMPROVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ETHNIC
STUDIES, ULTIMATELY WE COULDN'T
GET THERE. AND I THINK EVEN AS
IS DISCUSSED WITH THE AMENDMENTS
ON LIMITING IT TO JUST
GUARDRAILS, WE'RE NOT LIKELY TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. OF COURSE.
A CAVEAT I NEED TO READ, YOU
KNOW, THE LANGUAGE WHEN IT GOES
INTO PRINT. ETHNIC STUDIES IS
THE RESULT OF A 50 YEAR STRUGGLE
WHEREIN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS HAVE
PUSHED FOR CURRICULUM THAT MORE
CLOSELY REFLECTS THE HISTORY AND
CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION. BUT THIS BILL IS
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE. IT
ESTABLISHES OBSTACLES TO ETHNIC
STUDIES, IMPLEMENTATION THAT WE
DON'T NEED AND UNDERMINES
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY OPERATING ACROSS THE
STATE. THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
UNNECESSARILY DUPLICATING LEGAL
FRAMEWORKS CAN LEAD TO CONFUSION.
BY CREATING AMBIGUITY AND
REDUNDANCY, IT CAN BE CONFUSING
HOW THESE PROVISIONS SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED TOGETHER. EDUCATORS
MAY HAVE ONE VIEW ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANS. LAWYERS MAY HAVE ANOTHER
VIEW ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS, AND IN
CALLING OUT ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES AND ONLY ETHNIC STUDIES
EDUCATORS IN SINGLING THEM OUT
AS THE ONLY DISCIPLINE WHERE WE
NEED EXTRA SCRUTINY AND WHERE WE
NEED EXTRA RED TAPE, TO ENSURE
THE CLASS IS APPROPRIATE FOR ALL
LEARNERS. THESE UNNECESSARY
HURDLES REPLICATE THE VERY
INEQUALITY THAT ETHNIC STUDIES
SEEKS TO ADDRESS, LIMITING THE
POTENTIAL REACH AND IMPACT OF
ETHNIC STUDIES. A LONGER AND
LONGER LIST OF GUARDRAILS SHIFTS
THE FOCUS AWAY FROM THE CORE
DISCIPLINES THAT HIGHLIGHT THE
EXPERIENCES OF COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. ORGANIZATIONALLY, WE ARE
DEEPLY INVESTED IN THE SUCCESS
OF ETHNIC STUDIES. IT WAS OUR
ORGANIZATION, THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, THAT
SPONSORED THE BILL IN 2021 THAT
MADE ETHNIC STUDIES A HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENT,
ADDING REQUIREMENTS AS DISTRICTS
DEVELOP COURSES COULD DILUTE
QUALITY AND STIFLE INNOVATION,
AND WILL BE ANOTHER ROADBLOCK
WITH ONGOING COSTS. WE URGE YOU
TO HOLD THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE
AND REJECT ASSEMBLY BILL 2918.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO. MY
NAME IS MAYA STEINHARDT. I'M A
SACRAMENTO JEWISH TEACHER, AS
WELL AS A FORMER SAC STATE
STUDENT WHO SPENT TIME AT THE
PRO-PALESTINIAN ENCAMPMENT. I AM
IN AGREEMENT WITH EVERYTHING HE
JUST STATED AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS AN
EDUCATOR, I RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES, BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN THE SAME KIND OF
BIASED EDUCATION THAT THE
AUTHORS SAY THEY ARE COMBATING.
THEY HAVE MADE SO MANY CHANGES
AND GUARDRAILS TO THIS BILL AS
TO CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
ETHNIC STUDIES EVEN IS, AND THE
INTENT OF THIS DISCIPLINE, AS
THE AUTHORS STATED, MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES SHOULD HAVE A VOICE
IN HOW THEIR STORIES ARE TOLD.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN DIFFERENT
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES HAVE
DIFFERING VIEWS ON THE SAME
HISTORY? DO YOU PRIVILEGE ONE
GROUP'S PERCEPTION OVER ANOTHER,
OR DO YOU PREPARE STUDENTS TO
HAVE NUANCED CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WHITE SUPREMACY CREATES
INTERSECTIONAL OPPRESSIONS THAT
PIT MINORITIES AGAINST EACH
OTHER? ETHNIC STUDIES,
CURRICULUMS CREATED BY ACADEMICS
AND EXPERTS ALREADY EXIST. THERE
IS NO REASON FOR THE STATE OR
DISTRICTS TO TAKE ON THE COSTS
OF DEVELOPING NEW CURRICULUM,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE POTENTIAL
FOR THIS CURRICULUM TO FORWARD
ANTI-ARAB SENTIMENTS AS SEEN IN
THE EXISTING MODEL CURRICULUM.
THERE IS NOT THE SAME
INFORMATION GIVEN TO ARAB
HISTORY IN THE UNITED STATES.
ANY DISCUSSION OF THE NAKBA OR
THE RESULTING PALESTINIAN
DIASPORA, AND THIS BILL FORWARDS
ONE. IT RECREATES THE HARM IT
INTENDS TO SOLVE. WE ARE ALL
BETTER WHEN WE CAN LEARN ABOUT
HOW INJUSTICES ARE
INTERCONNECTED AND HOW WHITE
SUPREMACY AFFECTS ALL
MINORITIES. THIS BILL IS NOT
TAKING THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
ETHNIC STUDIES. IT IS
PRIVILEGING ONE GROUP OVER
ANOTHER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, DAVID MANDEL WITH THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF JEWISH
VOICE FOR PEACE. AGAIN, I AGREE
STRONGLY WITH THE LAST TWO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL, YOU'VE HEARD A LOT FROM
THE MULTITUDE OF SPEAKERS ABOUT
FIGHTING ANTI-SEMITISM. THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT'S A
MAJOR CONCERN OF OURS BECAUSE IT
IS RAMPANT. BUT ANTI-SEMITISM IS
NOT WHAT'S FOUND IN THE ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE STATE OR THAT
OTHER PEOPLE ARE ADVOCATING.
IT'S NOT THERE'S NO NOTHING
ANTI-JEWISH IN ETHNIC STUDIES
UNLESS YOU CONFLATE
ANTI-SEMITISM WITH SUPPORT FOR
PALESTINIAN RIGHTS AND CRITICISM
OF ISRAEL, WHICH I SUBMIT IS THE
REAL AGENDA BEHIND THIS, I
APOLOGIZE THAT I CAN'T SPEAK
MUCH ABOUT THE FISCAL ASPECTS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS, AND I CAN'T HONESTLY
CAN'T EVALUATE WHAT EFFECT THEY
MIGHT HAVE ON ON THE BILL. BUT
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
GUARDRAILS. IT'S THE LATEST
BUZZWORD. WE NEED THIS
GUARDRAIL. WE NEED THAT
GUARDRAIL. VERY UNSPECIFIC, I,
I'M AFRAID THAT THE GUARDRAILS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED, TO PUT
IT, THE QUOTE UNQUOTE GUARDRAILS
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS BILL ARE
NOT DESIGNED TO KEEP CARS ON THE
ROAD, BUT DESIGNED TO KEEP
PEOPLE, CERTAIN GROUPS OF PEOPLE
OFF THE ROAD AND TO NOT ALLOW
THEIR THEIR HISTORY, THEIR
ETHNICITY, THEIR IDENTITIES TO
BE AND INCLUDING VERY CONTACT
WITH, WITH, WITH CURRENT EVENTS
AND CURRENT STRUGGLES FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO BE GOING ON. I'VE
I'VE ALLOWED THIS THE
CONVERSATION. OKAY. BEYOND WHAT
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S LET'S JUST LEAVE THE
CURRICULUM ON ETHNIC STUDIES TO
EDUCATORS AND LET THEM AND LET
THEM DETERMINE IT AND NOT TRY TO
PUT IN ALL SORTS OF BUREAUCRATIC
OBSTACLES THAT ARE BOUND TO COST
A LOT OF MONEY FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO WE HAVE
A FEW MORE OPPOSITION, AND THEN
I UNDERSTAND A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
MISSED THE SUPPORT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THAT AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO FINISH IT, THIS
IS GOING TO GO TO SUSPENSE, AND
UNTIL WE SEE AMENDMENTS THAT
CHANGE THAT OPINION, WHICH COULD
HAPPEN, AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF
A DISLIKE OF THE BILL. IT'S A
PROCESS. IT'S A PROCESS. SO
THERE'S NOTHING PERSONAL HERE. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
BECAUSE, SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING
AND I FELT LIKE IT WAS MY MOTHER
REPRIMANDING ME FOR. ARE YOU
KIDDING? YOU'RE DOING IT THIS
WAY. SO THIS IS PART OF THE
PROCESS. SO YOU MAY PROCEED.
NAME AFFILIATION AND WHETHER
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. SO, MAGGIE COLTER,
I'M WITH THE SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
COALITION FOR PALESTINIAN
RIGHTS, WHOSE MEMBERS INCLUDE
OVER TWO DOZEN ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE SACRAMENTO REGION. WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL FOR THE REASONS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID. AND
REGARDING THE FISCAL IMPACTS, WE
SHOULD NOT BE USING STATE MONEY
TO SILENCE CRITICISM OF ISRAEL,
TO SILENCE SPECIFIC GROUPS. YOU
HEARD FROM THE THIRD SUPPORTER
HERE, WHO WAS UP HERE SPEAKING,
THAT THIS IS DEFINITELY ABOUT
CRITICIZING ISRAEL. THERE'S A
GENOCIDE GOING ON PALESTINIAN
AND ARAB AMERICANS NEED TO BE
HEARD. TALK ANY MORE ABOUT,
OKAY, I JUST THANK YOU. IT'S
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO. I
DON'T WANT MY TAX MONEY SPENT ON
THIS. SO THANK YOU. YEAH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YES MY NAME IS
PAMELA KAUFMAN. I AM AFFILIATED
WITH THE PENINSULA MULTI-FAITH
COALITION WITH THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCIL, AND
WITH THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI,
ELLEN. I'M A CONCERNED PARENT.
THIS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WHO
ARE OPPOSING THE BILL ARE
EXACTLY WHY WE NEED GUARDRAILS,
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT US ETHNIC
STUDIES. IT'S NOT ABOUT BRINGING
YOUR HATE IDEOLOGY OR ISLAMIC
SUPREMACY WHICH DENIGRATES
ISRAEL. ERASES. OKAY, I'M NOT
GOING TO LET YOU GET INTO THAT
EITHER. SO THIS THIS HAS TO DO
WITH FISCAL. I GET IT, I GET IT.
BUT THAT'S A POLICY COMMITTEE.
IT'S A POLICY COMMITTEE. NO NO
NO, IT'S A IT'S A POLICY
COMMITTEE. AND I APOLOGIZE.
YEAH. IN COLLEGE NOT NOT GREAT.
UNDERSTOOD. UNDERSTOOD. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION? I WANT TO GIVE
EVERYBODY A CHANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CARLOS MACHADO WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, WE'RE A WIENER. WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S,
WILLINGNESS TO DISCUSS THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE. I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT DOES GO IN IN 2930.
HOWEVER, LÀ ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
A COURSE OFFERED TO STUDENTS BY
2526 SCHOOL YEAR, WHICH MEANS WE
HAVE LESS THAN 12 MONTHS RIGHT
NOW TO GET A COURSE ADOPTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND BY THE TIME
THAT THE BILL GETS ENACTED, THAT
GIVES US LESS THAN EIGHT MONTHS
FOR THOSE SCHOOLS THAT GET START
IN AUGUST OR SEPTEMBER. SO WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO GET THAT
COURSE ADOPTED. THE PROCESS THAT
THEY'RE FOLLOWING RIGHT NOW IS
BASED UPON EXISTING GUIDANCE AND
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN
EXISTING LAW. TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CHANGE THAT, IT MAKES IT
HARDER FOR THOSE DISTRICTS TO BE
ABLE TO MEET WITH PARENTS AND
ALSO COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
GET THEIR INPUT IN THAT PROCESS
IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT CLASS IN
PLACE BY THE 25, 26 SCHOOL YEAR,
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS. WE DO
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION AS WE'RE
MAKING ANY CHANGES, SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THAT PROCESS. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
VERY MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE? OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
FINANCE NÓ FILE OKAY. SO AFTER
ALL THAT NÓ FILE THAT'S A
PUNCHLINE. SO, VERY WELL, LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANY COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. VERY BRIEFLY PLEASE.
THIS IS GOING TO GO TO SUSPEND.
SO I JUST UNDERSTAND I JUST, YOU
KNOW, MY SON GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND MY DAUGHTER JUST
GRADUATED. MY DAUGHTER GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL, HAD AN ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM THAT WAS
CLEAR AND DRAMATIC VIOLATION OF
AB 101 WITH OBVIOUS FACTUAL
INACCURACIES. THAT'S WHY THESE
GUARDRAILS ARE NECESSARY, AND BY
REMOVING THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS, THAT DOES REMOVE THE
COST. SO I'M VERY CONFUSED BY
THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
WHY THEY WOULD SAY THAT, AND THE
REASON THIS IS NECESSARY, ETHNIC
STUDIES IS THE ONLY DISCIPLINE
THAT DOES NOT HAVE A FULLY
DOCUMENTED CURRICULUM, DOES NOT
HAVE THE, THE EDUCATION
STANDARDS OR FRAMEWORKS. THAT'S
WHY THIS IS NECESSARY. THIS IS
REALLY THE LEAST WE CAN DO. AND,
AND IT HAS TO HAS TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU. SO, SO JUST SO YOU
KNOW, THE REASON I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. DON'T. PLEASE DON'T DO
THAT. IT'S NOT A SPORTING EVENT,
SO I TRY TO MAINTAIN SOME
DECORUM, THE REASON IS THAT IT
WE DO THINGS WHEN THINGS ARE IN
PRINT. SO IT'S NOT THAT ANYBODY
IS. IT'S. NO, NO NEFARIOUS KIND
OF PROCESS UNTIL IT'S IN PRINT.
IT DOESN'T EXIST. AND SO WE GOT
TO SEE IT IN PRINT. SENATOR. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
YOU KNOW, I SITTING ON
APPROPRIATIONS AND LOOKING AT
HOW MUCH THINGS COST VERSUS HOW
MUCH MONEY WE HAVE, AND
EVENTUALLY THERE'S A DECISION OF,
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S WORTH
IT? AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN SUMMED UP IN BY
EVERYBODY IS I KNOW THIS COSTS A
LOT. IF WE KNOW WHAT THAT COST
IS, BUT IT'S WORTH IT, THAT'S
ALL, SO, YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS. IT'S GOING
TO GO TO SUSPENSE. WE HAVE TO
ANALYZE THE COSTS. WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY IN THIS
STATE. AND, AND SOMETIMES WE
CAN'T SPEND MONEY ON, ON ON SOME
THINGS. THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO SAY IS JUST BECAUSE THERE'S A
CLASS DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE AN
EXPERT WHEN YOU COME OUT OF IT.
I TOOK LOTS OF ALGEBRA, AND IF
YOU PUT IT IN FRONT OF ME TODAY,
I WOULDN'T KNOW SQUAT ABOUT
ALGEBRA, SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
AN EXPECTATION THAT SOMEHOW
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE THIS BY,
BY MANDATING THAT PEOPLE GO
THROUGH SOMETHING. AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE MIGHT BE A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED. THIS IS A
CULTURAL SHIFT. NOT JUST A
CULTURAL SHIFT, BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S INCUMBENT ON
PARENTS AND THING TO TEACH THEIR
KIDS. MY KIDS WOULD NOT NEED TO
GO THROUGH AN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE IN ADDITION TO THE OTHER
COURSES THAT THEY STAYED UP TILL
UNTIL 2:00 IN THE MORNING TRYING
TO GET THROUGH. WHEN THEY WANTED
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OTHER THINGS
TOO, THAT WE MIGHT AS WELL START
MAKING HIGH SCHOOL FIVE YEARS
INSTEAD OF FOUR. AND I DON'T
THINK THE KIDS ARE GOING TO LIKE
THAT MUCH. AND I DON'T THINK
THEIR PARENTS ARE EITHER. SO WE
REALLY HAVE TO BE A LITTLE
DISCERNING ABOUT. I KNOW THIS IS
A VERY EMOTIONAL TOPIC, AND IT'S
VERY MUCH NEEDED. WE HAVE
DISCRIMINATION LAWS THAT SHOULD
APPLY TO EVERYBODY. EVERYBODY,
NOT JUST YOU KNOW, NOT JUST,
MINORITY PEOPLE, BUT, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE DIFFERENT RELIGIONS, ALL
THE DIFFERENT AND INCLUDING
WHITE PEOPLE. I'M SICK AND TIRED
OF HEARING WHITE SUPREMACISTS
APPLIED TO ALL THE WHITE PEOPLE.
WE'RE NOT WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
AND SO WITH THAT, I WOULD SAY,
LET'S MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SO I'LL
GIVE YOU THE FINAL WORD,
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, I HAVE THREE
SENTENCES, BUT I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS HAD
PROBABLY A SENTENCE OR TWO.
WELL, IT'S YOU KNOW WHAT? ONE OF
YOU GETS TO GO, GUYS. I MEAN,
I'VE LET YOU BOTH SPEAK, AND
WE'VE GONE A LONG TIME, SO
PLEASE, ALL I'LL SAY IS THAT, WE
BELIEVE THAT 2918 WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD, REMOVING THE
TRANSPARENCY WILL HAVE LITTLE TO
NO COST, BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
JUST ABOUT APPLYING A CHANGES TO
THE LEGAL STANDARD THAT APPLIES.
SO WITH THAT, ASK FOR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. VERY GOOD. THANKS. I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH, WE'VE
DEALT WITH THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS, BUT, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE ITEM. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING HERE
TODAY. WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY, AND, AND THERE'S A
LOT MORE THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO DON'T DESPAIR. THIS DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S GOING INTO A BLACK
HOLE, THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
COMING, AND WE'LL DEAL WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS LIKE WE DEAL
WITH ANY OTHER ONE, IF IT
REDUCES THE COST, THEN THEY GET
OUT RIGHT AWAY. SO NOT TO NOT TO
WORRY ABOUT IT. SO, IF THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITH
THAT OBJECTION, AB 2918 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AND WE HOPE TO
SEE YOU SOON WHEN THE AMENDMENTS
COME THROUGH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT SUBJECT. AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
HAD A CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE. SO
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
ESPECIALLY WELL, EVERYBODY
BECAUSE YOU TRAVELED YOU HAD TO
TRAVEL TO GET HERE, LET'S GO
BACK TO OUR AGENDA. ACTUALLY,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK. I THINK, MANY OF
US NEED TO USE THE SERVICES, AND
IT'LL GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET CAUGHT UP WITH OURSELVES. SO
FIVE MINUTE BREAK.
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO BE BACK IN SESSION
32, IN ROOM. 2200 2200. I AM LOW
BLOOD SUGAR, WE'RE GOING TO GO
ON WITH OUR AGENDA. WE WILL NOT
GET DONE BEFORE WE HAVE TO TAKE
OUR BREAK TO GO TO SESSION, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH AS MANY AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN. WE LEFT OFF AT AB 3211 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO SEE, WHO IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF HER BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS ERIC SOJA.
I'M A 25 YEAR SAG-AFTRA MEMBER
AND PROFESSIONAL ACTOR FROM LOS
ANGELES, AND I'M HERE TO TELL MY
STORY AND SUPPORT AB 3211 AND
ITS FISCAL IMPORTANCE ACTUALLY,
WE'RE NOT TAKING THE LONG
TESTIMONY. IT'S PRETTY MUCH AS
VERY, VERY QUICKLY RELATED TO,
TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. IN OTHER WORDS, UNDERSTOOD
NONE OF THE POLICY. I LET THAT
GO ON THE BUT THE FISCAL ASPECTS
DO REQUIRE AN EXPLANATION BEHIND
IT. SO IF I MAY, IT'S LITERALLY
TWO MINUTES LONG AND NO LONGER,
I PROMISE. IN 2014, ACTIVISION
HIRED ME TO PLAY A BELGIAN
GENETICIST NAMED DOC IN THE
BLOCKBUSTER GAME CALL OF DUTY
ADVANCED WARFARE. AND AFTER THE
GAME CAME OUT, A FRIEND CALLED
ME AND SAID, HEY, ERIC, MY SON
JUST SHOT YOU. IT TURNS OUT
ACTIVISION HAD ALSO PUT MY FACE
ON A DIFFERENT CHARACTER THAT
YOU CAN PLAY FOR A MONTHLY FEE
TO FIGHT OTHER PLAYERS, THAT
YEAR THE GAME GROSSED MORE THAN
TAYLOR SWIFT'S ALBUM 1989, PLUS
THE MOVIE'S FROZEN GUARDIANS OF
THE GALAXY COMBINED. AND I ONLY
RECEIVED MY ORIGINAL SESSION FEE
AND I FELT VIOLATED. TEN YEARS
AT THE DAWN OF AI, THE GAMING
COMPANIES CONTINUED TO EXPLOIT
PERFORMERS, AND SO OUR UNION
JUST WENT ON STRIKE, AND THE
STORY ILLUSTRATES A SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC ISSUE WITH CHEN AI,
GAMING COMPANIES, HOLLYWOOD
STUDIOS, EVEN INDEPENDENT
PRODUCERS CAN CREATE AND
MONETIZE ENTIRE CHARACTERS FROM
OUR LIKENESS, VOICE, MOVEMENT,
AND BIOMETRIC DATA. AB 3211.
DIGITAL PROVENANCE AND
WATERMARKING REQUIREMENTS WILL
EVENTUALLY ENABLE TRACKING AND
FAIR COMPENSATION, AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT INCREASING STATE
TAX REVENUE WILL OVERCUT THE
COST INFLATION COST. EXCUSE ME.
LET ME TRY THAT AGAIN.
INCREASING STATE TAX REVENUE I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS FOR K¾T, BUT WE MUST
CONSIDER THE COST OF INACTION.
LAST YEAR, CALIFORNIA'S VIDEO
GAME INDUSTRY GENERATED OVER $44
BILLION IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ARE
INVESTMENT THAT WILL PREVENT
BILLIONS IN LOST REVENUE AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AB 3211 COULD
ALSO REDUCE COSTLY LEGAL
DISPUTES FROM UNAUTHORIZED USE
OF DIGITAL LIKENESSES, SAVING
THE STATE AND BUSINESSES
SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION EXPENSES
WHILE PROTECTING BOTH LABOR AND
EMPLOYEES FROM EXPLOITATION AND
DEEPFAKES BY USING PROVENANCE TO
TRACK AI REPLICA USE. EVEN IN
MODULAR AI, WE SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD NOT TO PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY WELL DONE. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3211.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ANTICIPATES REQUIRING
TWO POSITIONS AND $1.6 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION, AND 12
POSITIONS AND 3.1 GENERAL FUND
ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET ACT FOR GOOD
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3211 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. I'M GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB 1122 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAYNES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB 1122 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 2357 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES, WHO
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? SHARON
GONSALVES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BAKERSFIELD IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT BUT IN OPPOSITION, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO AB 2357, ALTHOUGH THE BILL
DOES NOT OBLIGATE THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO FUND OR DEVELOP
A NEW BRANCH CAMPUS OF AN
EXISTING CAMPUS, THE èC
ESTIMATES STARTUP COSTS FOR A
NEW, NEW UC MEDICAL SCHOOL
BRANCH CAMPUS TO BE AT LEAST 300
MILLION FOR A NEW BUILDING
ONGOING AND OPERATIONAL COSTS OF
BETWEEN 40 AND 45 MILLION, WITH
UNKNOWN COSTS TO SUPPORT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO CREATE
A BRANCH CAMPUS, AND TO SEEK AND
OBTAIN ACCREDITATION FROM THE
LICENSING COMMITTEE ON MEDICAL
EDUCATION. FURTHER èC INDICATES
THERE WOULD BE UNKNOWN COSTS
THAT COULD RANGE INTO THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO CONDUCT A
FEASIBILITY STUDY TO PROVIDE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE REGION FOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION. TRAINING
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME AND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES TO
DEVELOP, SUSTAIN AND OPERATE A
NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL. IT'S GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND SEEING
NO COMMENT OR QUESTION, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2357 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2376 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAYNES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? WELL, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON AB 2376. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES COST OF 133,000IN
2425, 226,000IN 25, 26 AND 2627,
156,000IN 27 AND 28, AND 54,000
ONGOING STARTING IN 2829 FROM
THE LICENSING, LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION FUND. A FISCAL
ESTIMATE WAS NOT AVAILABLE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AT THE TIME OF THE
ANALYSIS. HOWEVER, FINANCE IS
PRELIMINARILY, PRELIMINARILY
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COSTS,
POTENTIALLY IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS TO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT
DXC'S OVERSIGHT OF RECOVERY
SERVICE EXPANSION FOR MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES. SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2376. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE AB 3027 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAYNES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BENNETT GORE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE SICK COALITION, WHO FOR THE
PAST YEAR HAS BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY, TIRELESSLY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO ADDRESS
TRANSNATIONAL REPRESSION.
PLEASED TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON AND
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT STATE
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
COORDINATION BETWEEN FEDERAL AND
STATE AUTHORITIES WHEN
RECOGNIZING AND COMBATING
THREATS OF TRANSNATIONAL
REPRESSION. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3027.
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ESTIMATES THE
BILL WILL RESULT IN COSTS OF
668,000 GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR FOR TWO PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO RESEARCH AND
DEVELOP A PROGRAM AND
COORDINATION WITH POST. CAL OES
WOULD ALSO NEED TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF WITHIN THE
HOMELAND SECURITY, AND THE
POSITIONS WOULD RESULT IN
ONGOING COSTS OF $663,000.
GENERAL FUND POST DOES ESTIMATE
COSTS TO IMPLEMENT WOULD BE
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE AND ALL
INCREASING, ALTHOUGH INCREASING
AWARENESS AND TRAINING ON
TRANSNATIONAL OPPRESSION IS AN
EMERITUS ENDEAVOR, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 24 BUDGET. I
THINK NO MEMBER CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3027 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3029 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? SHARON
GONSALVES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BAKERSFIELD IN SUPPORT? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO. FOR
SEEING THAT. THEY'RE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3029 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1135
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. SEEING NO,
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1135 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2389 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT AN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 2389 BECAUSE IT
MAY INCREASE BAR AND RESIDENTS
RESTAURANT SAFETY WITHOUT
INCREASING STATE COSTS. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2389 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3172 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL.
SENATOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. HI. CARLY STELZER ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA,
PROUD SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
THANKS FOR THE SUPPORT. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3172.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF 224,000.
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW FUND, AND
25, 26 AND 394,000 ONGOING FOR
TWO POSITIONS TO HANDLE THE
PROJECTED INCREASED WORKLOAD.
WHILE DOJ HAS NOT CONFIRMED THIS
AT THE TIME OF THE ANALYSIS,
FINANCE DOES NOTE THAT THESE
COSTS COULD BE POTENTIALLY
OFFSET TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE CIVIL PENALTIES COLLECTED BY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, BUT ANY
REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SHOULD BE EVALUATED
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. OKAY SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3172.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1137
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1137. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN COSTS OF 1.09 MILLION, OF
WHICH 530,000 IS GENERAL FUND
AND 2425 AND ONGOING TO PROVIDE
INFORMAL TIME OFF AND OVERTIME
PAY OR HOLIDAY CREDIT TO
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES FOR WORK
PERFORMED ON SPECIFIED HOLIDAYS.
SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY RESULT IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FISCAL PLAN, AND SUBSTANTIALLY
ALTERS THE NATURE OF
COMPENSATION PROVIDED TO
EMPLOYEES EXCLUDED FROM COVERAGE
UNDER FLSA. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1137 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1610 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER, WHO AGAIN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYBODY
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL? ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ PHÐ.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE LAST COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT
JUST WALKED OUT THE DOOR. SO, SO
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
1610 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2064. THE GREAT
THING ABOUT HAVING NO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS I CAN GET THINGS DONE
QUICKLY. QUICKLY. DON'T TELL HIM
I SAID THAT. 2064 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? WELCOME ORCHESTRA. ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? YES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2064. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES A FISCAL
IMPACT OF $5.7 MILLION. GENERAL
FUND IN 24, 25 AND $11.4
MILLION, GENERAL FUND IN 25, 26
AND ONGOING TO SUPPORT FOUR
POSITIONS WHO WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR GRANT
ADMINISTRATION, THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
SIGNIFICANT COSTS OF THE GENERAL
FUND GIVEN SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH PREVIOUS STATE PRISON
CLOSURES, AS WELL AS SCHEDULE
CLOSURES THAT WERE ALREADY
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE 2024
BUDGET. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
24 BUDGET. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2064 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2338 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2338 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3839 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER. TESTIMONY
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MARCUS. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT, THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CHLOE FERMIN WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT AS
WELL AS FACTS. NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO AND STANDING
UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE ELSE
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO. FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3089 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3108 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HI. BRIAN WHALEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3108 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1160 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT? BRIAN WHALEN, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANNA
MATTHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1160.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
1.5 MILLION ONGOING COSTS AND
$500,000 ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PROJECTS AN ANNUAL POTENTIAL
REVENUE LOSS OF 30 MILLION FROM
THE PROHIBITION ON DIPLOMA
HOLDS. CSU INDICATES THE BILL
WILL RESULT IN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
$485,000, AND EXPRESSED
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES DUE
TO THE PROPOSED PROCEDURES TO
COLLECT INSTITUTIONAL DEBT AND
THE DELAYED PROCESS OF ENGAGING
WITH THIRD PARTY COLLECTORS OR
USING A TAX OFFSET MECHANISM ON
AVERAGE, IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
CSU MANAGES ABOUT 100 MILLION IN
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT PER YEAR AND
SPENDS ABOUT 30 MILLION TO THIRD
PARTY DEBT COLLECTORS. FOR THESE
REASONS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE
AN ADDITIONAL I'M SORRY, COULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH PROPOSITION 98,
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THEREFORE,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1160 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1912 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED. AB 1912
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
ESTIMATES IT WILL COST $2.917
MILLION FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION'S PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE ACCOUNT AND 13
POSITIONS TO ACCOMPLISH THE NEW
ON GOING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BILL, AND THEREFORE WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT CREATES A TAX AND NEW COSTS
FOR THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET. OKAY, THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1912 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. NEXT IS AB 3241 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? YES, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3241. THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
ANTICIPATES COSTS RANGING FROM
250 TO 400,000. ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL AND AB
2042 BY JACKSON, WHICH THE BILL
IS DOUBLE JOINTED WITH. A POST
ALSO ESTIMATES THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN ONE TIME COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY 10 MILLION.
GENERAL FUND AND ONGOING COSTS
IN THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO REIMBURSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR THE
COSTS. THE AGENCIES INCUR TO
ATTEND THE CERTIFIED TRAINING.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ALSO ESTIMATE COSTS OF 800,001
TIME GENERAL FUND TO AUTOMATE
DATA, AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL INDICATES THE BILL MAY
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL UNKNOWN
COSTS FOR THE CHP, DEPENDING ON
THE GUIDELINES RELEASED BY POST.
JUST AGAIN TO BE NOTED, CHP
REQUIRES FUNDING FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING WITH A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE AND AB 3241 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 1296 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1296
BECAUSE IT DOES RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. AND CREATES
AN IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE UNATTAINABLE BY CARB.
THE REGULATIONS IN QUESTION TAKE
EFFECT DECEMBER 31ST OF 2024,
AND CARB WILL NOT HAVE TIME TO
PROCESS AN AMENDMENT BEFORE THE
REGULATIONS TAKE TAKE EFFECT.
ADDITIONALLY, THE CARB FUNDING
SOURCE WILL NEED A LOAN FROM THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND OR
FUND TO FUND THE NOTED RESOURCES.
AND LASTLY, SVP OR BP HAS
APPLIED FOR AN EXTENSION TO
COMPLY WITH THE REGULATIONS
WHILE A NEW WHILE NEW PILOT
BOATS ARE BROUGHT INTO SERVICE.
SO THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM. SO THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE AB
1296 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2091 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
HèA PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS EITHER. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE AND
AB 2091 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2434 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOESN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD NOTE
THAT DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE ESTIMATES FISCAL
IMPACT TO BE ABOUT $500,000 FOR
THE MANAGED CARE FUND IN 2526
FOR CONSULTING FEES, AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES BILL WILL RESULT IN
COST TO THE INSURANCE FUND OF
25,025 26 AND 16,027 28, AND IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT FUNDS
COMING FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND COULD BE PASSED ON TO
CONSUMERS IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS, SEEING
THAT THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2434 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2538 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2538. AND WHILE WE WOULD NOTE
THAT CAL FIRE HAS NOT ESTIMATED
COST FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL BECAUSE IT'S BECAUSE IT
IS NOT ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTABLE
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. SO WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT'S NOT
IMPLEMENTABLE WITHOUT AMENDING
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
SPECIFICALLY ARTICLE SEVEN,
SECTION FIVE, WHICH STIPULATES
THAT TEMPORARY APPOINTMENTS MADE
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN EMPLOYMENT
LIST AND NO PERSON AND NO PERSON
MAY SERVE IN ONE OR MORE
POSITIONS UNDER A TEMPORARY
APPOINTMENT FOR LONGER THAN NINE
MONTHS IN A CONSECUTIVE 12 MONTH
PERIOD. VERY GOOD, SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, 2538 WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE, AB 2774 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION AND ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT. CHLOE FERMIN WITH CLEAN
AIR FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG
WITH FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS AND CA AND GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ PHÐ.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2774 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2821 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREYSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
AN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2821.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
INDICATES THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN UNKNOWN BUT LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST TO
ADMINISTER AND IMPLEMENT THE
BILL REQUIREMENTS. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
INDICATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN 1.2 MILLION PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH ADMINISTERING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS, AND 153,000 IN 1
TIME GENERAL FUND COST TO HIRE
TWO CONSULTANTS TO DEVELOP THE
PROGRAM. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA INDICATES THE BILL
WILL RESULT IN AN UNKNOWN, BUT
LIKELY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
ADMINISTER AND IMPLEMENT ITS
REQUIREMENTS. SO NOTWITHSTANDING
THE MERITS OF THE PROPOSAL, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE GENERAL
FUND AND PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. SEEING THAT THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2821 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 3012 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GREYSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ. FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3012 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREYSON WILL BE
WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND. AB 1474 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION IS NEXT.
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BUT IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE, NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MEANS THAT THIS IS A IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
WITH THAT OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE, AB 1472 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
1597 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ,
WHO IS WAIVE PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. SEEING THAT
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1597 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2075 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2705.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE NATURE OF
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY,
WHICH IS UNCERTAIN. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES 333,000 FROM THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FUND
ANNUALLY DURING THE NEXT PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY, AND ONE AND A
HALF POSITIONS TO INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICE
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
1.664, IN 1,000,000 IN 2526,
2.748 MILLION IN 2627, AND
ONGOING AND ANNUAL COST OF 2.72,
FOUR AND NINE POSITIONS TO
ENSURE BILL COMPLIANCE. FINANCE
WOULD NOTE THAT COSTS WILL
DEPEND ON THE SCALE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND THE
WORKLOAD NEEDS THAT EMERGE, BUT
AT THE MOMENT, WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
INCREASED FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE STATE'S FISCAL PLAN AND
LIMITS THE STATE'S FLEXIBILITY
TO RESPOND TO FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES. OKAY, DID WE
MISS, SUPPORT OR OBJECTION,
OPPOSITION. SO I WASN'T QUITE,
QUITE FAST ENOUGH. BUT ON BEHALF
OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, IN OPPOSITION, AS
WELL AS THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION, AND THIS IS ON AB
2075. YES. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WELL, THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2075 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2326 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ, IS THERE ANYONE WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO, THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AB 2326 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2586 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? CAN I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? I'M SORRY. SURE. THANK
YOU. ALEGRIA DE LA CRUZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF 2586.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2586
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2953
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2953, BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
$15.8 MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY TO HIRE
COUNSELORS, COVER TRAVEL
EXPENSES, AND PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DOES
INDICATE MINOR ABSORBABLE COSTS.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2953 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2996 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FOR THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2996 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB 1511 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? YES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1511. THE OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS ESTIMATES THE
BILL RESULTS IN COSTS OF 701,500
GENERAL FUND AND 2526 AND
ONGOING FOR THREE AND A HALF
POSITIONS TO ASSIST THE STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS AND
MARKETING. IN ADDITION, Þ CPSC
ALSO INDICATED THAT WHILE NOT
EXPLICITLY WRITTEN INTO THE
BILL, IF THERE WERE EXPECTATIONS
THAT THEY TRACK COMPLIANCE WITH
MEDIA EXPENDITURE REQUIREMENTS,
THEY WOULD NEED TWO ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS TO ACCOMPLISH.
ACCOMPLISH THIS INCREASE IN THE
TOTAL COST OF 1.1 MILLION,
GENERAL FUND IN 25, 26, AND
ONGOING. THEREFORE, FINANCE IS
OPPOSED BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. FINANCE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT FUNDING FOR CPSC IS ONLY
AVAILABLE THROUGH 2526, SO
ESTABLISHING THIS PROGRAM WITHIN
THEM MAY NOT ACHIEVE THE PURPOSE
OF THE BILL ON A LONG TERM
BASIS. SO THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILED.
YES, SIR. ALEJANDRO SALAS ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO MEDIA
COLLABORATIVE AND SUPPORT, AND
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 1511.
YES. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1511 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2093 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2093.
THE ONGOING COST FOR THIS BILL
IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS, AND
ASSUMING CURRENT OR ASSUMING
CURRENT ENROLLMENT LEVELS WOULD
BE IN EXCESS OF $1 MILLION
ANNUALLY, THESE COSTS WOULD HAVE
TO WOULD HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE AS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INCREASE FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT AND EXPAND
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS OFFERED.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS,
NOT IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
SPENDING PLAN. SO THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2093 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2667 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FOR THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB AB 2667
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO AB 2910 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO PHÐ. NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2910 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1575 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CARLY
STELZER, ON BEHALF OF COMMON
SENSE MEDIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1575.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES COSTS OF 3 MILLION.
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO HIRE TWO
POSITIONS AT EACH OF THE TEN
CAMPUSES. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY ESTIMATES THERE WILL
BE A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COST
RANGING FROM 10,000 TO 15,000,
TO DEVELOP AN ONLINE TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR EXTERNAL SORRY FOR
EXTERNAL ADVISORS. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE WITH ONE TIME
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS RANGING FROM 196,000 TO
464,000. AN ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
TRAIN CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATES,
WHILE EMERITUS, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND COULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH PROPOSITION 98.
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1575 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2426 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE,
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2426 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2492 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO 2492
BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE LOW TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WHILE,
EXCUSE ME, BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
HIRE STUDENT ADVOCATES, FACULTY
ADVOCATES, AND COORDINATORS,
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2492 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2854 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION OR COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE, SO THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE AS WELL.
SO AB 2854 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
AB 3256 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO 3256.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL IS
2.154 MILLION FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT, ONGOING
AND 11 PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
CREATE A NEW SECTION DEDICATED
TO CONDUCTING THE AUDITS. ALL
ACCOUNTS, AUDITS, WORKLOAD WOULD
BE A NEW REQUIREMENT FOR THAT,
AND THE REVENUE, I'M SORRY,
WOULD BE A NEW REQUIREMENT, THE
PUC ERA REVENUE IS GENERATED
FROM A SURCHARGE AND UTILITY
BILLS. SO THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN INCREASED COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
TO GENERATE ADEQUATE REVENUE TO
COVER ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. ANY
REQUEST TO STATE RESOURCES FOR
THIS BILL SHOULD BE EVALUATED AS
PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 2356 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1588 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF SOLANO AND MARIN,
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ. FILE
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1588 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2061 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO AB 2061 BECAUSE OF
ITS NEGATIVE GENERAL FUND
REVENUE IMPACT, AND IT CREATES A
PRECEDENT FOR FURTHER REVENUE
LOSSES, MAINTAINING STRUCTURAL
BALANCE OF THE STATE BUDGET AND
ONGOING CHALLENGE THAT WILL
REQUIRE WEIGHING THE ADDITIONAL
COST OF A NEW TAX CREDIT WITH
OTHER COMPETING BUDGET
PRIORITIES. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2061 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2319 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. MARKUS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS,
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2319
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATE
COSTS, ESTIMATES, COSTS OF
171,000. GENERAL FUND AND 25, 26
AND 161,026 27 AND ONGOING FOR
STAFF TO CREATE STANDARDIZED
DATA COLLECTION, A STANDARDIZED
DATA COLLECTION TOOL, COLLECT
DATA SUBMISSIONS FROM HOSPITALS,
AND ANALYZE THE DATA FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2319 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
1635 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? PERMANENT FINANCE
FILE THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, SO
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
1635 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
1858 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. HI, MY
NAME IS CASSANDRA WHETSTONE. I'M
AN EDUCATOR AND A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MARY LOU
ROSATO, YOLO, YOLO, MOMS DEMAND
ACTION VOLUNTEER AND FORMER
POLICE OFFICER AND SCHOOL
TEACHER. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. CHLOE FERMIN WITH
CLEANUP FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT
ALONG WITH FACTS. NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU JULIE CHAPMAN.
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. Ó. NO
OPPOSITION. CAN'T FORGET THAT
SEEING NONE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL ON AB 1858 AS
IT STANDARDIZES THE PRACTICE OF
ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS WITHOUT
ADDING SIGNIFICANT NEW COST TO
THE STATE. IN ADDITION, FINANCE
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE THAT THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE ANY
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON A LOCAL
AGENCY ARE THE RESULT OF A LOCAL
AGENCY'S DISCRETION TO ADOPT A
NEW PROGRAM. VERY GOOD. THERE
AREN'T ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
IN REGARDS TO THIS BILL FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1858 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE, MOVING ON TO AB 1884
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE, NO QUESTIONS
ON THIS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1884 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2353 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FILE AGAIN, NO QUESTIONS
ON THIS. IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB 2353 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2893 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD.
ACTUALLY, THAT ONE IS OFF THE
FILE. THAT ONE WAS FULLER. OKAY,
THAT ONE WAS PUT OVER. GOOD
CATCH. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB
2934 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2934 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 1793 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT? TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AB 1793 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 1856 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT? TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 1856.
EXCUSE ME 1856, BUT NOTES
CONCERNS THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD FOR TRIAL
COURTS AND PUT ADDITIONAL
STRAINS ON LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
SYSTEMS. NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1856 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 3045 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANY TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3045.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN COSTS OF 92,024,
25, AND 103,000 ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. FIRST YEAR
EXPENDITURES INCLUDE A ONE TIME
COST OF UP TO 40,000 FOR A LOCAL
ARTIST TO DESIGN THE HEIRLOOM
CERTIFICATE, WHICH WOULD CREATE
GENERAL FUND PRESSURE DUE TO THE
DELAY IN RECEIVING REVENUES FROM
CERTIFICATE FEE PAYERS. ONGOING
COSTS WOULD BE SUPPORTED BY FEES
DEPOSITED INTO THE HEALTH
STATISTICS SPECIAL FUND TO COVER
STAFF TIME TO PROCESS
CERTIFICATE REQUESTS, BUT THIS
BILL COULD CREATE ADDITIONAL
COST PRESSURES FOR SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS FOR OTHER GROUPS.
SO AT THE MOMENT, THE FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN COSTS AND POTENTIAL
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT SPENDING
PLAN. OKAY, THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3045 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1794 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? SHARON GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
AND RANCHO PALOS VERDES IS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? YES, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1794. BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS INDICATES
THAT ALL AVAILABLE FUNDS FOR THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
PREVENTION AND OUGHT VERTICAL
PROSECUTION GRANTS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN AWARDED. THEREFORE, THIS
BILL WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED BECAUSE THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES TO FUND
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THE CAL
FAST PASS PROGRAM. GIVEN THAT
AVAILABLE ORTEZ GRANT FUNDS HAVE
BEEN AWARDED AND THE BILL CITES
THE OUGHT GRANT PROGRAMS AS THE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE NEW
COUNTY PROGRAMS, THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1794 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2088 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2088
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE ONE TIME
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS BETWEEN 1.1 MILLION AND
$1.7 MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO DEVELOP
HIRING PROCESSES, PROCESSES,
PROCEDURES AND POLICIES, AND
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
HIRING PROCESS PROCEDURES AND
POLICIES, AND ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS BETWEEN 12,000 AND $56,000
FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2088, WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2106 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2106
FINANCE. NOTES. THIS BILL MAY
IMPOSE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE AS DETERMINED BY THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES, BY
REQUIRING PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
TO PLACE DEFENDANTS IN A DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAM. FINANCE
NOTES. THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS AND COULD
ALSO CREATE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH TRACKING PROGRAM
CAPACITY AND AVAILABILITY.
THEREFORE, WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT COULD
POTENTIALLY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND COULD
IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND WORKLOAD ON
COUNTIES, WHICH WILL CREATE
ADDITIONAL FISCAL PRESSURES ON
THE LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
OBJECTION. AB 2106 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2508 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2508,
THE BILL IS ESTIMATED TO COST $6
MILLION. GENERAL FUND. IN 2526
TO ESTABLISH ADDITIONAL COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DEPOSITS INTO
EXISTING ACCOUNTS. FURTHER, THIS
BILL IS ESTIMATED TO CREATE
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
$2.4 MILLION PER YEAR TO
ESTABLISH NEW CAL KIDS ACCOUNTS
FOR ELIGIBLE YOUTH WHO ENTER THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AFTER 2526
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DEPOSITS
INTO EXISTING ACCOUNTS WHILE
EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE CAL KIDS
PROGRAM TO A WIDER COHORT OF
STUDENTS IS A WORTHWHILE GOAL.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES NEW GENERAL
FUND COSTS THAT ARE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE STATE'S CURRENT
FISCAL PLAN. THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2508 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2882 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT MARTIN
MENDIOLA ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIELLE SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB 282 DUE TO SERIOUS FISCAL
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
REDIRECTION OF BOTH THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH 2011
REALIGNMENT. THERE'S COSTS TO
COUNTIES ASSOCIATED WITH NEW
INFORMATION ELEMENTS REQUIRED IN
THE ANNUAL PLANS, COST AND
WORKLOAD TO ANALYZE SOME OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FUNDS AND AN
EXPANDED SCOPE OF QUANTIFIABLE
GOALS, ALL OF WHICH WE'RE
CONCERNED WOULD DISRUPT THE
VITAL PUBLIC SAFETY FUNDING. SO
WE URGE YOUR NO VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
CHAIR, COMMITTEE AND STAFF. RYAN
MOORE WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES, ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 2882. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS THAT RECOGNIZED THE
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING COST TO ALL
58 COUNTIES. AND IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME, JUST LIKE TO ECHO SOME
OF THE PREVIOUS FISCAL CONCERNS
THAT WERE JUST STATED. HOWEVER,
ANOTHER IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
IS THAT THE STATE PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED ANNUAL FUNDING TO
COUNTIES TO SUBMIT CCP PLANS.
HOWEVER DUE TO EARLY BUDGET
ACTION THAT THAT FUNDING HAS
BEEN ELIMINATED AND SO
ULTIMATELY THIS WOULD NOT ONLY
REQUIRE THAT ALL COUNTIES SUBMIT
ANNUAL PLANS, BUT IT WOULD ALSO
SUBSTANTIALLY EXPAND THE
REQUIREMENTS WITHIN THOSE. AND
SO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, WE
RESPECT YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF FRESNO, KERN,
MADERA, MENDOCINO, SAN JOAQUIN,
SAN LUIS OBISPO, SHASTA AND
SOLANO, ALL IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2882 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
3047 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3047. THE OR THE OFFICE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SURGEON GENERAL
ESTIMATES A FISCAL IMPACT OF
232,500 GENERAL FUND IN 2425,
2.215 MILLION GENERAL FUND, AND
25, 26 AND 2627 AND 1.107
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 2728 TO
COVER STAFFING, ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT AND CONTRACT COSTS. TO
OVERSEE THE COMMISSION AND
PUBLISH ITS FINDING FINDINGS. IN
ADDITION, STATE ENTITIES
SELECTED BY THE OSG FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE COMMISSION
WILL LIKELY INCUR COSTS. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH DOES
ESTIMATE MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
COSTS OF FINANCE, THEREFORE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
INCREASES DEPARTMENTAL COST TO
CONVENE A COMMISSION AND RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2832 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3047 BY DID. DID I GET IT
WRONG? NO. AB 3047. PARDON ME,
DID WE JUST DO THAT? I THINK WE
JUST DID 3040. THAT WAS THE LAST
ONE. OKAY I WAS WE WERE I WAS WE
WERE TALKING PART OF SO PART OF
THE CHALLENGE IS, IS TO ADVISE
EVERYBODY IS THAT I NEED TO
BREAK BECAUSE WE GO INTO
SESSION. AND I WAS HOPING TO GET
HALFWAY THROUGH SO I COULD
REPORT THAT WE'RE HALFWAY
THROUGH AND WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET, WHICH IS
REALLY DISAPPOINTING. BUT, WE
ARE WE NEED TO TAKE A RECESS
BECAUSE I HAVE TO I HAVE TO GET
READY TO GO TO SESSION. AND SO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL TAKE THE
SENATE. I'M SORRY, I SEE I'M A
LITTLE BLOOD SUGAR. I HAVEN'T
HAD LUNCH. YES, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECESS AND WE WILL COME
BACK AFTER SESSION. IS HAS HAS,
IS COMPLETED. SO WE'RE MEETING I
DON'T KNOW FOR HOW LONG IF I, IF
I COULD GIVE YOU A TIME, IT'LL
BE AFTER 3:00 SOMETIME OR OTHER.
BUT THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. AND WE'LL SEE YOU BACK AT
THREE ISH. APPROPRIATION IS IN
RECESS UNTIL. OKAY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS BACK IN ORDER.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND, WE'RE GOING TO
GET ROLLING WITH THE REST OF THE
AGENDA. SO WE'RE GOING TO START
ON AB 1807 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, AND ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200 IN THE Þ
STREET BUILDING THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THIS MATTER.
SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FILE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1807 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. NEXT UP IS AB
1817, WHICH IS A BILL BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? WELCOME.
CHLOE. FERMIN WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS AND CA AND GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. FILE
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
AB 1817, WHICH IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MOVING ON TO AB 1832 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1832
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT.
ESTIMATES OF FISCAL IMPACT OF
APPROXIMATELY 4.2 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND 22 POSITIONS
AND 2526 AND ONGOING. THIS
INCLUDES $150,000 ANNUALLY FOR
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES SUCH AS
EXPERT CONSULTANTS, CIVIL FOR
CIVIL ACTIONS, TRANSLATION AND
INTERPRETATION, INTERPRETATION,
BILINGUAL PAY FOR STAFF. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTES THAT
ANY REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE EVALUATED
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
1832 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1834 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO FILE.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1834 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 1878 ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. AGAIN, THERE'S
NO QUESTION OR COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1878 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2098 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
CONNIE DELGADO, ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FILE THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATE AND
SINCE THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2098 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2125 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY?
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2125.
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COSTS OF 320,000 TO 474,000.
GENERAL FUND TO HIRE A
CONSULTANT TO GATHER AND ANALYZE
THE DATA FROM COUNTIES. PURSUANT
TO THE BILL, THE RANGE AND COSTS
DEPENDS ON HOW MANY COUNTIES ARE
SELECTED FOR THE STUDY. THE
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
25,000 TO 50,000 GENERAL FUND
AND 2425, AND FOR EACH FISCAL
YEAR THEREAFTER UNTIL THE STUDY
IS COMPLETED, TO HAVE STAFF
AGGREGATE AND SORT THROUGH DATA.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS, NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2125 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE, TAKING ON AB 2610 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE THE THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2610.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2757
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2757 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3246 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS A
NEUTRAL BUT NOTES SOME CONCERNS
ON AB 3246. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION DOES
ESTIMATE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL ARE
2.23 5,000,025 26, 2.45 MILLION
IN 2627, 685, AND 1027 28 AND
2029, AND THEN 2.53 MILLION IN
2030, 31, AND THEN $685,000
ONGOING TO SUPPORT THE REVIEW OF
THE ADVANCED RECONSTRUCTING
PROJECTS ON AN EXPEDITED BASIS.
HOWEVER, FINANCE NOTES THAT THIS
HAS NOT BEEN VERIFIED, THAT THE
CPC CPUC ESTIMATE HAS NOT BEEN
VERIFIED, AND SO WE'RE NOT SURE
IF THE COST MAGNITUDE IS TYPICAL
FOR GENERAL ORDER UPDATES. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, BUT THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITH THAT OBJECTION, AB 3246,
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO AB 1840 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA, THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT AN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, NO FILE. HOWEVER, I'M
SO SORRY, SENATOR. ON THE
PREVIOUS BILL, I INDICATED THE
WRONG, POSITION. IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AN OPPOSED, NOT A NEUTRAL
NOTE. CONCERNS I GOT IT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, NO FILE ON THIS
ONE. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
1840, WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
1888 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 1888.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF 432,000.
GENERAL FUND. IN 2425, 1,000,025
26 AND 921,026 27, AND ONGOING
TO ESTABLISH THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING UNIT THAT WILL TAKE
STEPS TO PREVENT LABOR
TRAFFICKING, INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING,
AND REPORT SPECIFIED DATA TO THE
LEGISLATURE. IN ADDITION, THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES COSTS OF
$3.9 MILLION, GENERAL FUND AND
20 POSITIONS, AND 25, 26 AND
ONGOING FOR STAFF. SO FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS, NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1888 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2080 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN,
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2080.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS,
RANGING FROM 135,000 TO 150,000.
THESE COSTS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE NEED FOR EACH SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE TO COLLECT THE REQUIRED
DATA POINTS, WHICH NECESSARILY
NECESSITATES, EXCUSE ME, NEW
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO INDICATES
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS,
RANGING BETWEEN 380 AND 410,000
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF RESOURCES
AT THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE'S TO
COLLECT AND REPORT THE DATA.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES NEW, ONE TIME
AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
THAT ARE NOT REFLECTED IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT FISCAL PLAN.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2080 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2795 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOESN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE BILL WOULD RESULT
IN ANNUAL STATE OPERATION COSTS
OF $566,000. GENERAL FUND. IN
24, 25 AND 544,000 GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROCESS AND REVIEW THE
ADDITIONAL REPORTS REQUIRED BY
THE BILL AND TO THE EXTENT THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT SERVICES ARE
NOT BILLABLE FOR INSURANCE OR
FEDERALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT, THESE COSTS WOULD
BE BORNE BY THE GENERAL FUND.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2795 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1885 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1885? ANNA
MATHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT BUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ FILE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1885 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 1905 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYBODY HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CURRENTLY IS OPPOSED TO ÁP AB
1905. THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ESTIMATES ONE TIME
PROPOSITION 98 COST OF
APPROXIMATELY 1.2 MILLION TO
UPDATE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS REGARDING RETREAT
RIGHTS AND SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND COLLEGE OF
THE LAW OF SAN FRANCISCO REPORT
THAT ANY COST FROM BILLS WOULD
BE MINOR AND ABSORBABLE.
HOWEVER, THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA INDICATES ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 3 MILLION
TO ENSURE CAMPUS COORDINATION
AND ACCESS TO REAL TIME
INFORMATION FOR STAFF AND
FACULTY. FINANCE DOES ASSUME
THESE COSTS MAY BE MAY BE TO
SUPPORT WORKLOAD THAT IS BEYOND
THE CURRENT WORKLOAD REQUIRED BY
THE èC OR BY THE BILL. ALSO,
èC ESTIMATES ONE TIME COSTS AND
LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
IMPOSES PROP 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND CREATE COULD CREATE
NON PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND COST PRESSURES THAT
ARE NOT REFLECTED IN THE STATE'S
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 1905 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2022 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ FILE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2022, WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2537 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CHLOE FERMIN
WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS SUPPORTS
THIS BILL ALONG WITH FACTS.
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE,
ECO SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA
AND GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NÓ FILE. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTION, AB 2537 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3233 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
AFTERNOON. GRANT WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. PROUD
SPONSOR. STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB
3233. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ALWAYS HAD THE
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE OIL AND
GAS TO PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES, AND THE ENVIRONMENT
FROM HARMFUL POLLUTION. THIS
BILL SHOULD HAVE NO FISCAL
IMPACT. IT DOES NOT MANDATE ANY
LOCAL ACTION. IT DOESN'T
DIRECTLY REGULATE ANY OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT, NOR DOES IT
CHANGE ANY OF THE CURRENT
RESPONSIBILITY RESPONSIBILITIES
OF STATE OIL AND GAS REGULATORS.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
CAL JIM TO EVALUATE WHETHER AN
OPERATOR HAS LOCAL REQUIREMENTS
BEFORE ISSUING A STATE PERMIT.
CAL JIM HAS ALWAYS TRACKED HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ORDINANCES
INTERACT WITH STATE REGULATIONS.
THIS WOULD NOT ADD ANY NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR CAL JIM TO
COORDINATE OR TRACK LOCAL
ORDINANCES. CLAIMS THAT THIS
MIGHT GIVE RISE TO A TAKINGS ARE
PURELY SPECULATIVE AND BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL. THE BILL
REDUCES THE RISK OF LITIGATION
AGAINST CITIES AND COUNTIES BY
PUTTING AN END TO RECENT
INDUSTRY THREATS THAT DISTORT A
COURT HOLDING. THAT IS WHY THE
BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, AND MANY INDIVIDUAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THIS BILL
DOES NOT DECIDE A CITY OR
COUNTY'S APPROACH TO OIL AND
GAS. IT ONLY AFFIRMS THAT
DECISION LIES WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. MOST DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THESE PROJECTS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO NOTE SUPPORT FROM PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT, BAY AREA, SOLANO COUNTY
DEM CENTRAL COMMITTEE,
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, LÀ STAND, LÀ
350, BAY AREA ACTION PROTECT
MONTEREY COUNTY CLIMATE HEALTH
NOW, SIERRA CLUB, CALIFORNIA,
AND THE CLIMATE CENTER. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OPPOSITION READY? YEAH.
OKAY. SO CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE MADERA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION, DID I MISS ANYBODY?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? YES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3233. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES
UNQUANTIFIABLE, BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
FOR THE LAND USE AND
CONSERVATION SECTION WITHIN
DOJ'S PUBLIC RIGHTS DIVISION TO
HANDLE POTENTIAL LITIGATION
CHALLENGING THIS BILL, DOJ NOTES
THIS WORKLOAD COULD REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN ATTORNEY
HOURS. CAL JAM ESTIMATES UNKNOWN,
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL. SINCE THIS BILL
ALLOWS LOCAL AGENCIES TO
DETERMINE WHAT REGULATIONS TO
ENACT THE RESOURCES REQUIRED FOR
CAL JAM TO COORDINATE WITH THESE
LOCAL AGENCIES COULD VARY.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
AS IT CREATES POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET FOR BOTH
CAL JAM TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND DOJ'S
ANTICIPATED WORKLOAD TO HANDLE
POTENTIAL LITIGATION CHALLENGING
THE BILL. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
MAY INCREASE THE STATE'S FISCAL
LIABILITY OF LOCAL AGENCY
RESTRICTIONS, RESULT IN MORE
ORPHANED WELLS. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3233 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 1907 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF HER BILL? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON AB 1907. HOWEVER, WE
WOULD NOTE THE BILL IS ESTIMATED
TO RESULT IN ANNUAL LOCAL
ASSISTANCE COSTS OF 1.3 MILLION,
OF WHICH 900,000 IS GENERAL FUND
AND 24, 25 AND 2.6 MILLION, OF
WHICH 1.9 MILLION IS GENERAL
FUND ONGOING FOR THE COUNTY.
WORKLOAD TO INCORPORATE AND
ANALYZE THE CANS ASSESSMENT TOOL
DATA. ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN ANNUAL
STATE OPERATION COSTS OF
400,000. GENERAL FUND IN 2425,
AND ONGOING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FOR ALL
CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1907 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2050 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MAKI, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
CLERK'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2050.
THE SECRETARY STATE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF 11.2 MILLION. GENERAL
FUND AND 2420 52. 8,000,025 26
AND ALTERNATING BETWEEN 8
MILLION AND 2.8 MILLION EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER. FOR SYSTEM
ENHANCEMENTS TO INTEGRATE VOTE
CAL WITH ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
AND INFORMATION CENTER, OR ERIC
PAY ONE TIME AN ANNUAL
MEMBERSHIP MEMBERSHIP FEES FOR
THE SOS TO USE ERIC AND SUPPORT
13 ADDITIONAL STAFF MEMBERS. THE
ONGOING COSTS COULD FLUCTUATE
DEPENDING ON IF THERE IS A
GENERAL ELECTION THAT YEAR,
WHICH RESULTS IN HIGHER GENERAL
FUND COSTS. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2050,
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2387
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BUT IN OPPOSITION? YES
PERMANENT FINANCE. NO FILE.
AGAIN, NO COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2387 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2839 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT BUT IN
OPPOSITION? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
OH, SORRY. OH, I'M HIDING BACK.
DANNY KENDALL KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NHÀ FILE NÓ FILE. YES.
OKIE DOKIE, NO. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
2839 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ÁP
2866 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. ANYBODY HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON AB
2866. HOWEVER, WE NOTE THAT THE
BILL IS ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND STATE
OPERATION COSTS OF 300 TO
400,024, 25 AND 2526, AND
ROUGHLY 100 TO 200,000IN 2627,
AND ONGOING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO UPDATE AND
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE
AND PROVIDE ONGOING EXPERTISE ON
POOL SAFETY. FINANCE WOULD NOTE
THAT WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE, ALTHOUGH
THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO LOCAL
AGENCIES, THOSE COSTS ARE NOT
UNIQUE TO LOCAL AGENCIES. SEEING
THAT WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2866 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
NEXT UP IS AB 3260 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS, AS
A CO CO-SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO AB 3260.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE ESTIMATES
THE FISCAL IMPACT TO BE 10.72
7,000,052 POSITIONS IN 2427,
29.016 MILLION AND 136
POSITIONS, AND 2526 32 MILLION,
32.0046 MILLION AND 144
POSITIONS, AND 2627, 33.25
MILLION AND 144 POSITIONS IN
2728, 33.38, 2 MILLION AND 144
POSITIONS IN 2829 AND 32.097
MILLION AND 144 POSITIONS IN 29,
30, AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FROM
THE FEE SUPPORTED BY THE MANAGED
CARE FUND. JUST AS A REMINDER,
$1 MILLION INCREASE TO THE
MANAGED CARE FUND RESULTS IN A
TWO CENT INCREASE ON ASSESSMENTS
TO FULL SERVICE HEALTH PLANS AND
A $0.01 INCREASE TO SPECIALIZED
HEALTH PLANS. SO THE EXTENT THIS
BILL RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL
ASSESSMENTS ON HEALTH PLANS,
CONSUMERS MAY FACE INCREASED
PREMIUMS. IN ADDITION, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES THE FISCAL
IMPACT TO BE 163,024 25, 294,025
26, 245,026 27, AND 238,027 28,
AND THEREAFTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 3260, WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AND WE HAVE
COMMITTEES WITH MEMBERS BECAUSE
THE MEMBERS ARE CHAIR. SAY THAT
AGAIN. OH I. SO MOVING ON, ON
THE AGENDA. NEXT UP IS AB 1970
1917 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1917? HOW ABOUT
AN OPPOSITION? WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CARLOS MACHADO WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
CONSULTATION MEANS IN THE BILL,
THE COHORT OF TRUSTEES ARE
ELECTED IN 2024. WILL BE THE
FIRST COHORT THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO TAKE THE TRAINING
UNDER THE BILL. THAT REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF OUR 5000
TRUSTEES. AND THEY WOULD BE
REPRESENTING ABOUT HALF OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OUT THERE, 500.
THOSE DISTRICTS WOULD BE GOING
TO THE DISTRICT OR TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO SEEK A
CONSULTATION ON THAT COURSE.
CONTENT. THAT WOULD BE A LOT. WE
THINK, FOR GIVEN THE TIME FRAME.
THAT'S BUILT IN THE BILL FOR THE
DISTRICT OR THE DEPARTMENT TO
DEVELOP, ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
CONSULTATION PROGRAM AND TO
LEAVE TIME FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN THOSE 2500
TRUSTEES. SO WE'D LIKE FOR OR
WE'RE SEEKING AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD TRACK THE CONSULTATION
THAT THE FPPC CURRENTLY PROVIDES
FOR THE CONSULTATION FOR F
ETHICS, TRAINING THAT'S PROVIDED
NOW, SO WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS,
WE WOULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION,
BUT WE'RE CONCERNED THAT IT
INCREASES COSTS FOR DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
TRAINING. IF WE HAVE A VERY
SHORT WINDOW IN WHICH TO PROVIDE
IT, BECAUSE WE DON'T GET THE
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
WHEN WE NEED IT. SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FOR THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1970 17
WILL BE MOVED TO SUSPENSE AB
2134 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2134.
FINANCE ESTIMATES THAT THIS BILL
MAY CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH ONGOING PROP 98.
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF AN UNKNOWN
AMOUNT FOR EMPLOYING ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE SPECIFIED INFORMATION TO
NEW EMPLOYEES. ADDITIONALLY, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
ONGOING PROPOSITION 98 WORKLOAD
COSTS IN THE LOW THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION. IN
ADDITION, THE BILL WILL LIKELY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COSTS OF AN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT. AND WE ALSO
WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL'S
PROPOSAL COULD BE CONSIDERED A
RETROACTIVE ENHANCEMENT TO
BENEFITS RISK CONTRADICTS WITH
THE INTENT OF THE 2013 PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES PENSION REFORM ACT.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY IMPOSE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND
INCREASE LIABILITY FOR CALSTRS
AND CALPERS RETIREMENT BENEFITS
IF A LARGE PORTION OF MEMBERS
RETAIN ADDITIONAL UNUSED SICK
LEAVE TIME BEYOND THE AMOUNT
THAT IS CURRENTLY EXPECTED, AND
IT GETS CONVERTED TO SERVICE
CREDIT AT RETIREMENT, THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2134 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2226, SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR AND STAFF, TONY
TRUJILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION,
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND A
PROUD SUPPORTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ON I O COMMITTEES ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT, PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND JUST
LIKING TO HIGHLIGHT OUR, IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO WOULD
BE ADMITTED UNDER MANDATORY
KINDERGARTEN IS LESS THAN THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WE SEE FROM
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. AND WE
BELIEVE THE COST IS FULLY
ABSORBABLE WITHIN THE PROP 98
GUARANTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2226.
FINANCE ESTIMATES THAT THIS THAT
THIS BILL WILL CREATE ON GOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS BETWEEN 202 AND 588.3
MILLION, BECAUSE IT WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL ENROLLMENT BY ROUGHLY
16,000 TO 47,000 STUDENTS. THIS
ESTIMATE USES. FINANCES 2023
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S 2324 ENROLLMENT
DATA, 2324 KINDERGARTEN FUNDING
RATES IN THE HISTORICAL AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE YIELD. FINANCE
ALSO NOTES THAT ALTHOUGH THIS
BILL LIKELY CREATES A STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM, THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REQUIRED
SERVICES WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH
LWCF AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
ENTITLEMENTS WOULD, WHICH WOULD
OFFSET THE PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF THE
POTENTIAL MANDATE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2226 WILL BE
PLACED ON SUSPENSE AB 2309 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO PHÐ THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2309 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2473 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. AND HE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2473
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 121,000.
IT WOULD REPEAL THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY FINANCE
NOTES CONCERNS THAT AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED TO EDUCATION CODE
SECTION 44 4274.2, WITH CHAPTER
OUT AMENDMENTS MADE TO THAT
SECTION BY THE K-12 OMNIBUS
TRAILER BILL. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2473 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
1937 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? NO FILE. NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1937 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 1960 62 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY WANT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 1962,
BUT DOES NOTE CONCERN THAT TO
THE EXTENT THIS BILL RESULTS IN
ADDITIONAL CASES ENTERING THE
COURT SYSTEM OR INCREASES IN THE
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION, THE BILL
COULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD FOR TRIAL COURTS AND
PLACE ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEMS. THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1962 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2083 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CHLOE FERMIN
WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS IN
SUPPORT ALONG WITH FACTS NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT PROVIDED IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2083.
THE. EXCUSE ME, THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES
TOTAL ONE TIME COSTS OF 7.8
MILLION FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AND SEVEN LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS TO WORK WITH
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND DEVELOP
THE SCOPING PLAN THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES. IN ADDITION, THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
ESTIMATES TOTAL ONE TIME COSTS
OF 793,000 FROM THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAMS ACCOUNT AND
TWO LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
CONDUCT THE EVALUATION THAT THE
BILL REQUIRES. FINANCE OPPOSES
THE BILL AS IT IMPOSES
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON VARIOUS
STATE SPECIAL FUNDS, INCLUDING
IRPA, WHICH IS IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. ADDITIONAL EXPENSES
WILL EXACERBATE THE FUNDS AND
INSOLVENCY, AND THESE COSTS WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2083 WILL BE
PLACED ON SUSPENSE AB 2580, 2583
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
CHLOE, FOR BEING CLEANER FOR
KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FACTS, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY,
PEEPS AND CA AND GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. THANK YOU. ETHAN
NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF REDWOOD CITY, RANCHO PALOS
VERDES AND SANTA ROSA IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. ANA
ARCHIMEDES, ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE,
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2583 WILL
BE MOVED TO SUSPENSE AB 2642 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. CASSANDRA WHETSTONE
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND SUPPORT. JULIE
CHAPMAN VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MARCUS, ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? NO FILE. THERE'S NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB 2642 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND.
MOVING ON TO AB 2655. WHO IS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION? ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? HELLO, DANNY CANDO
KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ FILE.
THERE IS NO COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2655 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3251 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 3251. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE I'M SORRY FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON THE BILL BECAUSE
IT CONTINUES THE CBA'S AUTHORITY
TO LICENSE AND REGULATE
ACCOUNTANTS AT A MINIMAL COST TO
THE STATE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3251 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3252 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON AB 3252. THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD ESTIMATES A ONE TIME COST
OF 30,000 FROM THE COURT
REPORTERS FUND TO ADD THE NEW
LICENSE TYPE TO A WEBSITE TO ITS
WEBSITE. THE BOARD DOES NOTE THE
ONGOING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW LICENSE
TYPE IS UNQUANTIFIABLE AT THIS
TIME, BECAUSE IT'S UNKNOWN HOW
MANY NEW LICENSES WILL RESULT.
BUT THE BOARD DOES NOTE ALTHOUGH
THE WORKLOAD IS DIFFICULT TO
ESTIMATE, ADDITIONAL FEE
REVENUES ARE EXPECTED TO COVER
THE COSTS. THEREFORE, FINANCE IS
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL BECAUSE IT
EXTENDS THE REGULATION AND
LICENSURE OF COURT REPORTERS AND
MINIMAL COST TO THE STATE. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3252 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 3253 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT? TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON AB 3253 BECAUSE THE BILL
CONTINUES, THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
BOARD TO LICENSE AND REGULATE
LAND SURVEYORS, ENGINEERS,
GEOLOGISTS AND GEOPHYSICISTS, AT
A MINIMUM AT A MINOR ABSORBABLE
COST TO THE STATE. NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS COMING FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3253. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 3254 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY AND
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 3254 AS THE.
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH SOME OF THE
ASPECTS OF THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL COSTS OF THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL FUND, IT
EXTENDS THE OPERATIONS OF THE
CFP AND OTHER ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN SAVINGS. NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3254 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3255 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON AB 3255 AS IT EXTENDS THE
OPERATION OF THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS FROM
JANUARY 21ST, 2025 TO JANUARY
1ST, 2029. AND WHILE THE BNP TÊ
ESTIMATES THE RETIRED LICENSE
AUTHORIZED THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN AN UNKNOWN BUT OBSERVABLE
REDUCTION IN THE REVENUE TO THE
FUND BECAUSE THE LICENSEES WILL
QUALIFY FOR RETIREE STATUS, WILL
NO LONGER PAY THE FEE, THEY DO
NOT ANTICIPATE THAT THEY CANNOT
ABSORB IT, AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 3255 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1973 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
BUT OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1973 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
2645 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ FILE. AGAIN, THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL
FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2645 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
20. 20 002004, BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FILE NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS
THE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2004 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 20 ZERO AND
9096. ALL OF A SUDDEN, I CAN'T
SAY NUMBERS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 2096.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
INDICATE MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
COSTS, AND WE ARE NEUTRAL
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO FILE RESTRAINING
ORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS
WITHOUT CREATING SIGNIFICANT
COSTS TO THE STATE. NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2096 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2368 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2368.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION COMMISSION ESTIMATES
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL ARE 1.857 MILLION FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
UTILITIES REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT
ONGOING, AND SEVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO CONDUCT RELIABILITY
MODELING AND REVIEW THE RESULTS
ON A BIANNUAL BASIS FOR
REPORTING AND COORDINATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED THE BILL, AS IT RESULTS
IN COSTS THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET, AND MIGHT
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL FEES ON
CONSUMERS, NO QUESTIONS COMING
FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2368 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2490 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2490,
THE HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION OR HEALTH CARE ACT.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION ESTIMATES.
UNKNOWN GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES IN THE LOW TO TENS OF
MILLIONS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
ESTABLISHMENT AS WELL AS DIRECT
FUNDING OF THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PROGRAM AND ALIGNMENT WITH THE
BILL. HØI ESTIMATES COST OF
APPROXIMATELY 5% OF THE FUNDS
APPROPRIATED. THE GRANT PROGRAM
FOR ADMINISTRATION AND OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROGRAM. A FISCAL FROM
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY WAS NOT AVAILABLE AT
THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS, BUT TO
THE EXTENT THIS BILL CREATES
COSTS FOR THE AUTHORITY, THESE
COSTS WOULD BE BORNE BY THE
GENERAL FUND FINANCE AS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL, AS IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES.
GENERAL FUND NOT INCLUDED IN THE
STATE'S FISCAL PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY, IT SHOULD BE NOTED
CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED OVER 400
MILLION SINCE 2021 TO PROTECT
THE RIGHT TO SAFE AND ACCESSIBLE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS COMING FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2490 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2595. 2559 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2559 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2815 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. CLEANER
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FACTS WITH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE. ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS AND CA AND GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2815 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2019 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOOVER.
IS THERE ANYBODY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOOVER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYBODY LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2019,
WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES WITH MIDDLE COLLEGE
HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND EARLY
COLLEGE HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAMS ON
OR BEFORE AUGUST 1ST, 2026, AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO SUBMIT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
REPORT ON VARIOUS MIDDLE AND
EARLY COLLEGE HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS DATA. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS IT CREATES A COST OF
100,000 NON PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND FOR CTE TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL. NO QUESTIONS
FROM COMING FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION AB 2019 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2831 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOOVER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2831.
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION INDICATES ONE TIME
COSTS OF 397,000, AND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF $687,000
FOR FOUR NEW POSITIONS. EXCUSE
ME, A FINANCE NOTES THAT THE
OFFICE ESTIMATE INCLUDES
POSITION, AUTHORITY AND
ASSOCIATED FUNDING FROM THE 2024
STATE SCHOOL FACILITIES FUND. IN
ADDITION, K¾T INDICATES THE BILL
REQUIRES $763,000. ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR FOUR NEW
POSITIONS FOR OPERATING EXPENSES
AND EQUIPMENT. SORRY.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL, FINANCE IS OPPOSED
BECAUSE IT WILL LIKELY CREATE
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING COST
PRESSURES EITHER TO IMPLEMENT
THE INTENDED PROGRAM OF
PROPOSITION TWO. BOND FUNDING IS
NOT AVAILABLE, OR TO CONTINUE IT
AFTER PROPOSITION TWO BOND
FUNDING IS NO LONGER AVAILABLE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
2831. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
REMOVED RESCHEDULED. OKAY AND
NIELSEN AT THE BEGINNING. AB
2903 HAS BEEN RESCHEDULED, SO
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP RIGHT OVER
THAT AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB
3102 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOOVER,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE, NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3102 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3216 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOOVER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN
IN SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3216.
THE BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE,
RANGING IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND FOR
SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP AND ADOPT THE
SPECIFIED SMARTPHONE POLICIES
REQUIRED BY THE BILL.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL COULD
CREATE ONGOING PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS, LIKELY IN
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO UPDATE
THESE POLICIES EVERY FIVE YEARS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3216 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2033
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANNA
MATHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, A PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ PHÐ. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2033 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2207 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS COMING
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2207 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2262 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYBODY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2262. AT
THE TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS, GO
BAS INDICATED THERE ARE UNKNOWN
GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR GÓMEZ TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND TO ISSUE
A DATA CALL Ã. GÓMEZ DID
INDICATE COSTS COULD BE
RESOLVABLE TO THE EXTENT CITIES
AND COUNTIES DO NOT REQUEST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, BUT COULD
RESULT IN THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL TO THE
EXTENT CITIES AND COUNTIES
REQUIRE REQUEST LARGE AMOUNTS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
MAY RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2262 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2724 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2724
BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE A
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE IN
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS TO LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND STATE
SPECIAL SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON PRE-REGISTERING
TO VOTE AND PROVIDE A PAPER COPY
OF A VOTER REGISTRATION UPON
REQUEST TO THEIR PUPILS. THE
BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY HOW THE
INFORMATION COULD BE PROVIDED TO
PUPILS, SO TO THE EXTENT AN LEA
OPTS TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
BY EMAIL OR POST ON ITS WEBSITE,
THESE COSTS MIGHT BE MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2724 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2827 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT ETHAN
NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2827.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE DOESN'T
ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT
RESULTING FROM THE BILL GIVEN
THAT THEY ALREADY ALLOCATE FUNDS
FOR PEST PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
CONSULT WITH RELEVANT AGENCIES.
HOWEVER, CDFA NOTES THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THIS BILL WOULD
RESULT IN CDFA AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES NEEDING TO AUGMENT AND
EXPAND THESE EFFORTS, IT WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
FINANCE ALSO NOTES THAT THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES, POTENTIALLY IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, TO
EXPAND EXISTING EFFORTS TO
DETECT, CONTROL, MONITOR AND
ERADICATE INVASIVE SPECIES.
THEREFORE, WE ARE OPPOSED
BECAUSE IT COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN, AND IS
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS INVASIVE SPECIES. NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2827 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2040 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE, ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FILE, THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2040 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2740 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT. CHLOE
FOR MAIN WITH WITH CLEANER FOR
KIDS AND SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO AND
STANDING UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD
NOTE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
INDICATES MOSTLY MINOR
ABSORBABLE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL.
HOWEVER, THE REQUIREMENT FOR
REMAINING AT A MEDICAL FACILITY
NO FEWER THAN THREE DAYS AFTER
DELIVERY COULD DRIVE A FISCAL
IMPACT IF THE HOSPITAL WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE DISCHARGED THE
MOTHER INFANT SOONER THAN THAT.
TIMELINE THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
COMING FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2740 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2048 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
FONG, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? WE'LL GO BACK TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANNA MATHEWS
WITH THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2048.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
INDICATES SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
STATE OPERATIONS GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR THE LIFE OF THE
WORKING GROUP OF BETWEEN 700,000
TO $1 MILLION. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ALSO ANTICIPATES MODERATE
ONE TIME PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES FOR THE
DURATION OF THE WORKING GROUP OF
UP TO 200,000. THEREFORE,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT CREATES SIGNIFICANT
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
SUPPORT THE WORKING GROUP AND
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES TO SUPPORT DISTRICT
AND COLLEGE PARTICIPATION ON THE
WORKGROUP. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2048 WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2500 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ. FILE THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2500 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2931
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NÓ FILE. AGAIN, NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AM
I ON 2520? THANK EVERYONE. 2931
OKAY, DIDN'T MAKE MY MARK, NO
QUESTIONS. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WANTED TO MAKE SURE I HAD THE
RIGHT BILL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB 2931. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 3087 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO FILE. NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3087.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO AB 2060 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SORIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? BUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2060.
THE WATER BOARD ESTIMATES COSTS
AND STAFF REQUIREMENTS.
REQUIREMENTS MAY POTENTIALLY
INCREASE TO 900,004 POSITIONS.
ONGOING FROM THE WATER RIGHTS
FUND. IF THE WATER RIGHTS FUND
CAN'T SUFFICIENTLY COVER THE
ONGOING RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL, THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES, DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER OF PERMITS AND HOW THEY
ARE USED. THEREFORE, FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN COST OF THE WATER
RIGHTS FUND AND POTENTIAL COSTS
AND COST PRESSURES TO GENERAL
FUND NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET, AND THE BILL COULD ALSO
LEAD TO FEE INCREASES TO FEE
PAYERS. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2060 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2104 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2104 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3275 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SORIA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3275.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL TO BE 4.9899 8,000,019
POSITIONS, AND 2526 8.34
9,000,026 POSITIONS AND 2627
8.34 3,000,026 POSITIONS AND
2728, 5.8 4,000,026 POSITIONS,
AND 28, 29 AND 5.89 3,000,026
POSITIONS, AND 29, 30 AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FROM THE FEE
SUPPORTER FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND. IN ADDITION, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES FISCAL
IMPACT TO BE $63,000 AND 2526
FROM THE INSURANCE FUND. FINANCE
RECOMMENDS OPPOSING THE BILL AS
IT RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT COST
NOT INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S
SPENDING PLAN, AND THESE COSTS
WOULD LIKELY BE PASSED ON TO
CONSUMERS THROUGH HIGHER
PREMIUMS. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 3275. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2068 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ORTEGA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2068.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS. EXCUSE ME? THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT ESTIMATES $204,000
FROM THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND AND 25, 26, AND
193,000 ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL. FINANCE NOTES THAT THIS
BILL MAY ALSO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
BUT UNKNOWN COSTS FOR STATE
AGENCIES THAT CONTRACT OUT FOR
CALL CENTERS TO PROVIDE REPORTS
TO DLS. FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
COSTS, NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2063 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2446 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2446.
FINANCE IS PRELIMINARY. ESTIMATE
ESTIMATES THAT THE BILL WILL
LIKELY COST WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN COSTS IN THE LOW MILLIONS TO
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND AND FEDERAL FUNDS
ANNUALLY TO IMPLEMENT THE DIAPER
BENEFIT. COSTS WILL DEPEND ON
THE UTILIZATION AND BENEFIT
STRUCTURE, SO EXCUSE ME. EFFORTS
TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF MEDI-CAL
MEDI-CAL BENEFITS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. AND SO FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S SPENDING
PLAN. NO QUESTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2446 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2557 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
CABALLERO, BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
ASTHMA. CALIFORNIA PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? ETHAN NAGLER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICTS, THE CITIES OF
BAKERSFIELD, BEAUMONT, CARLSBAD,
CORONA, FOSTER CITY, MERCED,
SANTA ROSA, AND THE TOWN OF
HILLSBORO IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, VERY MUCH. I THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS JEANNE
HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION, ALSO OPPOSED ARE
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERANS SERVICES OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION, THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS,
AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION, THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE COUNTIES OF
RIVERSIDE, SANTA BARBARA,
VENTURA, AND LOS ANGELES ARE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. COUNTIES ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THIS BILL, VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AARON AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHRIS LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS, IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M ERIC LA. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL 58 COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTY OF PLACER BUTTE, MERCED,
STANISLAUS, KERN, SAN JOAQUIN,
SHASTA, HUMBOLDT, FRESNO, AND
KINGS, ALL IN OPPOSITION. AND
THEN ALSO OPPOSED IS THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS THE
SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN AREA, SOUTH
SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 2557.
HOWEVER, WE WOULD NOTE CONCERN
THAT THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS
GOVERNING THE POSTING OF
POTENTIALLY LARGE VOLUME OF
INFORMATION ONLINE CONCERNING
IMPACTED CONTRACTS, COUPLED WITH
THE REQUIRED EMPLOYEE BARGAINING
UNIT NOTIFICATIONS AND THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT MUST
BE INCLUDED IN IMPACTED
CONTRACTS, IMPOSES A SIGNIFICANT
NEW WORKLOAD ON LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT ELECT TO CONTRACT FOR
SERVICES. WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO
EXISTING CONTRACTS. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL WOULD
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE, BECAUSE ANY
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON A LOCAL
AGENCY ARE THE RESULT OF LOCAL
AGENCIES DISCRETIONARY DECISION
TO CONTRACT OUT FOR SERVICES.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2557 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2959 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PROVIDED IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2959.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATES UNOBSERVABLE COSTS OF
$4.3 MILLION BEGINNING IN 2425
AND ONGOING FOR POSITIONS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
ANTICIPATES UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIAL COST IMPACTS AS A
RESULT OF THE BILL. IN ADDITION,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL TO REDUCE COSTS FOR
FAMILIES AND OFFER AFFORDABLE,
FRESH AND NUTRITIOUS FOOD ITEMS
AND PRISON VENDING MACHINES, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY, IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW CDCR WOULD ENFORCE
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED BY THIS
BILL WHEN THE DOOR OPERATES AND
CONTRACTS FOR THE VENDING
MACHINE SERVICES. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2959 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2082 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO, THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON HIS
BILLS ON HIS BILL, AND, LOOKING
FOR TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. PHÐ
COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2082 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2485 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? MÀ CÁC ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ. FILE COMMITTEE HAS
NO COMMENTS OR CONCERNS AND THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2485 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 2622 IS BILL
BY JUAN CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COMMITTEE
HAS NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2622 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2736 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2736.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ANTICIPATES INCREASED COSTS
RANGING FROM BETWEEN 200 TO
$600,000, ONGOING FROM
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND. IF
THE BILL WERE TO RESULT IN A FEE
WAIVER INCREASE OF 5 TO 15%.
ALTHOUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
NOTES IT IS DIFFICULT TO
ESTIMATE ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL BECAUSE
THE STUDENT POPULATION
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM IS
SMALL. UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES INCREASED COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY 2.5 MILLION.
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF NEW AND CONTINUING
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS RECEIVING FEDERAL US
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
BENEFITS, CURRENTLY DO NOT
QUALIFY FOR THE STATE COLLEGE
FEE WAIVER. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WAS UNABLE TO
ESTIMATE HOW MANY STUDENTS WHO
EXCLUSIVELY RECEIVED THE FEDERAL
BENEFIT WOULD ENROLL, AND
THEREFORE COULD NOT PROVIDE A
NUMBER. HOWEVER THE FINANCE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE ASSOCIATED
COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE HIGHER
THAN THE ESTIMATES PROVIDED BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
GIVEN THE RELATIVE ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS FOR EACH SYSTEM.
THEREFORE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2736 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. OKAY PERFECT.
NEXT UP IS AB 2929 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY. EXCUSE ME. OPPOSED TO
AB 2929. THE BILL WOULD RESULT
IN ESTIMATED COSTS OF 624
625,000, OF WHICH 459,000 IS
GENERAL FUND AND 24, 25 AND 1.28
OR 2 FOUR 8 MILLION, OF WHICH
917,000 IS GENERAL FUND AND 25
AND 26 AND ONGOING FOR INCREASED
WORKLOAD FOR COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKERS TO DOCUMENT AND UPDATE
NEW INFORMATION IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTS RELATED TO
THE FAMILY FINDING EFFORTS FOR
EVERY SIX MONTHS PER APPLICABLE
CASE. THEREFORE, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AS IT RESULTS IN
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. AGAIN, THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO, AB 2929 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND FINALLY AB
3179 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SEE IF THERE'S ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3179 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. OKAY, THAT FINISHES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO ÁP
2072 BY MR. CALDERON ON PAGE
NINE. RIGHT THERE. OKAY, OKAY.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TAKE UP A
BILL OUT OF ORDER, WHICH IS AB
2872 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR CABALLERO.
JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA, DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA, PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ERIC CHIRLA,
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ENFORCEMENT BRANCH,
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DEPUTY CHIEF FELICIA
LEEB WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, AND I'M ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. LANCE
FERRARI, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. CAPTAIN. I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, JAY
FROMAN, DETECTIVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, SUSAN
BURNS. CAPTAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FRAUD
DIVISION, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. ALICIA
DANIELS, SERGEANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, DETECTIVE
VLADIMIR OLEYNIK WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FRAUD
DIVISION. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE MARISSA GARCIA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE GALGIANI HUESO,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE ALBERTO ARMENTA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE JOSEPHINE. TORA
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. AND I,
TOO, SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE MICHELLE GUICHARD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHRISTINA SMITH, CAPTAIN, WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DETECTIVE JOE LARA,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DETECTIVE SERGEANT DANIEL MACIAS
WITH CDI. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CURRENTLY OPPOSES AB 2872. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN COSTS OF $12.4
MILLION, OF WHICH 368,000 IS
GENERAL FUND AND 2425 AND
ONGOING. DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ANTICIPATES THIS BILL WILL
IMPACT APPROXIMATELY 233
ESTABLISHED POSITIONS. FINANCE
IS OPPOSED BECAUSE THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN ONGOING COSTS THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FISCAL PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO NEGOTIATE SALARY INCREASES
FOR BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN
MEMBERS EMPLOYED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE THROUGH
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS, BASED ON RELEVANT AND
CURRENT DATA, SUCH AS ECONOMIC
AND DEMOGRAPHIC FIGURES. VERY
GOOD. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
AND I KNOW MANY OF YOU WERE HERE
THIS MORNING. IT'S A LONG DAY,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2872 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO, OUR REGULAR AGENDA,
AND WE'LL TAKE UP, WE'LL START
WITH AGAIN WITH AB 1994, WHICH
IS A THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZERBO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. WE'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON AB 1994 BECAUSE IT CODIFIES
AN EXISTING POSITION CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER DEPUTY SECRETARIES
WITHIN CALVET, AND DOES NOT
CREATE NEW COST TO THE STATE. NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1994 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2086 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ. FILE
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITH
THAT OBJECTION, AB 2086 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2135 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. AND ANYONE HERE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE WHO
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2135,
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS STATES THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE REQUIRED
DEPENDING ON THE VOLUME AND
COMPLEXITY OF CASELOADS, APPEALS
THAT MAY STEM FROM THE
ADDITIONAL CASES COMPLETED OR
THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF THE BILL'S
FISCAL IMPACT. DER DOES ESTIMATE
A FISCAL IMPACT OF $330,000 AT A
LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
FUND, AND 25, 26, AND $319,000
ONGOING. FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE
NEW COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2135 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2499 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? CHLOE FERMIN CLEAN
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FOX NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS AND CA GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO AND
STANDING UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
PERMANENT FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2499. THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES A NEED FOR
THREE POSITIONS AND 629,000
GENERAL FUND, AND 25, 26 AND
613,000 GENERAL FUND, AND 2627
AND ONGOING TO INVESTIGATE
APPROXIMATELY 100 CLAIMS
ANNUALLY. AS A RESULT OF THE
BILL. FINANCE ALSO NOTES THE
BILL IS THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
COST NEUTRAL BECAUSE CRD CANNOT
USE THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND, WHICH DLC USES
TO FUND ENFORCEMENT OF THESE
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS. THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
IS FUNDED BY FEES ON EMPLOYEES,
WORKER'S COMPENSATION PREMIUMS
FROM DLS WORK TO ENFORCE THE
LABOR CODE. SO FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET. NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2499 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2670 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2670.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COST OF 1.6 MILLION TO 1.8
MILLION. IN 2526, 2.4 TO 3.5
MILLION IN 2627 AND 2.4 TO ì
MILLION ONGOING, AND FOR
POSITIONS TO DEVELOP AND
ADMINISTER THE AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN, OVERSEE THE CONTRACTS
AND FACILITATE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. FINANCE NOTES THAT
COSTS WOULD DEPEND ON THE SCOPE
OF THE AWARENESS CAMPAIGN, AND
WE ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COST TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED OVER $400 MILLION TO
PROTECT THE RIGHT TO SAFE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. NO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2670 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2999 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
HER BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2999
BECAUSE IT'S IT DOES HAVE A
POTENTIAL FOR STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF UP TO $24
MILLION FOR SCHOOLS TO ESTABLISH
HOMEWORK POLICIES AND TO PUBLISH
THEM ON THE INTERNET WEBSITE OF
THE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY OR
SCHOOL SITE. AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF $38,000
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2999 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 3167 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, BUT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SORRY, I
WAS OFF ON A BILL. YES, FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3167,
EXCUSE ME. THE BUREAU OF PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
ESTIMATES UNOBSERVABLE COSTS OF
$416,000 FROM THE PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT, 2627 AND
ONGOING FOR TWO AND A HALF
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS AN INCREASE
IN WORKLOAD RESULTING FROM THE
ELIMINATION OF THE EXEMPTION OF
AN ACCREDITED NONPROFIT
CORPORATION FROM HAVING TO
REGISTER WITH BPP AS AN OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTION. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT, POST
PRIVATE POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATION FUND COSTS, NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3167 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2108 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? 3167 CHEN WE JUST
DID THAT. WE JUST DID IT. I'M SO
SORRY. IT'S OKAY. NO, I THOUGHT
WE JUST DID. NO, BECAUSE WE, AT
21, WE'VE DONE 2107 AND 2618 IS
NOT ON THE ON THE. YEAH MY
APOLOGIES. IT'S OKAY. AT LEAST
IT'S NOT ME THIS TIME. SO I KNOW
THAT'S TRUE. SO WE ARE ON AB
2108 AND THERE WERE NO BODY
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND NOBODY
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2108,
WHICH REQUIRES A COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKER OR PROBATION OFFICER TO
IMMEDIATELY NOTIFY SPECIFIED
PERSONS AND ENTITIES WHEN THEY
RECEIVE INFORMATION THAT A CHILD
OR NON MINOR DEPENDENT RECEIVING
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES IS ABSENT
FROM FOSTER CARE. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2108 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2138 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. WE'LL CHECK AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED. AB 2138. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
THE BILL WILL RESULT IN COSTS OF
69,000 GENERAL FUND IN 24, 25,
2,000,025 26 AND 1.6 MILLION IN
26, 27 AND 2728. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ALSO ANTICIPATES THE
NEED FOR 272,000 GENERAL FUND IN
28, 29 AND ONGOING. THE PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS. EXCUSE ME,
THE COMMISSION ON THE PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPERATIONAL COSTS
RESULTING FROM THE LEGISLATION.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES, NOT IN THE 2024
BUDGET TO FUND THE PILOT PROGRAM
AND OTHER ACTIVITIES. ACTIVITIES
DESCRIBED IN THE BILL. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2138 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2246 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON AB 2246 BECAUSE THE BILL
EXPANDS THE DEFINITION OF HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE STATE, THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2246 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2695 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2695.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ANTICIPATES COSTS OF 430,000,
GENERAL FUND IN 24, 25 AND
130,000 GENERAL FUND AND 2526
AND ONGOING AND ONE POSITION TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL. THIS INCLUDES A 3000
$300,000 ONE TIME IN 2425 TO
MODIFY THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
INCIDENT-BASED REPORTING SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION, THE BILL MAY CREATE
A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
BECAUSE LOCAL REPORTING AGENCIES
MAY INCUR COSTS TO COMPLY WITH
THE ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. AT THE TIME OF OUR
ANALYSIS, THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL WAS NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE A
FISCAL ESTIMATE FOR THE BILL.
HOWEVER, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET ACT, AND MAY CREATE
A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, AND THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2695 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2711 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO. FILE
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, AND THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS BY THE
COMMITTEE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2711 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 3015 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? CHLOE FERMIN WITH
CLEANUP FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT
ALONG WITH FACTS NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS SEEKING ACTION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 3015 BECAUSE IT
WOULD ENABLE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
FROM CALIFORNIA'S FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES TO RECEIVE
IN-STATE TUITION AND FEE RATES.
HOWEVER, FINANCE IS CONCERNED
THAT UNLIKE PRIOR GOOD NEIGHBOR
TUITION AND FEE POLICY
LEGISLATION, THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES BUT DOES NOT REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
ENTER INTO RECIPROCAL AGREEMENTS
WITH ARIZONA, NEVADA, AND OREGON
TO PROVIDE A SIMILAR BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ARE THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
3015 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 20 2115 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MAKI ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY? LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, THE PROUD SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT, AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS,
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2115.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FISCAL WAS NOT
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME OF THE
ANALYSIS, HOWEVER FINANCES
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES THAT THIS
BILL WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT DC'S
OVERSIGHT OF CHANGES TO
ADMINISTRATION AND TREATMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR ADMISSIONS TO A
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAM.
FINANCE ALSO NOTES THAT THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN ONGOING
PROPOSITION 30 STATE MANDATE
COSTS OF AN UNKNOWN GENERAL FUND
AMOUNT. TO THE EXTENT THIS BILL
INCREASES UTILIZATION OF
TREATMENT, DO THE CHANGES IN
REQUIREMENT FOR ADMISSION
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN ONGOING
COSTS, INCLUDING POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION 30 STATE
REIMBURSEMENT COSTS THAT ARE NOT
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2115 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2182 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2182.
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES. THE BILL
RESULTS IN A FISCAL IMPACT OF
$3.2 MILLION FROM THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS ENFORCEMENT FUND IN
THE FIRST YEAR, 2.9 MILLION IN
THE SECOND AND $2.7 MILLION
ONGOING FINANCE NOTES THAT THE
STATE PUBLIC WORKS ENFORCEMENT
FUND IS STRUCTURALLY DEFICIENT,
WITH EXPENDITURES EXPECTED TO
EXCEED REVENUES BY APPROXIMATELY
13,000,000 IN 24, 25, 2023.
BUDGET INCLUDED STATUTORY
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW DER TO ADJUST
FEES FOR THE STATE PUBLIC WORKS
ENFORCEMENT FUNDING BEGINNING ON
JULY 1ST, 2026, AND UNTIL DER
CAN INCREASE THE FEES TO
ACCOMMODATE NEW COSTS. THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS ENFORCEMENT FUND
CANNOT SUPPORT NEW EXPENDITURES.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET. NO
QUESTIONS FROM QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2182 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2374 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. PERMANENT
FINANCE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2374.
DLSC ESTIMATES A MINIMUM FISCAL
IMPACT OF 3.4 MILLION FROM THE
LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR, AND 3.3
MILLION ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL.
THIS ESTIMATE DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE COST OF POTENTIAL LITIGATION
CONCERNING THE SCOPE AND INTENT
OF THE BILL, AND FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES SIGNIFICANT COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET, AND
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
FILED TO DLC, WHICH IS FACING AN
EXISTING WAGE CLAIM BACKLOG.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2374 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2408 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. SORRY FOR
ME WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS IN
SUPPORT ALONG WITH NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY. PEEPS CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH MOMS
ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY. YARD
SMART MARIN GRANDPARENTS TAKING
ACTION, SONOMA SAS, CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE AND BEYOND
PESTICIDES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT BUT IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, NO FILE,
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2408 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2475 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT AND PROUD
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2475.
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS ESTIMATES COST BETWEEN
2.8 MILLION AND 4.7 MILLION,
RESULTING FROM EXTENDED STAYS,
EXCUSE ME OF OFFENDERS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS, WITH
FISCAL IMPACT DEPENDENT ON THE
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL DAYS STAYED
IN HOSPITAL BEYOND THE CURRENT
FIVE DAYS PERMITTED IN STATUTE D,
DSH ALSO NOTES THERE MAY BE A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL BEDS FROM
THE EXTENDED STAYS. IF THE
ADDITIONAL STAYS CANNOT BE
ABSORBED BY THEIR CURRENT BED
CAPACITY. NOTWITHSTANDING THE
MERITS OF THE BILL, FINANCE IS
OPPOSED BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND IMPACTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2475 WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
AB 2629 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2629.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES THE COST OF
$70,000. GENERAL FUND. IN 24, 25
AND 186,000 GENERAL FUND IN 2526
TO MODIFY VARIOUS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY APPLICATIONS. AND
WHILE THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL IS
GENERALLY CONSIDERED APPROPRIATE
UNDER THE DEALER'S RECORD OF
SALE, SPECIAL ACCOUNT, DOJ NOTES
THAT CURRENT SPECIAL ACCOUNT
REVENUES ARE INSUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE COSTS OF THIS BILL.
THEREFORE, THE GENERAL FUND IS
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET. NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2629 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. NOW. AB 3061 HAS BEEN
CONTINUED TO ANOTHER DAY, SO WE
MOVE ON TO AB 3190 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE,
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3190 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2149 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION. IN
OPPOSITION. CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE PLACER COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SHARON GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REC AND PARK
DISTRICTS, AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
BOTH WITHIN, OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY
ELSE? DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2149.
FINANCE DOES CONCUR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS, DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION'S
ESTIMATE THAT THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO UPDATE ABOUT 2500 GATES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PARK SYSTEM
TO MEET THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS,
THE BILL IS ENACTED ANY COST,
THE STATE PARKS WILL BE REVIEWED
AS PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. FINANCE
ANTICIPATES THIS BILL MAY CREATE
A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A NEW
PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE GATES AT K-12
SCHOOLS AND IN LOCAL PARKS MEET
THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS.
THEREFORE, WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS,
NOT IN THE 2024 NOT INCLUDED IN
THE 2024 BUDGET, AND A POTENTIAL
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE ON K-12 SCHOOLS AND
OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES. NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL. IS THE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2149 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2416 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT. CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN
OPPOSITION, PERMANENT FINANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2416,
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES COST OF
241,000 OUT OF THE INSURANCE
FUND IN 2526, 986,000 IN 2627,
AND 1.288 MILLION IN 2728, AND
ONGOING FOR POSITIONS TO FILL
THE BILL REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION CAL
FIRE ESTIMATES COSTS OF 240,000
AT A LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION
FUND IN 2526, 473,026, 27 AND
453,000IN 27 AND 28. FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AT CAL FIRE.
ALSO, I'M SORRY OF THIS AMOUNT.
CAL FIRE ALSO ESTIMATES TRAVEL
COSTS OF $20,000 AND 2627 TO
CONDUCT TRAININGS ON THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
REGULATIONS AND TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL PRESENTATIONS TO
STAKEHOLDERS. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2416 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2968 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT.
CHLORPHENAMINE WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALONG WITH
FACTS. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY,
PEEPS AND CA AND GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2968
BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
ONE TIME AND ONGOING PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND COSTS RANGING
FROM 2.4 TO 8.4 MILLION FOR
SPECIFIED SCHOOLS TO COMPLY WITH
DEFENSIBLE SPACE STANDARDS AND
TO COORDINATE PROCEDURES AND
DEVELOP SPECIFIED COMMUNICATIONS
AND EVACUATION PLANS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL COULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH COSTS IN THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS TO POTENTIALLY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND. BY REQUIRING
SCHOOLS TO UPDATE THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS TO INCLUDE THE EVACUATION
PROCEDURES. ADDITIONALLY, THIS
BILL MAY CREATE COSTS FOR LOCAL
FIRE AGENCIES TO ANNUALLY VERIFY
SCHOOL COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. IT'S A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2968 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2231 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ. FILE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
2231 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
2816 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON,
WHO IS WAIVE PRESENTATION IN
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2816
BECAUSE TO THE EXTENT THAT AN
APPROPRIATION IS PROVIDED FOR
THE GRANT PROGRAM, THE BILL
CREATES SIGNIFICANT UNBUDGETED
ONE TIME PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES IN THE
MILLIONS TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES, AND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF UP TO 4.6 MILLION
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM. FINANCE DOES NOTE THAT
THESE COSTS MAY BE HIGH OR LOW,
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ALREADY HAVE
THEIR SCHOOL SITES MAPPED TO
MEET THE BILL REQUIREMENTS AND
HOW MANY LEAS WOULD APPLY FOR A
GRANT FROM THIS PROGRAM. THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS MAY ALSO BE
DUPLICATIVE, DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING SCHOOL SAFETY PLANNING
EFFORTS, NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2816 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 2975 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON, WHO WAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED. AB 2975. THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE TOTAL
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AND THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD IS
ESTIMATED TO BE 344,000 FROM THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR, AND
$323,000 AFTERWARD. ONGOING
ANNUALLY. FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON THE BILL. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2975 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2984 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 2984,
BECAUSE IT DOES INCREASE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS BY UP TO
THREE YEARS FOR A CRIME. WHEN A
DRIVER OF A VEHICLE FLEES THE
SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT THAT CAUSED
DEATH OR PERMANENT SERIOUS
INJURY, AND IS EVADING
PROSECUTION OUT OF THE STATE.
BUT DOES NOTE CONCERN THAT THE
BILL IMPOSES ADDITIONAL STRAIN
ON THE STATE PRISON AND LOCAL
JAIL POPULATIONS, AND LOCAL
COURT SYSTEMS, WHICH COULD
CREATE COST PRESSURES ON THE
STATE BUDGET. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2984. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON. TO. AB 2237 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DOESN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD NOTE
BASED ON THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
FINANCES, PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES
ARE PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES THAT
THIS BILL WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN
PROPOSITION 30 STATE MANDATED
COSTS OF AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT,
POTENTIALLY IN THE LOW MILLIONS
TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO
COUNTIES FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE DATA AND
INFORMATION SHARING REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRED BY THE BILL. COSTS MAY
VARY WIDELY DEPENDING ON HOW
COST MODIFY THEIR CURRENT OR I'M
SORRY, HOW COUNTIES MODIFY THEIR
CURRENT PROCESSES OR SYSTEMS TO
COMPLY WITH THE UPDATED
STANDARDIZED NOTIFICATION AND
INFORMATION SHARING REQUIREMENTS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IT'S A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2237 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2286 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IN
SUPPORT CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE
THIS, NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2286 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2514 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ. FILE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2514 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2901 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IN SUPPORT ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2901,
WHILE THE BILL PROPOSES A
LAUDABLE GOAL OF PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL MATERNITY LEAVE
BENEFIT FOR SPECIFIED EMPLOYEES,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT LIKELY CREATES
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLION
DOLLARS, TO THE EXTENT THAT
PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYERS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
WOULD NEED TO HIRE SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS AND TEMPORARY HELP. IF
EMPLOYEES UTILIZE THE 14 WEEKS
OF PAID LEAVE. THE BILL ALSO
IMPOSES COST PRESSURES FOR
CALSTRS, WHICH MAY LEAD TO AN
IMPACT ON CONTRIBUTION RATES.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2901 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE, MOVING ON TO AB 2247
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. THERE'S NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2247 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. NEXT UP AB 2277 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, TESTIMONY
AND SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2277.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
INDICATES THIS BILL COULD CREATE
ONGOING PROPOSITION 98 COSTS, OR
COST PRESSURES OF UP TO 274.3
MILLION FOR DISTRICTS TO OFFER
HEALTH INSURANCE BENEFITS FOR
ADJUNCT FACULTY, THE EXACT COST
OR COST PRESSURES COULD VARY
SUBSTANTIALLY DEPENDING UPON THE
EXACT NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
FACULTY WHO WOULD QUALIFY FOR
EMPLOYER SPONSORED HEALTH
INSURANCE, AND HOW MANY EXISTING
PART TIME FACULTY ARE CURRENTLY
ACCESSING HEALTH CARE FROM THE
DISTRICT THROUGH THE PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM. THEREFORE, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND COSTS OR COST
PRESSURES THAT COULD RANGE FROM
THE TENS OF MILLIONS TO HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. NØ
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2277 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2678 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALLACE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO. PHÐ AGAIN, THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2678 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2248 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT? THANK
YOU. IT'S LATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2248 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3064 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCHIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3064.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF 64,000
GENERAL FUND AND 51,000 FIREARM
SAFETY ACCOUNT IN 2425, 221,000
GENERAL FUND AND 78,000 FROM
FIREARM SAFETY ACCOUNT IN 25,
26, 79,000 GENERAL FUND AND
39,000 FIREARM SAFETY ACCOUNT
26, 27 AND $8,000 GENERAL FUND
ONGOING. THESE RESOURCES WOULD
SUPPORT ONE POSITION IN OVERTIME
TO UPDATE THE FIREARM SAFETY
DEVICES REGULATION TO REFLECT
THE FEE REQUIREMENTS AND NEW FEE
STRUCTURE, AND FOR THE IT
MODIFICATIONS. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN COSTS, NOT IN THE
2024 BUDGET. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
3064 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2298 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? CHLOE
FREEMAN WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS IN
SUPPORT, ALONG WITH FOX NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS AND CA AND
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FILE.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2298 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 30 AB 2322
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FILE. AGAIN, THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2322 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2308 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? CHLOE FREEMAN WITH
CLEANER FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT
ALONG WITH FOX NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO AND STANDING
UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ. FILE
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2308 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2316 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? CHLOE
FREEMAN WITH CLEANER FOR KIDS
AND SUPPORT ALONG WITH FACTS.
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND CA
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
MOMS ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY.
JAAN SMITH, MARTIN, GRANDPARENTS
TAKING ACTION, SONOMA SAS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE
AND BEYOND PESTICIDES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON AN AB 2316. HOWEVER,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL
COULD CREATE UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98. GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
INCREASE THE CURRENT STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR SCHOOL
MEALS. THIS IS BECAUSE
PROHIBITING CERTAIN SYNTHETIC
FOOD DYES WILL LIKELY
NECESSITATE THE SCHOOLS FIND NEW
FOOD ITEMS, NEW VENDORS, OR
ALTERNATIVE FORMULATIONS OF
EXISTING FOODS OR BEVERAGES THAT
COULD BE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
CURRENT OPTIONS. THIS ESTIMATE
ASSUMES THIS ESTIMATE ASSUMES 4
TO 5% OF THE $1.8 BILLION
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATED TO SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY USED TO ACQUIRE FOOD
THAT CONTAINS SYNTHETIC FOOD
DYES. IN ACQUIRING ALTERNATIVE
FOODS OR CONTRACTING WITH NEW
VENDORS COULD INCREASE FOOD
COSTS BY 0.5 TO 1%, FOR A TOTAL
ESTIMATED ROUGH COST OF 400 TO
$900,000. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2316 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2331 BY ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS WAIVED A
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2331.
THE STATE A STATE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD, ESTIMATES THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILL'S
REQUIREMENT TO BE 3.4 MILLION
FROM THE COST OF IMPLEMENTATION
ACCOUNT IN 25, 26, AND 2.4
MILLION FROM THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT IN 2627,
AND ONGOING FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT FISCAL PLAN, AND
BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE A
BOTTLENECK IN COMPLIANCE. OFFSET
CREDIT SUPPLY FOR THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM, AND REQUIRE CARB
TO REEVALUATE OFFSET SUPPLY AND
ITS IMPACT ON OUR CLIMATE GOALS,
WHICH CREATE COST PRESSURES. NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES OR
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2331 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2455 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MARK èC, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES PROUD SPONSORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO. FOR
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 2455 WILL MOVE TO
A SUSPENSE. NEXT UP IS 2550 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2550.
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION ANTICIPATES
COST UP TO 253,000 FOR THE
BUILDING STANDARDS
ADMINISTRATION SPECIAL REVOLVING
FUND, AND ONE POSITION ANNUALLY
FOR THREE YEARS TO IMPLEMENT
THESE REGULATIONS IN THE NEXT
CODE CYCLE. THERE ALSO MAY BE
ADDITIONAL UNKNOWN COSTS FOR
CONSULTANTS, AS CPSC DOES NOT
HAVE EXPERTISE IN REGULATIONS
FOR RETAIL FOOD ESTABLISHMENTS.
HOWEVER, FINANCE DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WILL CREATE
A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT REQUIRE A
NEW PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE BE PROVIDED TO LOCAL
AGENCIES. HOWEVER, FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
DOES CREATE NEW COST PRESSURES
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT AND REQUIRES CPSC TO CPSC TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS OUTSIDE OF
ITS TYPICAL SCOPE. NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FOR
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2550 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2728 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO FILE. WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2780. 2728 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2899 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2899,
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES COST OF
1.6 MILLION TOTAL ACROSS 24, 25
AND 2526 1,000,026 27, 1.1
MILLION AND 2728, AND 665,000
ONGOING FROM THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION FUND AND STAFF
SUPPORT FOR IT INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING TO CREATE AND MAINTAIN
AN INTERNAL DATABASE TO STORE
BARGAINING AND COMPLAINT
INFORMATION. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT HAS COSTS
THAT ARE NOT REFLECTED IN THE
STATE'S FISCAL PLAN, AND MAY
PLACE STRESS ON THE LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION FUND. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2899 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. ÁP 3160 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO FILE. WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3160. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
2317 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
HER BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2317.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WILL LIKELY INCUR
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO CREATE THIS POLICY,
AND PROVIDE ONGOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE, THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES 176,000 GENERAL FUND
IN 24, 25 AND 185,000 GENERAL
FUND AND 2526 TO COMPLETE
REQUIRED WORKLOAD FROM THE BILL.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2317 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2992 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2992.
THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE
ESTIMATES TOTAL COST OF 871,000
FROM REAL ESTATE FUND, AND 2526,
829,026, 27 AND 685,027, 28 AND
ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL OF
FINANCE DOES NOT ANTICIPATE THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. HOWEVER,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN COST OF
THE REAL ESTATE FUND NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET. THE
COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2992 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2335
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCE IS CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO AB 2335.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
STATE. IF CALIFORNIA. IF CAL H.R
IDENTIFIES EXISTING COMPENSATION
GAPS FOR STATE EMPLOYEES. FOR
ILLUSTRATIVE PURPOSES, A 1%
INCREASE IN ANNUAL COMPENSATION
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES WOULD RESULT
IN COSTS OF $368 MILLION, OF
WHICH 179 MILLION WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT MAY
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FISCAL PLAN AND ELIMINATES THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE
SALARY INCREASES FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 2335 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2561 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE,
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION, AND THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE COUNTIES OF
VENTURA AND COLUSA COUNTY ALL
OPPOSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING. I'M ERIC LA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING, MADAM CHAIR.
AARON AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SHARON
GONSALVES, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICTS, AS WELL AS THE CITIES
OF BAKERSFIELD, BEAUMONT,
CARLSBAD, CORONA AND RANCHO
CUCAMONGA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR BUTTE DEL NORTE,
FRESNO, HUMBOLDT, KERN, KINGS,
MERCED, SAN LUIS OBISPO, SHASTA
AND SOLANO, ALL IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEN ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2561.
FINANCE ANTICIPATES THIS BILL
MAY RESULT IN UNKNOWN AND
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST TO
LOCAL PUBLIC ENTITIES WITH HIGH
VACANCY RATES. WHILE THIS BILL
SPECIFIES THAT IT DOES NOT
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSEMENT
MANDATE, FINANCE ANTICIPATES
THAT THIS BILL'S REQUIREMENT
THAT LOCAL PUBLIC ENTITIES MEET
AND CONFER WITH EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS MAY CONSTITUTE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE,
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST TO
THE STATE. FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL, WHICH MAY CREATE A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT,
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE AND REQUIRES LOCAL
PUBLIC ENTITIES TO MEET WITH
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS OVER
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS HIGH
VACANCY RATES OUTSIDE OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2561 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 2780 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2780 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
2355 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2355 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2383 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2383.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES ANNUAL
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LICENSING CERTIFICATION
FUND COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY 25
OR 257,524 25 446,025 26,
446,000 2627, 375,527 28,
280,028 29 AND ONGOING AT THE
TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS, THE
FISCAL ESTIMATE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT,
EXCUSE ME, AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES, WAS NOT
AVAILABLE. HOWEVER, THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS TO DEVELOP A
TRAINING PROGRAM WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST TO IMPLEMENT, SO
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND IMPACTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2383 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2986 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? BILL. BUT
IN OPPOSITION, AN OPPOSITION
PARTY ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2986.
THIS BILL MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES A NEW PROGRAM, HIGHER
LEVEL OF SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED
BY LOCAL AGENCIES, SPECIFICALLY
BY REQUIRING THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES TO DEVELOP A REPORT AS
SPECIFIED. THIS BILL MAY CREATE
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE OF
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS. GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME. THEREFORE, THE
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2986 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2360 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2360.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY 21 MILLION TO
EXPAND THE CURRENT FAMILY
WELLNESS PILOT PROGRAM TO
FAMILIES OF ALL REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS. THREE YEARS OR
YOUNGER IN 24, 25 AND ONGOING.
THIS ESTIMATE IS BASED ON THE
CURRENT FAMILY WELLNESS PILOT
PROGRAM COST OF APPROXIMATELY 1
MILLION ANNUALLY PER REGIONAL
CENTER, 21 OF THEM STATEWIDE, TO
SERVE A SMALL GROUP OF FAMILIES
OF CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
THREE. DSS ALSO ANTICIPATES
ANNUAL COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
318,000, OF WHICH 254,000 IS
GENERAL FUND FOR TWO POSITIONS
TO ASSIST IN IMPLEMENTATION.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL,
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE FAMILY
WELLNESS PILOT PROGRAM AT ALL
REGIONAL CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2360 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
AB. THE NEXT IS AB 2696 BY
SPEAKER EMERITUS RENDON, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO,
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? FINANCE. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS CURRENTLY NEUTRAL
ON AB 2696. AS ON THE BILLS, IT
IS NOT EXPECTED TO CREATE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE COSTS. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2696 WILL WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2757
BY SPEAKER EMERITUS AT 2754. I'M
SORRY. WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, IT'S AGAIN AB
2754, IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2754.
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COST OF 2.2
MILLION FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
IN 25, 26 AND $2 MILLION FROM
THE LABEL ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND IN 2627 AND
ONGOING TO ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALSO NOTES
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT HAS AN EXISTING WAGE
CLAIM BACKLOG, AND THIS BILL
WOULD INCREASE THAT BACKLOG.
THEREFORE, FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET AND COULD INCREASE THE
EXISTING WAGE CLAIM BACKLOG.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2754 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2834 AGAIN BY
SPEAKER EMERITUS RENDON, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2834.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
DOES INDICATE MINOR ONE TIME
STATE OPERATION COSTS FOR
LIMITED WORKLOAD TO ISSUE TO
ISSUE, DEFINE THE TERM BULLETIN
OF COURSES AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE BILL WOULD
CREATE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY TO UPDATE CLASS
SCHEDULES AND BULLETINS, AND TO
IMPLEMENT A CLASS CANCELLATION
PAY AND NOTICE POLICY THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE BILL. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2834 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2423 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT AN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2423.
FISCAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ANNUAL SERVICE PROVIDER RATE
MODEL ADJUSTMENTS ARE UNKNOWN.
HOWEVER, THEY ARE LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT BASED ON RECENT
HISTORICAL TRENDS OF 10 TO 15%.
INCREASES IN PURCHASE OF SERVICE
COSTS, AND ACCOUNTING FOR
CASELOAD AND UTILIZATION
PROJECTIONS, DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
COST PRESSURES OF AT LEAST 1.3
BILLION, OF WHICH 896.3 MILLION
IS GENERAL FUND TO 2 BILLION, OF
WHICH 1.3 BILLION IS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY AND 2526 AND
ONGOING FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2423 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2818 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2818.
WE WOULD NOTE THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
INDICATES NO FISCAL IMPACT FROM
THE BILL BECAUSE THEY WOULD NOT
INSPECT FOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT APPEARS TO
DUPLICATE DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING LAW REGARDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, AND IT MAY
CREATE NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS
THROUGH A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE ON COUNTY JAILS.
ALTHOUGH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY
ALREADY BE INCURRING COSTS AT
THEIR OWN DISCRETION, THIS BILL
WOULD REMOVE THE LOCAL AGENCY'S
DISCRETION AND IMPOSE
REQUIREMENTS INCURRED MANDATED
COSTS. SO IT IS UNKNOWN WHAT THE
FISCAL COST WOULD BE FOR THE
LOCAL SERVICE AGENCIES RECEIVING
REFERRALS FROM COUNTY JAILS, NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2818 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2452
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2452, AS
IT WOULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF 78.6 MILLION IN 2425
AND 157.2 MILLION ONGOING
BEGINNING IN 2526 FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
PROVIDE THE ADVANCED MONTHLY
TRANSPORTATION PAYMENT, THE
FISCAL PAYMENT ASSUMES ALL
WELFARE TO WORK. PARTICIPANTS
WILL RECEIVE A MINIMUM 200
MONTHLY ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION
PAYMENT, WITH THE OPTION TO
REQUEST REIMBURSEMENT FOR ACTUAL
COSTS ABOVE THE $200 2425 COSTS.
ASSUME IMPLEMENTATION ON JANUARY
1ST, 2025, AND REPRESENT A SIX
MONTH IMPACT. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT EXPANDS
CALWORKS PROGRAM BENEFITS AND
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
2024 BUDGET. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
2452 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND AB
2555 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2555,
WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE OF
THE USE OF TAX EXEMPTION FOR
DONATED MEDICINAL CANNABIS FROM
MARCH 1ST, 2025 TO JANUARY 1ST,
2030, AND REQUIRES EXEMPTION TO
COMPLY WITH REVENUE AND TAX CODE
SECTION 41 REQUIREMENTS. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL DUE TO ITS
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON STATE
REVENUES AND CURRENTLY
MAINTAINING A STRUCTURAL BALANCE
OF THE STATE BUDGET IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE THAT WILL
REQUIRE WEIGHING THE ADDITIONAL
COSTS OF THIS TAX EXEMPTION WITH
OTHER COMPETING BUDGET
PRIORITIES. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2555 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3150 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. THERE IS NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3150 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2462
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. EXCUSE ME,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CALDERON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CALDERON HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2462.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ESTIMATES COSTS OF
400,001 TIME AND 50,000 ONGOING
FROM THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT TO DEVELOP
AND INCORPORATE THE SPECIFIED
RECOMMENDATIONS AND
CONSIDERATIONS IN THE ANNUAL
REPORT. FINANCE IS OPPOSED
BECAUSE THE RESULTS AND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS, SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2462 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2494 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON AB 2494
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYEES NOTICE THAT
THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR COBRA
WITHOUT CREATING STATE COSTS.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2494 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2752 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT AN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2752. THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND
FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS WAS
REALIGNED TO THE COUNTIES AS
PART OF THE 20 2011 PUBLIC
SAFETY REALIGNMENT, AND PURSUANT
TO PROPOSITION 30, WHICH WAS
APPROVED BY VOTERS IN NOVEMBER
20TH 20 OR 2012. WHILE THE
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION RELATED
TO VISITATIONS REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL IS ALREADY PART OF CURRENT
COUNTY PRACTICE IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT. THEREFORE, COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED BY THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS. THEREFORE,
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET ACT. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2752 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2777 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2777.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ANTICIPATES COSTS OF
UP TO 805,000 GENERAL FUND AND
THREE POSITIONS ANNUALLY TO
ESTABLISH BASELINE INFORMATION
SECURITY SCORE METRICS AND
ANNUALLY EVALUATE STATE AND
ENTITIES BASELINE INFORMATION
SECURITY SCORE FINANCE IS
OPPOSED THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN NEW GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024
BUDGET ACT, AND IS DUPLICATIVE
OF EXISTING PROGRAMS WITHIN K¾T.
THE COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2777 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. REMEMBER, WE TOOK UP
AB 2872. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
OVER THAT BECAUSE IT IS DONE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2958 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE ON THAT BILL THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 2958. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ANTICIPATES THIS
BILL WILL HAVE AN ANNUAL FISCAL
IMPACT OF 556,000. AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND TO PAY THE SALARIES
AND BENEFITS OF THE SIX AIR
DISTRICT MEMBERS OF THE BOARD,
WHICH IS BASED ON THE CURRENT
YEAR SALARY FOR A NON-DISTRICT
MEMBER OF 55,738, THE SALARY
WILL INCREASE WHENEVER STATE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE GENERAL PAY
INCREASE INCREASES FINANCE. AS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL, AS IT
CREATES ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES ON THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND, WHICH IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AND WILL EXACERBATE THIS
FUND STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE. WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2958 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3030 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT AN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3030. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PRELIMINARILY ESTIMATES COSTS
FROM THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION FUND RANGING FROM
382 TO 818,024 25 AND ONGOING
COSTS OF 656,000 TO 1.5 MILLION
ANNUALLY FROM AND 6 TO 8
POSITIONS, TO CONDUCT ON SITE
SURVEYS. FACILITY FOR FACILITY
COMPLIANCE CDPH ESTIMATES ASSUME
THAT 40 TO 80% OF FACILITIES
WILL EVENTUALLY USE GENERATIVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT HAS COSTS THAT ARE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN AND ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
MAY PLACE STRESS ON THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION
FUND, AND CONSIDERATIONS MUST BE
GIVEN TO THE IMBALANCE THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN PROVIDED FEDERAL
FUNDS AND ACTUAL WORKLOAD. THE
COMMITTEE DOES NOT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, AND THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, ÁP 3030 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ÁP 3111 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3111.
THE. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL IS
115,000 FROM THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT
ONGOING AND ONE PERMANENT
POSITION TO COLLECT AND SHARE
THE INFORMATION REQUIRED. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT EACH OF THE
SIX MAIN OPERATING ACCOUNT IS IN
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT, AND
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES FROM
ARPA WILL ACCELERATE THE
ACCOUNT. THE ACCOUNTS.
INSOLVENCY. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ALSO
ESTIMATES THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL IS 179,000 FROM
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION,
UTILITY REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT
ONGOING, AND ONE POSITION TO
DEVELOP REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3111 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3193 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT? TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3193.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES ANTICIPATES COSTS UP TO
742,000 TO SUPPORT FIVE
POSITIONS ANNUALLY FOR FIVE
YEARS UNTIL THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL END IN 2030. THESE
POSITIONS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PRODUCE AND COLLABORATE WITH DOR
AND ANNUAL REPORTING AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY, DGS ANTICIPATES
ONE TIME BUT UNKNOWN OR I'M
SORRY ANTICIPATES ONE TIME BUT
UNKNOWN COST TO MODIFY THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE THE NEW
REPORTING CRITERIA. FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN FISCAL IMPACTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
ADDITIONALLY, THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVE AND EXISTING
ADMINISTRATIVE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
THAT COULD HELP STREAMLINE THE
POSITIONS OF ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES AND REDUCE
PROCUREMENT DELAYS. CURRENTLY,
ALREADY IN PLACE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3193 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3263 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT PROVIDED IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FILE. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2363. WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. REMEMBER, WE
CONTINUED THE NEXT ITEM, WHICH
IS AB 2498. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
AB 2525 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF
BR WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ. FILE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2525 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2613 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2613.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF 371,024 25,
649,000 FROM 2526 TO 2728, AND
371,028 29 TO SUPPORT THREE
POSITIONS WHO WILL COORDINATE
AND ADMINISTER THE COUNCIL'S
OPERATIONS. FINANCE ESTIMATES.
THE BILL'S ACTIVITIES WOULD
RESULT IN MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
GENERAL FUND COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. FINANCE, HOWEVER, IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT. NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2613 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2704 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZUBIR, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2704.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
REQUIRE $6 MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND 2425 AND ONGOING TO COVER
THE COST OF THE BACKGROUND CHECK
FEE WAIVER FOR PROVIDERS AND
CONDUCT BACKGROUND CHECKS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE $6,535 FROM THE
FINGERPRINT FEES ACCOUNT FOR 140
TEMPORARY HELP HOURS AND FOUR
WEEKS OF SUPPORT FROM AN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATE
TO REMOVE THE CURRENT DOJ FEE
CHARGE TO THE TIME OF
FINGERPRINTING, WE WOULD NOTE
THE BILL WOULD NOT LIKELY CREATE
A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND
THE FINANCE ESTIMATES. THE BILL
HAS NO FISCAL IMPACT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
HOWEVER, WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES A NEW
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
STATE TO COVER BACKGROUND CHECK
COSTS AND RESULTS IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. 36 NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 20 704 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 2889 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF BR WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY A NEUTRAL ON AB 2889.
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD ESTIMATES THE COST OF THE
STATE PER INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
RELIEF REQUEST TO BE 60,000. IN
ATTORNEY TIME, AND EXPECTS 1 TO
2 SUCH REQUESTS FROM THE CITY OR
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES PER YEAR,
RESULTING IN AN ANNUAL WORKLOAD
COST OF 60 TO 120,000. OUR
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
DESPITE THE INCREASED WORKLOAD,
AS IT PROMOTES CONSISTENT
TREATMENT OF EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FOR ALL
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2889 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2907 BY ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS OF BORE WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2907.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST ESTIMATES, COST
OF 552,000 GENERAL FUND AND 24,
25 AND 649,025 26 AND ONGOING
FOR POSITIONS TO COVER THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL,
FINANCE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
BILL ALSO MIGHT CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE, AND THAT
REQUEST FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SHOULD BE EVALUATED
THROUGH THE BUDGET DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. THEREFORE, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET
AND MAY RESULT IN STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND FISCAL
PRESSURE ON THE COURT, STATE
PRISON AND COUNTY JAIL SYSTEMS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, AND THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2907 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2917 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CASSANDRA WHETSTONE, VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OPPOSES AB 2917. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF 76,000, GENERAL FUND IN
24, 25 AND 125,025 26, AND
ONGOING FOR ONE POSITION TO
ADDRESS WORKER WORKLOAD RELATED
TO THE INCREASE IN PROHIBITION
TRIGGERING EVENTS IN THE ARMED
PROHIBITED PERSONS UNIT, AND
OVER OVERTIME COSTS RELATED TO
PROCESSING AND INCREASE IN
ARREST. PRINCE FINANCE DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE. HOWEVER,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL, FINANCE IS OPPOSED
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET, THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 20 2917 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. WE ALREADY DID AB
2918, SO WE'LL MOVE PAST THAT
ONE ON TO THE NEXT BILL, WHICH
IS AB, 33,006 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF BR, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? UP
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO AB 3006. THE BILL WOULD
CREATE ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF UP TO 500,000 FROM
MULTIPLE STATE ENTITIES, FROM
VARIOUS FUNDING SOURCES. THE
STATE ENTITIES AFFECTED INCLUDE
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH,
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION,
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, STATE LANDS
COMMISSION, AND THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
FINANCE NOTES THAT ANY RESOURCES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE
WOULD BE EVALUATED THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3006 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2534
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORES, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
AN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2534,
BECAUSE IT WILL LIKELY CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE WITH
ONGOING PROPOSITION 98. GENERAL
FUND COST IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TO LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, DEPENDING ON HOW MANY
TEACHERS LEAVE THEIR TEACHING
POSITION FOR A TEACHING POSITION
AT ANOTHER LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY OR STATE SPECIAL SCHOOL
IN A GIVEN YEAR, AND HOW MUCH
TIME A SCHOOL EMPLOYEE MUST
SPEND INQUIRING WITH PAST
EMPLOYERS REGARDING INSTANCES OF
MISCONDUCT. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2534 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 2578 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY
AND SUPPORT CHRIS KHN
REPRESENTING NIGHTINGALE
COLLEGE, THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2578.
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
ESTIMATES. EXCUSE ME.
UNOBSERVABLE COSTS OF 1.189
MILLION FROM THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING FUND IN 2526
AND 1.176 MILLION IN 2627
ONGOING FOR FIVE OFFICE
TECHNICIANS TO CREATE NEW
PROFILES IN THE BREEZY FOR 3000
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN COST TO
THE FIRM THAT WILL NOT BE
RECOVERED BY REVENUES COLLECTED
FROM THE FEE ESTABLISHED IN THE
BILL, AND IT IS. IN ADDITION,
THE BILL MAY INCREASE BARRIERS
TO ENTRY FOR STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN CALIFORNIA REGULATED SCHOOLS
AND MAY INCREASE THE RISK OF
CONSUMER AND PATIENT HARM. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2578 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE'LL BE ON TO
AB 2564 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERNER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IN ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
FINANCE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2564,
WHICH REQUIRES THE STATE
COMPTROLLER TO TRANSFER THE
AMOUNT NECESSARY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE SENIOR
CITIZENS AND DISABLED CITIZENS.
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT FUND
OR PTP FUND. ON JANUARY OR JUNE
30TH, 2025. IN EACH FISCAL YEAR
THEREAFTER TO ENSURE THE FUNDS
BALANCE IS NEVER LESS THAN $15
MILLION. FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE 2024 BUDGET. THE 2024
BUDGET ACT DID PROVIDE A
TRANSFER OF 7.5 MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO THE PTP FUND, WHICH IS
ESTIMATED TO COVER THE COST OF
NEW APPLICANTS AND PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION INTO 2526. GIVEN
THE STATE'S ONGOING STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT, FUTURE RESOURCES
PROVIDED THIS PROGRAM SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED ALONG WITH OTHER
BUDGET FUND PRIORITIES DURING
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2564 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2666 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF HER BILL? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION FINANCE?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2666.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL IS
2.896 MILLION. IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION, AND 2.803
MILLION ONGOING FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT COST COVER
12 PERMANENT POSITIONS TO REVIEW
THE IOUS RATE OF RETURN, ACTUAL
COST, AND ADJUST PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED GENERAL RATE CASE
DECISIONS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS,
THE PUC LARA REVENUE IS
GENERATED FROM A SURCHARGE ON
UTILITY BILLS, AND THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN INCREASED COSTS TO
RIGHT RATE PAYERS TO GENERATE
ADEQUATE REVENUE TO COVER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. SO FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THE BILLS THAT
RESULTS IN COSTS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET AND
MIGHT RESULT IN ADDITIONAL FEES
ON CONSUMERS. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2666 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2692
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF HER
BILL? TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED. AB 2692. THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ESTIMATE COSTS OF 25.7 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND 2425, 54.3
MILLION AND 2526, AND 72.5
MILLION AND 2627 AND ONGOING
BASED ON FUTURE PROJECTED
CASELOADS. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
MAY CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A
NEW PROGRAM OF HIGHER LEVEL
SERVICES PROVIDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. IN ADDITION, Ã
FINANCE ALSO NOTES THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN ONGOING PROPOSITION 30
STATE MANDATE COSTS OF AN
UNKNOWN GENERAL FUND AMOUNT TO
COUNTIES FOR INCREASED INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DURING THE DIVERSION
EXTENSION PERIOD, AND
POTENTIALLY FOR COUNTIES TO
INCARCERATE PEOPLE DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL UNTIL
THEY CAN ENTER TREATMENT.
PROGRAM FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET.
IN ADDITION TO POTENTIALLY A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND
IMPACT THROUGH PROPOSITION 30,
STATE MANDATE COSTS, THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL. IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2692 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
3023 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3223.
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES THE BILL
REQUIRES TWO PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND 1.05 MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND 25, 26 AND 2627 FOR
REGULATION, DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
UPDATES AND ADDITIONAL SCOPING
AND DEVELOPMENT OF CONSOLIDATED
APPLICATIONS. ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS ARE ESTIMATED BETWEEN
1 AND 4 MILLION TO SUPPORT STAFF
COSTS AND IT DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT. DEPARTMENT OF FIRE AND
FORESTRY PROTECTION ESTIMATES
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE 200,000
GENERAL FUND AND 25, 26 AND 2627
TO FIRE OR TO HIRE CONSULTANTS
IN ADDITION, THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES ESTIMATES THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE UP TO 200,000
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN ADDITIONAL COSTS. NOT NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE 2024
BUDGET. AGAIN, THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, AND SO, WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 3023 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3220 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 3220.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IS REQUIRED TO
REVIEW PROJECT APPLICATIONS,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THOSE
PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD TO A STAGE
WHERE FEES CAN BE ASSESSED AND
ANY EXPANSION OF REGULATORY
RESPONSIBILITIES INHERENTLY
CREATES COST PRESSURES TO THE
GENERAL FUND, FINANCE NOTES.
COST PRESSURES SHOULD CDF W
DECIDE TO SEEK AND OBTAIN
FEDERAL AUTHORITY, WHICH WOULD
HAVE UNKNOWN AND LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE STATE
IN ORDER TO COMPLETE REGULATORY
PERMIT REVIEW AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES. THEREFORE, FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT CREATES GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN. NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 3220 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2716
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR KERN
AND MADERA, BOTH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2716.
CAL CHEN ESTIMATES THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE UP TO 35 POSITIONS
AND 7.6 MILLION FROM OIL, GAS
AND GEOTHERMAL ADMINISTRATIVE
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND 7.1 MILLION
FROM THE OGA ONGOING.
ADDITIONALLY, CAL GÒM ESTIMATES
THE PROVISION OF THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN INCREASED STATE
LIABILITY UP TO $1.5 BILLION FOR
THE REMEDIATION OF ORPHAN WELLS,
DEPENDING ON WHETHER IDLE WELLS
ARE CONSIDERED SUBJECT TO THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS. IN ADDITION,
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION NOTES
THE BILL COULD HAVE UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND BY
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
FROM THE LONG BEACH OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
GO TO THE GENERAL FUND.
THEREFORE FINANCE NOTES THAT ANY
REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE SUBJECT TO REVIEW
AND APPROVAL THROUGH THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2716 WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
ON TO AB 3049 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ FILE.
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE. CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3049 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3265 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. AGAIN, THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3265 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON TO AB
2738 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF
US. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? SHE'S WAIVED
PRESENTATION CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEY, DAVID CHU IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2738.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS STATES THAT THIS BILL
WOULD NOT HAVE A DIRECT FISCAL
IMPACT ON THE DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH,
OR THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD, BOTH
WITHIN DIR. BUT THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT ANY PENALTIES
RECOVERED BY PUBLIC PROSECUTORS
FOR VIOLATIONS OF CERTAIN
SECTIONS OF THE LABOR CODE ARE
TO BE SPLIT EVENLY BETWEEN THE
STATE AND PUBLIC PROSECUTOR.
APPROXIMATELY $15 MILLION IS
ANNUALLY DEPOSITED INTO THE
GENERAL FUND FROM LABOR CODE
PENALTY ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO THIS BILL. SO
FINANCE KNOWS THAT THIS BILL
COULD DECREASE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES BY SEVERAL MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY, TO THE EXTENT
THAT PENALTIES WOULD HAVE TO BE
DEPOSITED INTO THE GENERAL FUND
ARE INSTEAD DISTRIBUTED TO
PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. THEREFORE
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT REDUCES GENERAL FUND
REVENUES. YOU HAVE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2738. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2469, BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL ON AB 2469, ALTHOUGH
EXTENSION. EXCUSE ME. ALTHOUGH
EXTENSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE MITIGATION PROGRAM MAY
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS.
FINANCE NOTES THAT CONSISTENT
WITH BUDGET LETTER 24 DASH TEN,
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK
WITH DEPARTMENTS TO MAINTAIN
CORE PROGRAMS THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCIES AND ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT EXTENSION
OF THE CW. EMP PROGRAM WILL BE
CONSIDERED WITHIN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. NO. NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
2469 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2660 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2660.
CAL OES ESTIMATES THIS BILL
ANNUALLY COSTS $16 MILLION FROM
GENERAL FUND ONGOING. THIS
INCLUDES 4.3 MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO BACKFILL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING. FINANCE
IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING LOSS FOR BASELINE
PROGRAMS SUPPORTING STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FUNCTIONS.
THIS WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE 2024 BUDGET TO
BACKFILL THE COST OF OPERATING
AND ADMINISTRATING THESE
PROGRAMS. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2660. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2776 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NØ FILE COMMITTEE
HAS NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN
REGARDS TO THIS. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2776 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2983 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO AB 2983,
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ESTIMATES IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN COSTS OF
1.429 MILLION. GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR THREE ACTUARIES TO
COMPLETE THE REQUIRED RESEARCH
AND ASSESSMENTS, AND AN ATTORNEY
FOR TO REVIEW THE ASSESSMENTS
AND MANAGE INQUIRIES. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL WILL BE INSURED. WILL BE
INSURANCE FUND COSTS OF 35,000
IN YEAR ONE, 133,000 IN YEAR TWO
AND 64,000 IN YEAR THREE. AND
ONGOING FOR INCREASED STAFFING
AND ADMINISTRATION COSTS. SORRY,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE 2425 BUDGET.
THE COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO THIS
BILL AND IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2983 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2817 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DIXON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE
COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO THE BILL,
AND IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2817 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
3156 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? NO FILE. THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENT. YEAH,
RIGHT. I'M THIS EERIE. I CAN'T
HEAR TOO WELL. I CAN'T HEAR. THE
COMMITTEE HAS NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3156 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. NOW, THE ONLY THING I
NEED TO MAKE SURE OF, BECAUSE
THAT CONCLUDES, THE BILLS THAT
WE'RE DOING, OKAY, WE'LL WAIT
JUST A FEW MINUTES BECAUSE WE
WANT TO RECALL THE BILLS THAT WE,
HAD A DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION
FIRST TO MOTION. YES. OKAY.
YOU'RE ALL SET, SENATOR. THANK
YOU. YOU'RE SAID AS WELL. I
THINK YOU'RE SET. GOOD JOB.
OKAY THE SENATE, APPROPRIATION,
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS BACK IN
SESSION. WE HAVE TWO REMAINING
ITEMS BEFORE WE, FINISH TODAY.
AND THAT IS TO LIFT THE
OUTSTANDING CALLS FOR MEMBERS
THAT WERE ABSENT. AND SO, THE
FIRST BILL IS AB 2107 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. MADAM
ASSISTANT, PLEASE, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD I THAT BILL IS OUT 7 TO
0 AND THE NEXT BILL IS AB 3100.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. MADAM
ASSISTANT, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD. I 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT AS WELL. I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING, WE HAD A ROBUST
AND LONG HEARING. WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
MEETING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATION IS ADJOURNED.
10:00 WE STARTED AT TEN.